artificial intelligence or ai
is one of the most trending technologies
of the 21st century
hello everyone welcome to this full
course video on artificial intelligence
in this video we will cover everything
you need to know about ai
our experienced instructors with good
industry experience will take you
through this course
first you will understand the basics of
artificial intelligence from a short
animated video
we will look at the future of ai and
listen to some of the industry experts
such as sundar pichai
jeff bezos and bill gates and learn what
they have to say about ai
you will see the top 10 applications of
ai in 2021
then we'll understand about machine
learning and the different algorithms
used to build ai models
we will get an idea about another core
component of artificial intelligence
that is
deep learning finally we learn the top
10 artificial intelligence technologies
in 2021
so let's begin picture this a machine
that could organize your cupboard
just as you like it or serve every
member of the house a customized cup of
coffee
makes your day easier doesn't it these
are the products of
artificial intelligence but why use the
term
artificial intelligence well these
machines are artificially incorporated
with human-like intelligence
to perform tasks as we do this
intelligence is built using complex
algorithms
and mathematical functions but ai
may not be as obvious as in the previous
examples
in fact ai is used in smartphones cars
social media feeds video games banking
surveillance and many other aspects of
our daily life
the real question is what does an ai
do at its core here is a robot we built
in our lab
which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot
must perform as expected this ability to
react appropriately to a new situation
is called generalized learning the robot
is now at a crossroad one that is paved
and the other
rocky the robot must determine which
path to take
based on the circumstances this portrays
the robot's
reasoning ability after a short stroll
the robot
now encounters a stream that it cannot
swim across
using the plank provided as an input the
robot
is able to cross this stream so our
robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this
is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot
artificially intelligent in short ai
provides machines with the capability to
adapt
reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
an ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai
focuses solely on one task for example
alphago is a maestro of the game go but
you can't expect it to be even remotely
good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai
since it can perform multiple tasks well
that's not really true when you ask
alexa to play despacito
it picks up the keywords play and
despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question
it isn't trained to answer for instance
try asking alexa
the status of traffic from work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information
as she is not trained to and that brings
us to our second category of ai
strong ai now this is much like the
robots that only exist in fiction as of
now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence
different from machine learning and deep
learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique
to achieve ai and deep learning in turn
is a subset of machine learning machine
learning provides a machine with the
capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain
this means through deep learning data
and patterns can be better perceived
ray kurzweil a well-known futurist
predicts that by the year 2045
we would have robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well
that's not all in fact elon musk
predicts that the human mind and body
will be enhanced by ai implants which
would make us
partly cyborgs so here's a question for
you
which of the below ai projects don't
exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship
b a robot with a muscular skeletal
system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below
since the human brain is still a mystery
it's no surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains for now ai is built
to work with humans
and make our tasks easier however
with the maturation of technology we can
only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us
well that is artificial intelligence for
you in short
do not forget to leave your answer to
the quiz in the comment section below
[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
ai as we have been
to specifically target tasks that we
need or want done
in place of ourselves that's how ai
will ultimately unfold it is a
renaissance
it is a golden age we are now solving
problems with machine learning and
artificial intelligence
that were you know kind of in the realm
of science fiction for the last several
decades
ai is probably the most important thing
humanities
has ever worked on and i think of it as
something more profound than electricity
or
fire and anytime you work with
technology
you need to learn to harness the
benefits and
while minimizing the downside
[Music]
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and uh clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars
there are others uh and we sort of see
it as the mother of
all ai projects there's a class of
things like
game plane or speech recognition or
image recognition
that the performance levels are
phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition computer speech recognition
the computer is slightly better and
that's you know
mind blowing certainly we use ai to do
drug discovery these biological systems
are very complicated
and so the fact that we have you know
vaccines for tb
and hiv coming that's partly enabled by
this rich data
advance in biology and machine learning
when i look at seeing ai which is an
application we just launched for anybody
with visual impairment they can go
download this app that uses the latest
cutting edge computer vision technology
in our cloud to give anyone
the ability to see and in fact angela
mills was a colleague of mine was just
telling me about how it's changed her
life
inside of microsoft she can go into our
cafeteria order food using this app with
confidence
walk into conference rooms with
confidence because she knows she's
walking into the right conference room
or what we've done with our onenote and
word learning tools
anyone who has dyslexia can now use
ai to be able to read better the latest
release of windows 10
has this capability called eye gaze
which is something that we learned
working with steve gleason and the als
patients saying if you all you have is
the
eye muscle and the gaze can we help you
type
yeah you have to be careful uh when
there's advances in a sense
we're all better off if if the machines
can make all the food and the clothes
and none of us have to work uh and you
think okay now we have all the freedom
if we
to stand behind the counter and you know
make sandwiches okay you can if you want
but there's this other way to make those
goods and services but it will be
very disruptive uh because you know say
your mid-career
in manufacturing or driving then it's a
disruption
now we've had that in a slow way for
hundreds of years
you know we used to all be farmers now
very few of us are farmers
i said it's right to be concerned
absolutely you have to worry about it
otherwise you're not going to solve it
right and
it's important to understand tomorrow
whether google is there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress
uh you know technology has this nature
it's a it's going to evolve
i think pulling back history shows
pulling back
countries which pull back don't do well
with the change
we know that 20 30 years ago you
educated yourself
and that carried you through for the
rest of your life that is not going to
be true for the generation which is
being born now they have to learn
continuously over their lives
we know that so we have to transform how
we do education
look i think i mean you nailed it
anything that's repetitive and done
you know on the back of you know
technology or
you know is going to be fundamentally
vulnerable yeah
so i think uh technology and in
particular ai
can in fact bring more empowerment more
inclusiveness
and at the same time we should be
clear-eyed about displacement
clear-eyed about unintended consequences
like any other technology
and work both skilling so that
you know people can find the jobs of the
future
create new jobs and uh lastly
i think have a set of policy decisions
uh that really help people
uh as they go through this change
the risks are important and i think the
way we solve it is
we think ahead we worry about it we
do things like from from be upfront uh
you know have ethical charters think
about ai safety from day one
be very transparent and open in how we
perceive progress there
and figure out global frameworks by
which we can engage just like paris
agreement and climate change
you know using forums like this i think
we bring people together
to engage on the hard questions and i
think ansys will emerge
um you know i have exposure to the
very most cutting edge ai
and i think people should be really
concerned about it
um i keep sounding the alarm bell but
you know until people see like robots
going down the street
killing people like they don't know how
to react you know because it seems so
ethereal
and i think we should be really
concerned about ai
and i think we should this ai is a rare
case where i think we need to be
proactive in regulation instead of
reactive
because i think by the time we are
reactive in ai
regulation it's too late right now we
have
machine learning algorithms that can
solve an incredibly complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially
complete idiots and like two-year-olds
and anything that's not that problem
they're dumb like that you can give them
this enormous data set
and they come up with brilliant
correlations and insights but they're
not going to
plug into skynet and you know like like
like threaten us anytime soon
so i'm quite optimistic and
i don't think artificial intelligence
is a threat i don't think that if at
fish intelligence is something
terrible but human beings are smart
enough to learn that
[Music]
hey guys welcome to this simply learn
session on ai applications in 2020
so here's a small refresher about
artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence refers to
intelligence displayed by machines
that simulates human intelligence
basically it's the ability of a machine
or a program to think
and learn now that you're all caught up
let's take a look at how different
domains are using ai
let's have a look at the current market
state of ai
according to atractica a market research
firm the global ai market is expected to
reach a revenue of 118 billion dollars
by
2025. next according to the research
firm
gartner ai usage has grown by 270
percent in the last four years
a clear indication of the growth that's
yet to come in the upcoming years
in fact 87 percent of companies that
actually have adopted ai
were using it to improve email marketing
and in some news that could be positive
or negative depending on how you look at
it
75 countries are now using ai technology
for surveillance
now let's have a look at how artificial
intelligence is used in different
domains
first off ai applications in e-commerce
ai offers you personalized shopping with
ai you have a recommendation engine
through which you can engage better with
your customers
these recommendations are made by taking
into consideration their usage history
their preferences
and interests by providing these
recommendations what you're doing is
basically
improving your relationship with your
customers you are improving
their loyalty towards your brand and by
extension causing an increase in the
number of conversions
with ai you can provide users the
ability to perform
visual searches users can upload an
image of the item they require
search results are shown that match
their query so all of this can be done
without them having to type a single
word
next we have ai powered assistance
assistants like virtual shopping
assistants and chat bots help improve
user experience while shopping online
for this techniques like nlp or natural
language processing
are used to make the conversation sound
as human and personal as possible
did you know that soon customer service
could be handled by chatbots on
amazon.com
moreover these assistants can have
real-time engagement with your customers
they can handle multiple situations like
if the customer has some feedback the
chatbot will take it from them
or if they have some basic questions
about your brand the chatbot can help
them out
these assistants can help further
emphasize the point to the users about
how important they are to your
organization
next under e-commerce we have smart
purchasing
customer trends are often difficult to
predict but with ai they don't have to
be
ai can focus demands related to a
particular product
with this knowledge your decisions on
what products to stock up and when it
needs to be done
can be positively impacted doing this
you're meeting customer expectations and
improving their experience with your
brand
finally under e-commerce we have fraud
prevention
two of the biggest issues that
e-commerce companies have to deal with
are
credit card fraud and fake reviews by
taking into consideration usage patterns
ai can help deal with reducing the
possibility of credit card frauds taking
place
talking about fake reviews did you know
that more than 80 percent of customers
decide to buy a
product or service based on their
customer reviews
ai can help identify and handle fake
reviews
by making sure they're handled you are
improving customer trust in your brand
and products
some of the organizations that have
already started ai
are amazon alibaba.com and ebay based on
research performed by mit
gps technology can provide users with
accurate timely and detailed information
to improve safety
the technology uses a combination of
conventional neural networks and graph
neural network
which makes lives easier for users by
automatically determining the number of
lanes
and road types behind obstructions on
the roads
next up we have ai applications in
robotics
first off let's have a look at mobility
robots that are powered by ai will use
real-time updates
they would be able to maneuver through a
particular part of travel
with this path the robot can sense
obstacles in its path
and then pre-plan its journey it can be
used for carrying goods in factories
warehouses and hospitals
cleaning offices and large equipments
inventory management
and it is also used for exploring
environments that are too dangerous for
humans
ai can also be used in process
optimization
data obtained by sensors can be analyzed
to enhance ai intelligence
with this knowledge unnecessary
breakdowns are prevented
and it can also reduce associated costs
of major issues
next up let's see how ai is applied in
the human resources domain
now this is something most people
wouldn't have expected
did you know that companies use software
to ease the hiring process
artificial intelligence helps with blind
hiring
software that uses machine learning can
be used to sift through applications
based on specific parameters
ai can be used to scan job candidates
profiles and resumes to provide
recruiters an understanding of the
talent pool they must choose from
now let's have a look at ai applications
in healthcare
first off let's have a look at how ai is
used in patient care
so there are these things called
prescription errors which are basically
caused due to slips
lapses or mistakes in a doctor's
prescription let's face it a dosage too
high can be the difference between life
and death
audit systems that use ai can help
prevent these kinds of errors from being
handled
and the diseases are properly identified
some of the popular uses are jv on
analytic and well frame next let's see
how ai
is used with medical imaging and
diagnostics
ai can help with early diagnosis to
analyze chronic conditions taking into
consideration laboratory and other
medical data
it is also used with advanced medical
imaging through which you can analyze
and transform images
through this you can create models for
possible scenarios
next up is ai applications in research
and development
ai is really important when it comes to
the discovery of new drugs
this is made possible with the help of a
combination of historical data and
medical intelligence
it also helps understand the human gene
and its components
it also helps predict the different
outcomes possible if gene editing is
performed
right now there's probably scientists
racing to develop the gene sequence for
covid19
and towards the creation of the vaccine
now that we have reached midwest i have
a question to ask
are you guys using ai powered software
in your workplace
let me know in the live chat if you
enjoy watching informative tech videos
like this one consider subscribing to
simply learn's channel to stay up to
date on the trending
technologies and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
next up let's talk about ai applications
in agriculture
first off ai helps with monitoring crop
and soil health
it can help with identifying defects and
nutrient deficiency in the soil
by analyzing images of soil and patterns
in them
soil defects plant pests and diseases
can be identified
next ai helps decrease pesticide usage
using technology like computer vision
robotics and machine learning
using this kind of technology it can be
determined where weeds are grown
this way herbicides can be sprayed only
where the weeds are
with this herbicide usage is limited ai
also helps with agriculture bots it can
be used to reduce human labor by
harvesting crops at a faster rate and a
higher volume
next let's have a look at artificial
intelligence in gaming
one of the most important things that
game companies need to handle which is
labor costs
this is done to generate levels maps
textures
weapons characters etc ai can be used to
create smart human-like npcs to interact
with players
it can also be used to predict human
behavior using which game design and
testing can be improved
now this example isn't a recent one but
that of a 2014 game called alien
isolation
now if you know about the movies you
know it's from the alien series of
movies
so in this game the titular alien stalks
the player throughout the game
the alien uses two ais to hunt the
player
a director ai that always knows the
position of the location of the player
and an alien ai which is driven by
sensors and behaviors that constantly
hunt the player
the director ai only gives the alien ai
clues to the player's location which it
needs to figure out
now let's have a look at ai application
in automobiles
first off we have driverless automobiles
by taking a combination of information
obtained from the vehicle's camera
radar cloud services gps and control
signals
that can be used to operate the vehicle
it's thanks to all of this that the car
is able to drive itself
next ai offers driver assistance ai can
be used to improve the in-vehicle
experience as well
systems like emergency braking blind
spot monitoring driver asset steering
are used next up ai and social media
first let's see how facebook is able to
use ai
one of the ways ai is being used is for
analyzing pictures
this can be used to identify the people
in an image
ai is also used in a tool called deep
text so with the help of ai can be used
to analyze posts that represent suicidal
thoughts
the tool can also be used to translate
posts from different languages
next let's have a look at ai used by
instagram
ai takes into account your likes and the
accounts you follow to determine what
posts you are shown
on your explore tab the deep text tool
has also been used recently to identify
and remove spam messages from user
accounts
ai is also used for handling cyber
bullying to check content based on
hashtags from other users
next up ai in twitter ai is used to
determine fraud propaganda
and hateful content on the platform it
is also used to recommend tweets that
the users might enjoy based on what
tweets that you engage with
it is also used to filter through
inappropriate content and remote from
the platform
ai is also used for automatically
cropping images based on face
recognition
it is also used to filter through
inappropriate content and remove it from
the platform
ai is also used for automatically
cropping images based on face
recognition
and finally let's have a look at ai
applications and marketing
first off ai enables programmatic
advertising
ai enables highly targeted and
personalized ads by taking into
consideration behavioral analysis
pattern recognition and much more
ai also enables you to re-target
audiences at
right time to make sure they are given
appropriate results
and ensure feelings of annoyance and
distrust next up that's personalized
narratives
ai can help with content marketing in a
way that matches the brand style and
voice
it can also be used to handle routine
tasks like performance campaign reports
and much more
then ai helps with setting up chatbots
chatbots are powered by ai natural
language processing natural language
generation natural language
understanding that can understand what
they use as language
and respond in the ways humans do then
we have personalized ui
and ux it can be used to provide users
with real-time personalization
basically these smart systems can
process information about site visitors
or app users
then apply changes to the model in ways
that optimize it for future use
by continually learning and adjusting
the algorithms improves the user's
experience to offer a more engaging
personalized experience
next ai helps with localization it can
help with editing
and optimizing market campaigns to fit
the needs of the local market
by automated editing of certain
variables like ctas ad copies etc
the campaigns would be able to connect
better with a local audience
and there you go these are the top
applications of ai in 2020.
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more what do you think is making
our lives easier off late
and how do you think the world is
rapidly changing
imagine getting into a car feeding your
destination as the input
and automatically getting dropped off at
your destination
at the same time you sit back and relax
through the ride without having to do
anything at all physically whoa life has
become
so much simpler with all kinds of
automation taking us through everyday
life
what do you think is making all this
possible artificial intelligence
thanks to numerous advancements in
technology which is bringing about a lot
of changes in our day-to-day lives
to drive innovation ai is using machine
learning
taking things one step further so what
exactly do you mean by artificial
intelligence
in simple terms ai refers to simulating
a machine
with human intelligence and programming
the device to think
and act like humans artificial
intelligence
also called machine intelligence is far
beyond robots as portrayed by science
fiction
from google search algorithm to amazon's
alexa
to apple siri to self-driven cars ai
progresses rapidly towards a harmonious
future between technology and man
bringing together the best of both
worlds since the machines are
artificially incorporated with
human-like intelligence
and perform tasks as we do it's termed
as artificial intelligence
and it was coined in 1956.
the programs that were developed after
ai was founded were simply astonishing
people could witness computers proving
theorems in geometry
solving algebra word problems and much
more
between the 1950s and 1970s neural
networks emerged
from the 1980s until the last decade
machine learning took over the world
now is the era of deep learning the
boons of ai
undoubtedly ai has changed our lives in
many ways
at number one we have safety factor
there are many fields like defense
mining etc where human health is at
significant risk
ai is the biggest boon in these fields
where a robo
or a drone does the work instead of a
human with the invention of self-driven
cars
ai is aiding at our road safety by
reducing the number of road traffic
accidents compared to those caused by
humans
speaking of language processing and
speech recognition
ai helps in effective communication by
processing and understanding the
language spoken by humans
it is also capable of comprehending the
words spoken by humans and reciprocate
in the same way
all this is possible by the voice
assistant feature which the ai bots have
at number three we have daily needs be
it
alexa or apple siri we are surrounded by
various applications that run on ai
fingerprint detection face detection gps
grammarly all these run on artificial
intelligence
google maps calculate the traffic
congestion to find the best route to
your destination which works on ai
whether it is the mathematical
calculations booking a ticket
buying a product online and driving a
car
ai has limited human interaction and
provides various services
in all the unexpected ways ai is helping
humans in the day-to-day needs
at number four we have healthcare ai is
a promising tool for supporting
healthcare administration
it helps healthcare workers and
stakeholders to manage
vast amounts of data and transform them
into potentially life-saving information
in the present scenario people are
threatened by the growing health
emergency due to the spread of the core
with 19 coronavirus
a who report released said that ai is a
vital part of the response to this
disease
ai systems are being developed
predicting people's temperatures and
survival rates with more than 90 percent
accuracy
one promising approach of ai in the
field of health care is it guides
vaccine design
as covet 19 began to spread globally
machine learning tools were used to
search
immunogenic components of the virus that
would make good vaccine candidates
yet another field where the ml is
significantly evolving is genomics
which is the study of the complete set
of genes within an organism
ai can sequence and analyze dna much
faster
cheaper and accurate than the
researchers ever will
at number 5 we have robus one of the
most amazing inventions by humans that
thinks
intelligently and acts autonomously the
disinfecting robots
are playing a significant role in these
uncertain times
they rove around healthcare facilities
spreading uv light to disinfect
places contaminated with viruses the
benefits of ai robots
far exceed the apprehensions speaking of
role of technology advancements
artificial intelligence is rapidly
advancing with a lot of computers and
robots capable of doing miracles
though the machines and robots cannot
have human feelings
they can think and act like humans
companies use techniques like machine
learning and neural networks to
accomplish
artificial intelligence which is also
called machine intelligence
in the present scenario considering the
total intelligence
we can conclude that 95 of it is machine
intelligence
and the remaining 5 is what we call
human knowledge
speaking of ai versus human ai has a
positive as well as a negative impact on
us
and society according to some recent
studies seven million existing jobs will
be replaced by ai
in the uk between 2017 and 2037
but at the same time 7.2 million jobs
could be created as well
a study from mckinsey global institute
states that by 2030
automation will replace 400 to 800
million jobs
requiring as many as 375 million people
to switch their job categories entirely
this is indeed going to cause fear and
concern to many vulnerable countries
the biggest challenge is how people
would make a living with these changes
and uncertainty
google ceo sundar pichai has claimed
that ai will be more transformative to
humanity
than electricity ever will google even
launched an ai system which bet some of
the best atari 2600 game players
also did you know that the best choice
player in the world is a machine how
would it be when the best doctor in the
world is a machine
the best teacher is a machine the best
architect is a machine
and the best of many professions are
various machines and robots
ais and robos will replace fast food
joints and radiologists in hospitals
someday ai will diagnose your cancer and
your robo will perform your surgery
it won't be long until a machine is
superior in every single professional
field
warning by musk this is extremely
important
um i think the danger of ai is much
greater than the
the danger of nuclear warheads by a lot
um and nobody would suggest that we
allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want
that would be insane and mark my words
ai is far more dangerous than nukes
so why do we have no regulatory
oversight this is insane
though ai is a boon to humankind in many
different ways
not everyone is ready to welcome ai with
open arms
some ai experts like stephen hawking and
elon musk have warned us about the
looming dangers that ai may possess to
humanity
they have even suggested that ai is
likely to be the greatest threat that
could end the human species
elon musk says that he is close to the
cutting edge in ai
which scares him a lot ai is vastly more
than almost
anyone knows and the rate of improvement
is exponential
he also says that ai is far more
dangerous than nuclear warheads
earlier in 2014 musk had described ai as
our biggest existential threat
ai can be harmful to us in two different
ways the idea that ai will become
conscious and
responsive and seek to destroy us
also the notion that people with evil
hands can turn this ai into a critical
tool for wicked purposes
if the super intelligent ai more
intelligent than us
becomes conscious they will look at
humans like how humans will look at
monkeys
people are afraid of ai by watching
movies like 2001 a space odyssey
where one of the most well-known ais
turned terrible
the terminator the matrix and few others
these movies have speculated about ai
that far exceeds the expectations of
its creators and escapes their control
eventually targeting humans for
extinction speaking of the real reasons
to be afraid of ai
there are doctors engineers accountants
judges
architects who seek information from an
ei system
they treat this information as it is
from a trusted colleague
this trust is what we should be afraid
of it is not because of how often ai
gets it wrong
ai researchers pride themselves on the
accuracy of results
it is how bad it gets it wrong when it
makes a mistake
these systems do not fail gracefully one
such incident is when facebook had to
shut down a controversial chatbot
experiment where the two ais developed
their own language for communication
a research was conducted with two
chatbots named alice and bob
focusing on how to negotiate with each
other unfortunately the researchers
found that the bots had deviated from
the actual script and had started
inventing their new phrases
without any human script as the bots
were left unsupervised they developed
their machine language which was
otherwise developed to converse with
people
that's the scary part of ai neural
networks and deep learning
the developers and researchers working
on this would have no idea
what it's doing this technology can get
complicated
and we have to make sure what we are
doing with it holds value
we must also handle it cautiously
because ai is a direct reflection of
us people should lead and not follow so
here's the question
should we be afraid of ai we all know
that ai is a transformative technology
that we have ever seen in the history of
humankind
on the other hand we should be scared of
this so-called transformative power it
has the potential to be transformative
both for good reasons as well as for the
wrong
however fear of the unknown has always
been the case with technology
fears that ai will develop awareness and
overthrow humanity are grounded in
misconceptions of what
ai is ai is defined by the algorithms
that dictate its behavior
and operate under definite limitations
people are afraid of what happens when
ai reaches its consciousness
what if an ai machine starts to have
human feelings and emotions
well there has been no progress in
research in these areas
also we don't think that is anywhere in
our near future
pretty much any type of machine can be
used for either good or bad reasons
we as developers and researchers should
know where to stop
or pause in a ted talk peter haar says
imagine you're driving up a mountain and
it's raining very heavily
as you climb into the mountains the rain
is turning into snow
and pretty soon that snow is a white out
you cannot see the taillights of the car
in front of you
you start skidding you see some vehicle
was coming to crash into you
all this wouldn't have happened if you
paused your journey as the rain was
getting worse
this is to tell you how something small
and seemingly mundane can quickly grow
into something hazardous
consider yourself driving the rain with
ai right now
that rain will turn into snow soon and
that snow could quickly become a
dangerous blizzard
so we need to pause check the conditions
put in place safety standards
and ask ourselves how far we want to go
only the healthy skepticism of these
systems is going to help keep people
in the loop spot checking what the ai
algorithms are doing keeping people in
the loop will probably
solve some of our most significant
challenges
at the moment ai isn't dangerous in
itself unless you're living in the
realms of the movies as mentioned
earlier
however evolved these am machines are
they still lack human empathy and
consciousness
so instead of running away from this
technology we should understand this
revolutionary technology and make sure
it is used in the right way to make our
lives better
and on that note if you want to master
ai and machine learning
you can check out simplylearn's
postgraduate program in ai
and machine learning in partnership with
purdue university
hello my name is richard kirschner and
today we're going to go over what is
artificial intelligence
one example of today's artificial
intelligence is a smart home so
welcome to my smart home smart homes are
run by artificial intelligence
let's have a look at some of the key
features of a smart house
home appliances are voice controlled
sensors adjust lights and air coolers
according to the climate
security systems can detect movement
outside and worn at the residence
all the appliances are interconnected to
each other and
can detect vehicles in the driveway and
let the owner know home appliances can
be controlled remotely through the phone
now this is just one example in today's
world so what's in it for you today
today we're going to cover a brief
history of artificial intelligence
what is artificial intelligence types of
artificial intelligence
applications of artificial intelligence
and just a quick glimpse of the future
of artificial
intelligence let us start with a brief
history of artificial intelligence
let's start with john mccarthy he was
the first one to
coin the word artificial intelligence
and in
1956 had the first artificial
intelligence
conference let's jump forward to 1969
was shaky
shaky was the first general purpose
mobile robot built
and although by today's standard he was
very simple he did mark a milestone
in that we were now processing data
differently he was now able to do things
with a purpose versus just a list of
instructions albeit the list included
things like turning on and off lights
and pushing boxes around the room we're
going to move forward to
1997. in 1997 the super computer deep
blue was designed which defeated the
world's
chess champion in a game this is the
first time when we're actually seeing
the computer
using logic to beat a human doing some
kind of logical
in this case a game so it was a huge
milestone by ibm to create this large
computer that was able to do that in a
timely fashion let's jump up to 2002
when we have our first commercially
successful robotic
vacuum cleaner nowadays you can go down
to the target and buy one but back in
2002
that was the first model that was put
out and finally 2005 to 2018 today
in the last more than a decade we have
speech recognition
rpa dancing robots smart homes and many
more to come
what i want you to notice about this
brief history of artificial intelligence
is the compression of time in 1956 it
was just an idea
and more than 10 years later we have our
shaky the first one who's able to flip
light switches
and then we go all the way to 97 where
we have deep blue and there's a lot of
little steps between 69 and 97 but it's
actually able to take on a human
in chess and beat them regularly now
they did have a lot of ties so don't
think that it won
every game and then we go only four
years later we have our first
commercially successful robotic vacuum
cleaner and as we go from 2005 to 2018
we go from simple speech recognition to
very complicated
able to really register with your google
voice and your siri
we have our rpa we have dancing robot
smart homes and many more things are
just coming out almost
monthly in the world of artificial
intelligence so
what is artificial intelligence ai
is a form of computer science used to
create intelligent machines
that can recognize human speech objects
can learn
plan and solve problems like humans
and i'd like you to focus just on that
last one can solve
problems like humans as we saw earlier
we compare the computer that can beat
the chess
champion it's able to the one before
that able to turn on and off lights in
the house
so right now our concept of artificial
intelligence
is based primarily on our understanding
of how it interacts with humans and how
we can compare it to humans
so speech recognition that's a big one
today object detection
solve problems and learn from the given
data and plan an approach for future
tasks to be done these are all very
human things that we do
to plan and solve for the future types
of artificial intelligence
hi heard you want to know the types of
a.i you can imagine a little robot
taking us on a tour
the first type is purely reactive the
second type
is limited memory the third type theory
of mind
which is still in the process of being
invented and definitely the question of
self-awareness being the fourth which is
still not invented yet or
is it let's look at these a little
closer here we have our
purely reactive he does not have any
past memory or data to work with
he takes actions reacts based on what he
sees
okay it's not that tough observes every
move you can see we have a nice game of
chess going on here and wins takes the
best possible decision
purely reactive machines specialize in
one field of work
only in this case we see a chess game
where they figure out the best moves
calculating all the different moves
maybe it's calculating the next one in a
row in a linear regression model so you
can figure out the best marketing but
they're very reactionary they don't have
a lot of data they just have what's in
front of them to look at
next let's look at limited memory let's
try to understand the limited memory
setup
these machines use previous data and
keep adding it to their memory
so just me a good restaurant so maybe
we're looking to go out for dinner
tonight and we're not sure what we want
to eat
hmm i see you have been to kfc quite a
lot in the past week there is a kefc
nearby so it goes through the previous
location data and where they ate prior
and says hmm this is probably a good
suggestion for you tonight
thanks it has enough memory or
experience to make proper decisions
but the memory is very limited this
isn't trying to
guess what a new location would be or
anything like that
it just takes what it has in front of it
and goes okay this is where you've been
this is what you liked you gave it two
thumbs up
one thumb down whatever and then it goes
from these suggestions
this is where i think you should go
theory of mind this kind of ai
has a capacity to understand thoughts
and emotions and
interact socially a machine based on
this type is yet to be built
that human looks lonely hey human you
want to be my friend
huh okay theory of mind is a thing of
the future
certainly we see a lot of the industry
poking a little bit at this
as it tries to guess how you feel about
things but most of that is still based
on previous data you know
yes no two thumbs up one thumb down
theory in mind
would take it one step further in
understanding the emotions behind it
and finally as we get deep into the
sci-fi futuristic we have self-aware
self-aware machines are future
generation of machines
they will be super intelligent sentient
sentient
and conscious like the terminator the
good guy in the thing or
ultron or vision from avengers for right
now
these are mostly movie characters or
cartoon characters but we certainly are
getting closer to seeing them in the
real world
hopefully they'll be of the type of the
good guys and not the bad guys we see
also in the artificial intelligence
sci-fi movies
applications of artificial intelligence
let's take a look at
some of today's commercial business uses
for the ai
we have banking fraud detection from a
large data consisting of fraudulent and
non-fraudulent transactions the ai
learns to predict if a new transaction
is fraud or not
online customer support most of the
customer support is now being automated
by artificial intelligence
cyber security using machine learning
algorithms and a lot of sample data ai
can be used to detect anomalies
adapt and respond to threats virtual
assistants
siri cortana alexa and google now use
voice recognition to follow the user's
commands
these are all wonderful examples of
current ais that are in the commercial
and business world
and these ones in particular have
matured over the last half a decade
for instance very few large banks in
today world would not use
banking for fraud detection or for
deciding whether it's
a good person to give a loan to or not
based on their credit scores and where
they're from and their income
same thing with cyber security detecting
anomalies
or online customer support could you
imagine in
say hp who has over 70 000
help pages across 17 different languages
now they have to figure out how to do
online customer support to cover
new problems that come up and track them
so they can build new pages
if they had one person doing that that
would take them a year just to do what
they need to have posted yesterday
and of course our virtual assistants i
don't know about you but i love mine
kind of like having a private secretary
without having a private secretary
future of artificial intelligence if we
see where it's at now commercially and
business-wise
then where is it going of course the
imagination's a limit on this one but
you can already see the development in
the world today for automated
transportation they'll become a common
thing
maybe even early as 2020 when they have
the final release from the
leaders in the industry humans will be
able to augment themselves with robots
certainly the idea of having the robot
bring me my coffee is lovely
or when i'm doing reports or something
else on the computer
it does part of that work for me so that
i'm freed up to think about other things
there will be more
numbers of smart cities as vehicles
phones home appliances will be run by ai
home robots will help elderly people
with the day-to-day work
japan already has a very in-depth
program where they begin to integrate
robots
helping elderly even some of the simple
things like getting that
box of cereal off the top shelf or
monitoring if they fall
and need to contact the doctor in an
emergency to show up robots will take
over hazardous jobs like bomb defusing
welding etc for the future of artificial
intelligence you can see here a number
of robotic uses that are already in
development
people are already working on these and
trying to bring them to us in a
commercial
business fashion your own imagination
can take this to the next level
or a simple google search will show you
some of the stuff that's out there now
in addition to these
hello and welcome to machine learning
tutorial part one
this is part one of a machine learning
series put on by simplylearn
what's in it for you today well we'll
start off with a brief explanation of
why machine learning and what is machine
learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms
linear regression decision trees support
vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe
is of a cupcake or a muffin
using the svm or the support vector
machine sounds like a delicious way to
explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us
well because machines can now drive your
car for you
it's still very in the infant stage but
it's just exploding as we see with
google's waymo and then uber had their
program which unfortunately crashed
they know that this is huge this is
going to be the huge industry to change
our whole
transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases
do you know how amazing that is to have
a computer that double checks for the
doctor for things they might miss
that's just huge in the health industry
pretty soon they actually do already
have that within some areas where maybe
not for eyes but for other diseases
where they're using
the camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go and see the
doctor
and because the machine can now unlock
your phone with your face
i mean that's just cool having it being
able to identify your face
or your voice and be able to turn stuff
on and off for you depending on where
you're at and what you need
talking about an ultimate automation or
world we live in
and as we dig in deeper we have a nice
example of
facebook as you can see here they have
the facebook post with halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam post on facebook that
annoy them into
interacting with likes shares comments
and other actions
i remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here
you will have bad luck or some kind of
fear factor
well this is a huge thing in social
media when people are getting spammed
and so
this tactic known as engagement bait
takes advantage of facebook's news feed
algorithm by choosing engagement in
order to get the greater reach
to eliminate engagement bait the company
reviewed and categorized hundreds of
thousands of posts to train a machine
learning model that detects different
types of engagement bait
so in this case we have we're using
facebook but this is of course across
all the different social media
they have different tools are building
and the facebook scroll gif
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there and notices that there's
a certain setup with
facebook and it's able to replace it and
they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of general titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something
so they fed all this this data was fed
into the machine and then they have the
new post the new post
comes up that takes over part of the
facebook setup
and that's what you're looking at you're
looking at this new post that's replaced
like a virus has replaced that
so what facebook do to eliminate this is
they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this
and checks the click-through rate so it
starts looking for people who are
clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through
once facebook has scanned for these
keywords and phrases
it is now able to identify the spam
coming in
and this makes your life easier so
you're not getting spammed it's not like
walking through an airport and
a lot of countries you have like
hundreds of people trying to sell you
timeshare
come join us sign up for this eliminates
that annoyingness so now you can just
enjoy your facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures mine is family
certainly people like their cat pictures
too another good example is google's
deepmind
project alphago a computer program that
plays a board game go
has defeated the world's number one go
player and i hope i say his name right
kiji the ultimate go challenge game of
three of three
was on may 27 2017. so it's just last
year that this happened
and what makes this so important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world
but they are using games to learn
how to get the machine learning program
to learn they want it to learn how to
learn and that is a huge
step a lot of this is still in its
infant stage as far as development
as we saw what happened with the as i
referred to earlier the
uber cars they lost their whole division
because they jumped ahead too fast
so it's still an infant stage but boy is
this like the beginning
of just an amazing world that is
automated in ways we can't even imagine
what tomorrow's going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning
so let's see if we can give a little bit
more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and information
without being explicitly programmed
we see here we have a nice little
diagram where we have our ordinary
system
and your computer nowadays you can even
run a lot of stuff on
a cell phone because cell phones are
advanced so much and then with
artificial intelligence
and machine learning it now takes the
data and it learns from what happened
before
and then it predicts what's going to
come next and then
really the biggest part right now in
machine learning that's going on is
it improves on that how do we find a new
solution
so we go from descriptive words learning
about stuff and understanding how it
fits together
to predicting what it's going to do to
post scripting coming up with a
new solution and when we're working on
machine learning
there's a number of different diagrams
that people have posted for what steps
to go through a lot of it might
be very domain specific so if you're
working on
photo identification versus language
versus medical
or physics some of these are switched
around a little bit or new things are
put in they're very specific to the
domain
this is kind of a very general diagram
first you want to define your objective
very important to know what it is you're
wanting to predict then you're going to
be collecting the data so once you've
defined an
objective you need to collect the data
that matches you spend a lot of time
in data science collecting data in the
next step preparing the data you've got
to make sure that your data is clean
going in
there's the old saying bad data in bad
answer out
or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we've cleaned all this
stuff coming in
then you're going to select the
algorithm which algorithm are you going
to use you're going to train that
algorithm in this case
i think we're going to be working with
svm the support vector machine
then you have to test the model does
this model work is this a valid model
for what we're doing
and then once you've tested it you want
to run your prediction you want to run
your prediction
or your choice or whatever output it's
going to come up with
and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing
then you want to go ahead and deploy the
model remember i said domain specific
this is very general
as far as the scope of doing something a
lot of models you get halfway through
and you realize that your
data is missing something and you have
to go collect new data
because you've run a test in here some
place along the line you're saying hey
i'm not really getting the answers i
need
so there's a lot of things that are
domain specific that become part of this
model this is a very
general model but it's a very good model
to start with and we do have some basic
divisions
of what machine learning does that's
important to know
for instance do you want to predict a
category well if you're categorizing
thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease
so in other words i'm looking for a yes
no answer is it going up or is it going
down
and in that case we'd actually say is it
going up true
if it's not going up it's false meaning
it's going down this way it's a yes no
zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's
regression so remember we just did
classification now we're looking at
regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height
weight health and other factors so based
on these different factors
you might guess how old a person is and
then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly
that's anomaly detection this is
actually very popular right now
for instance you want to detect money
withdrawal anomalies you want to know
when someone's
making a withdrawal that might not be
their own account we've actually brought
this up because this is really big right
now
if you're predicting the stock whether
to buy stock or not
you want to be able to know if what's
going on in the stock market is an
anomaly
use a different prediction model because
something else is going on you got to
pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm i'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested
so being able to detect anomalies is
very big in data science these days
another question that comes up which is
on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure
in unexplored data and that's called
clustering for instance
finding groups of customers with similar
behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics
and past buying records and in this case
we might
notice that anybody who's wearing a
certain set of shoes
goes shopping at certain stores or
whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases
by having that information it helps us
to market or group people together so
that we can now explore that group
and find out what it is we want to
market to them if you're in the
marketing world
and that might also work in just about
any arena you might want to group people
together
whether they're based on their different
areas
and investments and financial background
whether you're going to give them a loan
or not before you even start looking at
whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on
unknown data so you're not you don't
know what the data is going to tell you
but you want to cluster people together
that come together
let's take a quick detour for quiz time
oh my favorite so we're going to have a
couple questions here
under a quiz time and we'll be posting
the answers
in this part two of this tutorial
so let's go ahead and take a look at
these quiz times questions and hopefully
you'll get them all right
we'll get you thinking about how to
process data and what's going on
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases
of course you're sitting there with your
cup of coffee and you have your checkbox
and your pen
trying to figure out what's your next
step in your data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories
based on the topic and content of each
document
very big these days you know you have
legal documents you have
maybe it's a sports group documents
maybe analyzing newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images
correctly so we want to know whether
they're writing an a or capital a b
c what are they writing out in their
hand digit their handwriting
c behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed
d predicting salary of an individual
based on
his or her years of experience
with hr hiring set up there so stay
tuned for part two we'll go ahead and
answer these questions when we get to
the part two of this tutorial
or you can just simply write at the
bottom and send a note to simply learn
and they'll follow up with you on it
back to our regular content
and these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another
way of dividing our types of machine
learning and that is with
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning supervised
learning
is a method used to enable machines to
classify predict
objects problems or situations based on
labeled data
fed to the machine and in here you see
we have a jungle of data
with circles triangles and squares then
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square
and we have our model training and it
trains it so we know the answer
very important when you're doing
supervised learning you already know the
answer to a lot of your information
coming in
so you have a huge group of data coming
in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model
the model now knows the difference
between a circle a square a triangle
and now that we've trained it we can
send in in this case a square and a
circle goes in
and it predicts that the top one's a
square and the next one's a circle
and you can see that this is uh being
able to predict whether someone's going
to default on a loan because i was
talking about banks earlier
supervised learning on stock market
whether you're going to make money or
not
that's always important and if you are
looking to make a fortune in the stock
market keep in mind
it is very difficult to get all the data
correct on the stock market
it is very it fluctuates and weighs you
really hard to predict
so it's quite a roller coaster ride if
you're running machine learning on the
stock market you start realizing you
really have to dig for new data
so we have supervised learning and if
you have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning
machine learning model finds the hidden
pattern in an unlabeled
data so in this case instead of telling
it what the circle is and what a
triangle is and what a square is
it goes in there looks at them and says
for whatever reason it groups them
together maybe they'll group it by the
number of corners
and it notices that a number of them all
have three corners a number of them all
have four corners
and a number of them all have no corners
and it's able to filter those through
and group them together
we talked about that earlier with
looking at a group of people who are out
shopping we want to group them together
to find out
what they have in common and of course
once you understand what people have in
common
maybe you have one of them is a customer
at your store or you have five of them
our customer your store
and they have a lot in common with five
others who are not customers at your
store
how do you market to those five who
aren't customers at your store yet they
fit the demographs of who's gonna shop
there
and you'd like them to shop at your
store not the one next door of course
this is a simplified version you can see
very easily
the difference between a triangle and a
circle which might not be so easy in
marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning where an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result
we have here where the in this case a
baby it's actually great that they used
an
infant for this slide because the
reinforcement learning
is very much in its infant stages but
it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now
or in the future it's going to be coming
up over the next few years is
reinforcement learning and how to
make that work for us and you can see
here where we have our action
in the action on this one it goes into
the fire hopefully the baby didn't it
was just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here
when the baby comes out and the new
state is the baby is
sad and crying because they got burned
on the fire and then maybe they take
another action
the baby's called the agent because it's
the one taking the actions
and in this case they didn't go into the
fire they went a different direction and
now the baby's happy
and laughing and playing reinforcement
learning is very easy to understand
because that's how
as humans that's one of the ways we
learn we learn whether
it is you burn yourself on the stove
don't do that anymore don't touch the
stove
in the big picture being able to have
machine learning programming or an ai
be able to do this is huge because now
we're starting to
learn how to learn that's a big jump
in the world of computer and machine
learning and we're going to go back and
just kind of go back over
supervised versus unsupervised learning
understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on
we have in supervised learning we have
labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said
yes that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be
and then with unsupervised training it's
not labeled so we really don't know
what it is there's no feedback so we're
not telling it whether it's right or
wrong we're not telling it whether it's
a triangle or a square
we're not telling it to go left or right
all we do is we're finding
hidden structure in the data grouping
the data together to find out
what connects to each other and then you
can use these together
so imagine you have an image and you're
not sure what you're looking for
so you go in and you have the
unstructured data find all these things
that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data
and program something to predict what's
in the picture so you can see how they
go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms
let's have a look at a few of them
hopefully this gives you a little flavor
of what's out there
and these are some of the most important
ones that are currently being used
we'll take a look at linear regression
decision tree
and the support vector machine let's
start with a closer look at
linear regression linear regression is
perhaps one of the most well-known and
well-understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning linear regression is a linear
model
for example a model that assumes a
linear relationship between
the input variables x and the single
output variable
y and you'll see this if you remember
from your algebra classes
y equals mx plus c imagine we are
predicting distance traveled y
from speed x our linear regression model
representation for this problem
would be y equals m times x plus c or
distance equals m times speed plus c
where m is the coefficient and c is the
y-intercept
and we're going to look at two different
variations of this first we're going to
start with
time is constant and you can see we have
a bicyclist
he's got a safety gear on thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second
and so over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers
we have a second bicyclist he's going
twice the speed or
20 meters per second and you can guess
if he's going
twice the speed and time is a constant
then he's going to go twice the distance
and that's easy to compute 36 times 2
you get
72 kilometers and so if you had the
question of
how fast would somebody is going three
times at speed or 30 meters per second
is
you can easily compute the distance in
our head we can do that without needing
a computer
but we want to do this for more
complicated data so it's kind of nice to
compare the two but let's just take a
look at that and what that looks like in
a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed
and we have our m equals the ve slope of
the line and we'll notice that the line
has a plus slope
and as the speed increases distance also
increases hence the variables
have a positive relationship and so your
speed of the person which equals y
equals mx plus c
distance traveled in a fixed interval of
time and we could very easily compute
either following the line or just
knowing it's 3 times 10 meters per
second that this is roughly 102
kilometers distance that this third
bicep
has traveled one of the key definitions
on here is
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive
as distance increase so to speed
increase let's take a look at our second
example where we put
distance is a constant so we have speed
equals 10 meters per second
they have a certain distance to go and
it takes him a hundred seconds to travel
that distance
and we have our second bicyclist who's
still doing 20 meters per second
since he's going twice the speed we can
guess that he'll cover the distance in
about half the time
50 seconds and of course you could
probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed
you can easily guess that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or
graph if the distance is assumed to be
constant let's see the relationship
between speed and time
and as time goes up the amount of speed
to go that same distance
goes down so now your m equals a minus
ve slope of the line
as the speed increases time decreases
hence the variable
has a negative relationship again
there's our definition
positive relationship and negative
relationship depended on the slope of
the line
and with a simple formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression
and we'll take this data so suppose we
have this data set where we have x
y x equals 1 2 3 4 5
standard series and the y value is 3
2 2 4 3. when we take that and we go
ahead and plot these points on a graph
you can see there's kind of a nice
scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression
and the first thing we do is we come up
here we have the mean
of x i and remember mean is basically
the average
so we added five plus four plus three
plus two plus one and divide by five
and that simply comes out as three and
then we'll do the same for y
we'll go ahead and add up all those
numbers and divide by five
and we end up with the mean value of y
of i equals
2.8 where the x i references it's an
average or means value and the y i
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in
the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3
in there on our graph we kind of give it
a little different color so you can sort
it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression the linear
regression model
should go through that dot now let's
find our regression
equation to find the best fit line
remember we go ahead and take our y
equals mx plus c
so we're looking for m and c so to find
this equation
for our data we need to find our slope
of m
and our coefficient of c and we have y
equals
mx plus c where m equals the sum of
x minus x average times y minus y
average or y means and x means over the
sum of
x minus x means squared that's how we
get the slope of the value of the line
and we can easily do that by creating
some columns here we have
x y computers are really good about
iterating through
data and so we can easily compute this
and fill in a graph of data
and in our graph you can easily see that
if we have our x value of one
and if you remember the x i or the means
value is three
one minus three equals a negative two
and two minus three
equals a negative one so on and so forth
and we can easily fill in the column of
x minus x i
y minus y i and then from those we can
compute
x minus x i squared and x minus x i
times y minus y i and you can guess it
that the next step is to go ahead and
sum the different columns for the
answers we need
so we get a total of 10 for our x minus
x i squared
and a total of 2 for x minus x i times y
minus y i
and we plug those in we get 2 10 which
equals 0.2 so now we know the slope of
our line equals 0.2
so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y
axis and if you remember i mentioned
earlier
that the linear regression line has to
pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph
and you can see right here there's our
means value which is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into
our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals
0.2 times 3 plus c and you can just
solve for c
so now we know that our coefficient
equals 2.2
and once we have all that we can go
ahead and plot our regression line
y equals 0.2 times x plus 2.2
and then from this equation we can
compute
new values so let's predict the values
of y using
x equals 1 2 3 4 5 and plot the points
remember the 1 2 3 4 5 was our original
x values
so now we're going to see what y thinks
they are not what they actually are and
we plug those in
we get y of designated with y of p you
can see that
x equals 1 equals 2.4 x equals 2 equals
2.6
and so on and so on so we have our y
predicted
values of what we think it's going to be
when we plug those numbers in
and when we plot the predicted values
along with the actual values
we can see the difference and this is
one of the things that's very important
with linear regression in any of these
models
is to understand the error and so we can
calculate the error on all of our
different values and you can see over
here we plotted
x and y and y predict and we draw a
little line so you can sort of see what
the error looks like there between the
different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model
minimizing the distance there are lots
of ways to minimize the distance between
the line and the data points
like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors
root mean square error etc we keep
moving this line through the data points
to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
so to recap with a very simple linear
regression model
we first figure out the formula of our
line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals
mx plus c but you can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those
using the different formulas to minimize
the error
let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model
decision tree is a tree shaped algorithm
used to determine a course of action
each branch of a tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
we have data which tells us if it is a
good day to play golf
and if we were to open this data up in a
general spreadsheet
you can see we have the outlook whether
it's a rainy overcast sunny
temperature hot mild cool humidity
windy and did i like to play golf that
day yes or no
so we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not
but you can imagine if you got up in the
night before you're trying to plan your
day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you
in the morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that
this becomes very beneficial and we see
this in a lot of applications coming out
now where it gives you suggestions
and lets you know what would be fit the
match for you for the next day or the
next purchase
or the next uh whatever you know next
mail out in this case
is tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in
and so we come up and let's determine if
you should play golf
when the day is sunny and windy so we
found out the forecast tomorrow is going
to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity
and then we have our normal which is if
it's if you have a normal humidity
you're going to go play golf
and if the humidity is really high then
we look at the outlook and if the
outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do
so if you know that it's a very high
humidity and it's sunny
you're probably not going to play golf
because you're going to be out there
miserable
fighting off the mosquitoes that are out
joining you to play golf with you
maybe if it's raining you probably don't
want to play in the rain but if it's
slightly overcast
you get just the right shadow that's a
good day to play golf and be outside
out on the green now in this example you
can probably
make your own creep pretty easily
because it's a very simple set of data
going in
but the question is how do you know what
to split where do you split your data
what if this is much more complicated
data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand
like studying cancer they take about 36
measurements of the cancerous
cells and then each one of those
measurements represents
how bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are
something that as a human we would have
no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but
since the question is going to come up
is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information
gain two important vocabulary words
there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or
impurity in the data set entropy should
be low
so we want the chaos to be as low as
possible we don't want to look at it
and be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data
and the information gain it is a measure
of decrease in entropy
after the data set is split also known
as entropy
reduction information gain should be
high
so we want our information that we get
out of the split to be as high as
possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side
in this case we're going to denote
entropy as
i of p of and n where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and
n is the probability where you're not
going to play the game of golf
now you don't really have to memorize
these formulas there's a few of them out
there depending on what you're working
with but it's important to note that
this is where this formula is coming
from so when you see it you're not lost
when you're running your programming
unless you're building your own decision
tree code in the back
and we simply have a log squared of p
over p plus n minus n over p plus n
times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like
when we're computing that from the
computer script side
entropy of a target class of the data
set is the whole entropy
so we have entropy play golf and we look
at this
if we go back to the data you can simply
count how many yeses and no in our
complete data set
for playing golf days in our complete
set
we find we have five days we did play
golf and nine days we did not play golf
and so our i equals if you add those
together nine plus five is fourteen
and so our i equals five over fourteen
and 9 over 14. that's our p and n values
that we plug into that formula
and you can go to 5 over 14 equals 0.36
9 over 14 equals 0.64 and when you do
the whole
equation you get the minus 0.36
log root squared of 0.36 minus 0.64
log squared root of 0.64 and we get a
set value we get
0.94 so we now have a full
entropy value for the whole set of data
that we're working with
and we want to make that entropy go down
and just like we calculated the entropy
out for the whole set we can also
calculate entropy for playing golf and
the outlook
is it going to be overcast or rainy or
sunny
and so we look at the entropy we have p
of sunny times e
of three of two and that just comes out
how many sunny days
yes and how many sunny days no over the
total which is five don't forget to put
the we'll divide that five out later on
equals p overcast equals four comma zero
plus rainy equals two comma three and
then when you do the whole setup
we have five over fourteen remember i
said there was a total of five
five over fourteen times the i of 3 of 2
plus 4 over 14
times the 4 comma 0 and 5 14
over i of 2 3. and so we can now
compute the entropy of just the part
that has to do with the forecast
and we get 0.693 similarly we can
calculate the entropy of other
predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain outlook how much are we going to
gain from this
entropy play golf minus entropy play
golf outlook
and we can take the original 0.94 for
the whole set
minus the entropy of just the rainy day
and temperature
and we end up with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy
and we define an information gain the
higher the information
gain the lower the entropy the better
the information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way
so we have our gain for temperature
equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152
and our gain for a windy day equals
0.048
and if you do a quick comparison you'll
see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain
and we can continue to go down the tree
using the different information gains
with the largest information we can
continue down the nodes of the tree
where we choose the attribute with the
largest information gain as the root
node
and then continue to split each sub node
with the largest information gain that
we can compute
and although it's a little bit of a
tongue twister to say all that you can
see that's a very easy to view
visual model we have our outlook we
split it three different directions
if the outlook is overcast we're going
to play and then we can split those
further down if we want so if the
outlook is sunny but then it's also
windy
if it's uh windy we're not going to play
if it's not windy we'll play
so we can easily build a nice decision
tree to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day
so we want to know if it's a good day to
play golf when it's sunny and windy
remember the original question that came
out tomorrow's weather report is sunny
and windy
you can see by going down the tree we go
outlook sunny outlook windy
we're not going to play golf tomorrow so
our little smart watch pops up and says
i'm sorry
tomorrow is not a good day for golf it's
going to be sunny and windy
and if you're a huge golf fan you might
go uh oh
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home
so we'll sit in front of the tv instead
of being out playing golf in the wind
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have uh well we'll start with the
simple linear regression where we had y
equals m plus x plus c and we're trying
to find the value of y
now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in
so instead of having just x we have x1
x2 x3 and instead of having just one
slope each variable has its own slope
attached to it
as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out
so you have y equals m1 times x1 plus
m2 times x2 so on all the way to
m to the nth x to the nth and then you
add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part
let's understand how multiple linear
regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before
we were looking at a company and just
based on its rnd
trying to figure out his profit we're
going to start looking at the
expenditure of the company we're going
to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r
d we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs
marketing costs and so on and from there
we're going to see if we can figure out
what the profit of that company is going
to be
to start our coding we're going to begin
by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression
we're going to take a look at the data
to see what we're playing with then
we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model
and then from there we'll go ahead and
solve it and just see how
valid our solution is so let's start
with importing the basic libraries
now i'm going to be doing this in
anaconda jupiter notebook a very popular
ide
i enjoy it it's such a visual to look at
and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this
so break out your favorite python ide so
here we are in our jupiter notebook
let me go ahead and paste our first
piece of code in there and let's walk
through what libraries we're importing
first we're going to import numpy as in
p and then i want you to skip one line
and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning
pandas although you don't have to have
it for your sklearn libraries it does
such a wonderful job of importing data
setting it up into a data frame so we
can manipulate it rather easily and it
has a lot of tools also in addition to
that so we usually like to use the
pandas when we can and i'll show you
what that looks like
the other three lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it
so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as
plt and then seaborn as sns
seaborn works with the matplot library
so you have to always import matplot
library and then seaborn sits on top of
it
and we'll take a look at what that looks
like you could use any of your own
plotting libraries you want there's all
kinds of ways to look at the data
these are just very common ones and the
seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody
and the final line is the amber signed
matplot library inline that is only
because i'm doing an inline ide
my interface in the anaconda jupiter
notebook
requires i put that in there or you're
not going to see the graph when it comes
up
let's go ahead and run this it's not
going to be that interesting so we're
just setting up variables
in fact it's not going to do anything
that we can see but it is importing
these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables now
here in the slide you'll see companies
equals pd.read csv and it has a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies dot csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have
and the file itself you can request just
go down to the commentary below this
video
and put a note in there and simply learn
we'll try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself
so we're going to add this code in here
and we're going to see that i have
companies equals pd.reader underscore
csv
and i've changed this path to match my
computer c colon slash simply learn
slash 1000 underscore companies dot csv
and then below there we're going to set
the x equals to companies
under the eye location and because this
is companies as a pd data set
i can use this nice notation that says
take every row
that's what the colon the first colon is
comma except for the last column that's
what the second part is where we have a
colon minus one
and we want the values set into there so
x is no longer
a data set a pandas data set but we can
easily extract the data from our pandas
data set with this notation
and then y we're going to set equal to
the last row
well the question is going to be what
are we actually looking at
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and we're going to look at the
companies dot
head which lists the first five rows of
data and i'll open up the file in just a
second so you can see where that's
coming from but let's look at the data
in here
as far as the way the pandas sees it
when i hit run
you'll see it breaks it out into a nice
setup this is what panda is one of the
things pandas is really good about is it
looks just like an excel spreadsheet
you have your rows and remember when
we're programming we always start with
zero we don't start with one
so it shows the first five rows zero one
two three four and then it shows your
different columns
r d spend administration marketing spend
state profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows
why don't we go ahead and open this file
up in a csv so you can actually see the
raw data so
here i've opened it up as a text editor
and you can see at the top we have rnd
spend comma administration comma
marketing spin comma state comma profit
carriage return i don't know about you
but i'd go crazy trying to read files
like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that
top part the first five row now as nice
as this format
is where i can see the data to me it
doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
investments and you understand
what uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents
compared to the administration cost of
136
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261
and 83 cents that makes no sense to me
whatsoever
no pun intended so let's flip back here
and take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so
at this point we're going to use a
single line of code to get a lot of
information
so we can see where we're going with
this let's go ahead and paste that into
our notebook and see what we got going
and so we have the visualization
and again we're using sns which is
pandas
as you can see we imported the map plot
library dot pi plot as plt
which then the seaborn uses and we
imported the seaborn as sns
and then that final line of code helps
us show this
in our inline coding without this it
wouldn't display and you could display
it to a file in other means and that's
the matplot library in line with the
amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame
so i can just take the companies dot
core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this
we get this beautiful plot and let's
just take a look at what this plot means
if you look at this plot on mine the
colors are probably a little bit more
purplish and blue than the original one
we have the columns and the rows we have
r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit
and if you cross index any two of these
since we're interested in profit if you
cross index profit with profit
it's going to show up if you look at the
scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data
they have an exact correspondence so r d
spending is going to be the same as r d
spending and the same thing with
administration costs right down the
middle
you get this dark row or dark um
diagonal row
that shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same and as it becomes lighter there's
less connections between the data
so we can see with profit obviously
profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier
and it has a slightly less connection to
marketing spending and even less to how
much money we put into the
administration
so now that we have a nice look at the
data let's go ahead and dig
in and create some actual useful linear
regression models so that we can predict
values and have a better profit now that
we've taken a look at the visualization
of this data we're going to move on to
the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard
data some hard values so let's see what
that looks like
we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps
the first one is we need to prepare some
of our data so it fits correctly
and let's go ahead and paste this code
into our jupyter notebook and what we're
bringing in is we're going to bring in
the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder
and the one hot encoder to use the label
encoder we're going to create a variable
called label encoder and set it equal to
capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can
reuse for transferring the labels back
and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before
and see what i'm talking about here if
you remember when we did the companies
dot head and we printed the top
five rows of data we have our columns
going across
we have column zero which is r and d
spending
column one which is administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state and you'll see
under state we have new york california
florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process new
york
it knows how to process a number so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to change that new york california
and florida
and we're going to change those to
numbers that's what this line of code
does here
x equals and then it has the colon comma
3
in brackets the first part the colon
comma means that we're going to look at
all the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row
and in there we're going to take the
label coder and we're going to fit and
transform
the x also the third row so we're going
to take that third row we're going to
set it equal to a transformation
and that transformation basically tells
it that instead of having
a new york it has a zero or a one or a
two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals
one hot inc or categorical features
equals three
and then we take the x and we go ahead
and do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation
preps our data force so it's completely
set the way we need it as just a row of
numbers
even though it's not in here let's go
ahead and print x
and just take a look what this data is
doing you'll see you have an array of
arrays
and then each array is a row of numbers
and if i go ahead and just do row 0
you'll see i have a nice organized row
of numbers that the computer now
understands
we'll go ahead and take this out there
because it doesn't mean a whole lot to
us it's just a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important
why because the computers automatically
transformed
our header into the setup and it's
automatically transformed all these
different variables
so when we did the encoder the encoder
created two columns and what we need to
do is just have the one
because it has both the variable and the
name that's what this piece of code does
here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x
colon comma one colon all this is doing
is removing that one extra column we put
in there when we did our one hot encoder
and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model and let's see what that looks like
here and we're going to do that in two
steps
the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model
and train it and set it up let's go
ahead and paste this next piece of code
in here
and i'll go ahead and shrink it down a
size or two so it all fits on one line
so from the sklearn module selection
we're going to import train test split
and you'll see that we've created
four completely different variables we
have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different
models you usually see that a capital x
and you see the train and the test and
the lower case y
what this is is x is our data going in
that's our r and d
spin our administration our marketing
and then y
which we're training is the answer
that's the profit because we want to
know the profit
of an unknown entity so that's what
we're going to shoot for in this
tutorial the next part train test split
we take
x and we take y we've already created
those
x has the columns with the data in it
and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going to set the test size
equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent
so 20 of the rows are going to be tested
we're going to put them off to the side
so since we're using a thousand lines of
data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later
and then the random state equals zero
we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this
it's not overly exciting cause it's
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model
now that we got to the linear regression
model we get that next piece of the
puzzle
let's go ahead and put that code in
there and walk through it so here we go
we're going to paste it in there and
let's go ahead and
since this is a shorter line of code
let's zoom up there so we can get a good
look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now i don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization
and then we also looked at setting it up
with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to
multiple linear regression where we're
adding all those formulas together
all of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually
and then we do the regressor.fit in this
case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data
x being the data in and y being profit
what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line
we've created the whole linear
regression model and we fit the data to
the linear regression model and you can
see that when i run the regressor
it gives an output linear regression it
says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model
now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it
and if you remember we kept a bunch of
data aside so we're going to do a y
predict variable and we're going to put
in the x test
and let's see what that looks like
scroll up a little bit paste that in
here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y
predict equals regressor dot predict x
test going in and this gives us y
predict
now because i'm in jupiter inline i can
just put the variable up there
and when i hit the run button it'll
print that array out
i could have just as easily done print
why predict
so if you're in a different ide that's
not an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side
it's going to produce 200 answers this
is what it says the profit are for those
200 predictions
but let's don't stop there let's keep
going and take a couple look we're going
to take just a short
detail here and calculating the
coefficients and the intercepts
this gives us a quick flash at what's
going on behind the line
we're going to take a short detour here
and we're going to be calculating the
coefficient
and intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice
about our regressor we created is it
already has a coefficients for us
we can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore
when i run this you'll see our
coefficients here and if we can do the
regressor coefficient
we can also do the regressor intercept
and let's run that and take a look at
that this all came from the multiple
regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from
you can see the formula down here where
y equals m1 times
x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and so on
plus c
the coefficient so these variables fit
right into this formula
y equals slope one times column one
variable
plus slope two times column two variable
all the way to the
m into the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient
or in this case you have minus eight
point eight nine
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column
and then our intercept is the minus 1 0
3 0
0 9 point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it
this is why we don't do this by hand
anymore this is why we have the computer
to make these calculations easy to
understand and calculate
now i told you that was a short detour
and we're coming towards the end of our
script
as you remember from the beginning i
said if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works
so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use
to predict how good our prediction is
and let's take a look what that looks
like in code
and so we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
r2 score that's the r squared value
we're looking at the
error so in the r2 score we take our y
test versus our y predict y
test is the actual values we're testing
that was the one that was given to us so
we know are true
the y predict of those 200 values is
what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage
so it's not saying it's 93 percent
correct but you do want that in the
upper 90s
oh and higher shows that this is a very
valid prediction based on the r2 score
and if r squared value of 0.91 or 9 2 as
we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good
model which means success yay we
successfully trained our model with
certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be
whether they're going to repay their
loan or not for his bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount
or not and then we're going to be using
the decision tree algorithm in python
let's see what that looks like and let's
dive into the code
in our first few steps of implementation
we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over
and here i'm using the anaconda jupiter
notebook
now you can use any python ide you like
to run it in but i find the jupiter
notebook's really nice for doing things
on the fly
and let's go ahead and just paste that
code in the beginning and before we
start
let's talk a little bit about what we're
bringing in and then we're going to do a
couple things in here we have to make a
couple changes as we go through this
first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as np
that's very standard when we're dealing
with mathematics especially with uh very
complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num
your number it's called number python it
has your mathematics in there in this
case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with
and then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the
pandas is a data frame setup and you can
liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks
like an excel spreadsheet so as we come
back to this when you see
np or pd those are very standard uses
you'll know that that's the pandas
and i'll show you a little bit more when
we explore the data in just a minute
then we're going to need to split the
data so i'm going to bring in our train
test and split and this is coming from
the sk learn
package cross validation in just a
minute we're going to change that and
we'll go over that too and then there's
also the sk.tree import decision tree
classifier that's the actual tool we're
using remember i told you don't be
afraid of the mathematics it's going to
be done for you
well the decision tree classifier has
all that mathematics in there for you so
you don't have to figure it back out
again and then we have sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says
i need to read a file and when this was
written
the person who wrote it this is their
path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path
i'm just going to call it full file name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy
setup on here where i stored the
data2.csv
file don't worry too much about the full
path because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated
by simplylearn if you want a copy of
that you can comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to
full file name so let's go ahead and run
it now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a
opportunity to understand what's going
on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation
is depreciated so it's a warning on it's
being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation
and if you research this and go to the
sklearn site you'll find out that you
can actually just swap it right in there
with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one
that's all that is and very easy and
quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the
data underscore2.csv let's talk a little
bit more about that and see what that
looks like both as a text file
because it's a comma separated variable
file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got
one two three four five columns and each
column has data in it and let me flip
this over because we're also going to
look at this uh
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as
excel and zoomed in and you can see
we've got our columns
and our rows of data a little easier to
read in here we have a result
yes yes no we have initial payment last
payment credit score
house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1 000 lines of data
now as a programmer if you're looking at
a small amount of data i usually start
by pulling it up in different sources so
i can see what i'm working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be
too too large so you need to either
bring in a small amount that you can
look at it like we're doing right now
or we can start looking at it through
the python code so let's go ahead and
move on
and take the next couple steps to
explore the data using python
let's go ahead and see what it looks
like in python to print the length and
the shape of the data
so let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this you'll see that it's
a thousand
long and that's what we expected there's
a thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the
column head this is one of the nice
things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines
it also tells me there's five columns so
we were looking at the data we had five
columns of data
and then let's take one more step to
explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape
let's go ahead and use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize
so let's put that on our sheet here and
we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there
and then we went ahead and gave a label
for our print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that and let's just take a
closer look at that let me zoom in here
there we go pandas does such a wonderful
job
of making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can
have it when you put it as the head it
prints the first five lines of the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two
three four instead of one two three four
five that's a standard
scripting and programming set as you
wanna start with the zero position
and that is what the data head does it
pulls the first five rows of data
puts in a nice format that you can look
at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet
or open office cal or trying to look at
a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read you can now
get a nice
open view of what you're working with
we're working with a shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns
and we do the full data head you can
actually see what this data looks like
the initial payment
last payment credit scores house number
so let's take this now that we've
explored the data and let's start
digging into the decision tree
so in our next step we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that
we need to first separate the date out
we're going to separate into two groups
so that we have something to actually
train the data with and
then we have some data on the side to
test it to see how good our model is
remember with any of the machine
learning you always want to have some
kind of test set
to to weigh it against so you know how
good your model is when you distribute
it
let's go ahead and break this code down
and look at it in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data and y is going to
be the answer or the target you can look
at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in
and the data that we're actually trying
to guess what the answer is going to be
and so to separate it we can simply put
in
x equals the balance of the data.values
the
first brackets means that we're going to
select
all the lines in the database so it's
all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not
so we want to start with one if we go
back up here that's the initial payment
and it goes all the way through the
house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for
y which is the answers and we're going
to set that just
equal to the zero row so it's just the
zero row
and then it's all rows going in there so
now we've divided this into
two different data sets one of them with
the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test
your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules
this does it all for us and you can see
they set the test size equal to 0.3
so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there
and then finally we get to actually
build our decision tree
and they've called it here clf
underscore entropy
that's the actual decision tree or
decision tree classifier
and in here they've added a couple
variables which we'll explore in just a
minute
and then finally we need to fit the data
to that
so we take our clf entropy that we
created and we fit the x
train and since we know the answers for
x trait or the y train
we go ahead and put those in and let's
go ahead and run this
and what most of these sklearn modules
do
is when you set up the variable in this
case we set the clf
entropy called decision tree classifier
it automatically prints out what's in
that decision tree
there's a lot of variables you can play
within here and it's quite beyond the
scope
of this tutorial to go through all of
these and how they work
but we're working on entropy that's one
of the options we've added that it's
completely a random state of 100 so 100
percent
and we have a max depth of three now the
max depth if you remember above when we
were doing the different graphs of
animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops
and then we have minimal samples of
leaves as five so it's going to have at
least
five leaves at the end so i'll have at
least three splits i'll have no more
than three layers
and at least five end leaves with the
final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it
let's go ahead and apply it and see what
that looks like so let's go ahead and
make a prediction
and see what that looks like we're going
to paste our predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created and then you'll
see dot predict
and it's very common in the sk learn
modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and
distributed it this would be the new
loans you're putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is it
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the y
predict e in to print it i could just as
easily put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out
we'll go ahead and do that it doesn't
matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly
300 in here remember it's 30 percent of
a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our
test went in there and this is what our
y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data
and try to figure out just how good a
model we have so here we go since
sklearn does all the heavy lifting for
you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is
and let's go ahead and go through that
and see what that means and what that
looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go so you have a nice full
picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see
where that's coming from that's coming
from here down here from sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score and you could
probably run a script make your own
script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
did we get right
and so we put in our y test that's the
one we ran the predict on
and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal
and we want to see it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit
we can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that
we now have accuracy set up on here and
so we have created a model that uses the
decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not
the accuracy of the model is about 94.6
percent
the bank can now use this model to
decide whether it should approve the
loan request from a particular customer
or not
and so this information is really
powerful we may not be able to as
individuals understand all these numbers
because they have thousands of numbers
that come in but you can see that this
is a smart decision for the bank to use
a tool like this
to help them to predict how good their
profit's going to be
off of the loan balances and how many
are going to default or not
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering
what is clustering k means clustering
which is one of the most common used
clustering tools out there
including a flow chart to understand
k-means clustering and how it functions
and then we'll do an actual python live
demo on clustering of cars based on
brands
then we're going to cover logistic
regression what is logistic regression
logistic regression curve and sigmoid
function
and then we'll do another python code
demo to classify a tumor as malignant or
benign
based on features and let's start with
clustering
suppose we have a pile of books of
different genres
now we divide them into different groups
like fiction
horror education and as we can see from
this young lady she definitely is into
heavy [ __ ] you can just tell by those
eyes
and the maple canadian leaf on her shirt
but we have fiction
horror and education and we want to go
ahead and divide our books up
well organizing objects into groups
based on similarity is
clustering and in this case as we're
looking at the books we're talking about
clustering things with known
categories but you can also use it to
explore data so you might not know the
categories
you just know that you need to divide it
up in some way to conquer the data
and to organize it better but in this
case we're going to be looking at
clustering in specific categories
and let's just take a deeper look at
that we're going to use k
means clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library
k-means clustering is an example of
unsupervised learning
if you remember from our previous thing
it is used when you have
unlabeled data so we don't know the
answer yet we have a bunch of data that
we want to cluster to different groups
define clusters in the data based on
feature similarity
so we've introduced a couple terms here
we've already talked about
unsupervised learning and unlabeled data
so we don't know the answer yet we're
just going to group stuff together and
see if we can find
an answer of how things connect we've
also
introduced feature similarity features
being different features of the data
now with books we can easily see fiction
and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data
some of that information isn't so easy
to see right when we first look at it
and so k-means is one of those tools
where we can start finding things that
connect
that match with each other suppose we
have these data points and want to
assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together
but in k-means we pick k clusters and
assign
random centroids to clusters where the k
clusters represents two different
clusters we pick k
clusters and cirandom centroids to the
clusters then we compute
distance from objects to the centroids
now we form new clusters based on
minimum distances and calculate the
centroids
so we figure out what the best distance
is for the centroid then we move the
centroid and recalculate those distances
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stop changing
their positions and become static
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stop changing
and the positions become static
once the clusters become static then k
means clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged
that means whatever math we're using to
figure out the answer
has come to a solution or it's converged
on an answer
so we see the flowchart to understand
make a little bit more sense by putting
it into a nice easy step by step
so we start we choose k we'll look at
the elbow method in just a moment
we assign random centroids to clusters
and sometimes you pick the centroids
because you might look at the data in a
graph and say oh these are probably the
central points
then we compute the distance from the
objects to the centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids
then we compute the distance from
objects to the new centroids
and then we go back and repeat those
last two steps we calculate the
distances
so as we're doing it it brings into the
new centroid
and then we move the centroid around and
we figure out what the best
which objects are closest to each
centroid so the objects can switch from
one centroid to the other the centroids
are moved around
and we continue that until it is
converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics a and b
so here's our subject in this case
referring to
the person taking the test and then we
have subject a where
we see what they've scored on their
first subject and we have subject b
and we can see what they score on the
second subject now let's take two
farthest apart points as initial cluster
centroids
remember we talked about selecting them
randomly or we can also just put them in
different points and pick the furthest
one apart so they move together
either one works okay depending on what
kind of data you're working on and what
you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one
and five and seven and now let's take
the two farthest apart
points as initial cluster centroids each
point is then assigned to the closest
cluster with respect to the distance
from the centroids
so we take each one of these points in
there we measure that distance and you
can see that
if we measure each of those distances
and you use the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know
the x and the y and you can figure out
the diagonal line from that or you just
take a ruler and put it on your monitor
that'd be kind of
silly but it would work if you're just
eyeballing it you can see how they
naturally
come together in certain areas now we
again calculate the centroids of each
cluster
so cluster one and then cluster two and
we look at
each individual dot there's one two
three we're in one cluster
the centroid then moves over it becomes
one point eight comma two point three so
remember is that one and one
well the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 2 2 but 1.8 and 2.3
and the second one if we wanted to make
the overall
mean vector the average vector of all
the different distances to that centroid
we come up with four comma one and five
four so we've now moved the centroids
we compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean
and to that of the opposite cluster and
we find
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move that centroid around
we now have a new different kind of
clustering of groups and using euclidean
distance between the points and the mean
we get the same formula you see these
new formulas coming up so we have our
individual dots
distance to the mean centroid of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster
only individual three is nearer to the
mean of the opposite cluster
cluster two than its own cluster one and
you can see here in the diagram where
we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster
the centroids are the clusters over one
of the points shifted to the other
cluster
because it's closer to that group of
individuals thus individual three is
relocated to cluster two resulting in a
new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the
centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here
on comparing the distance of each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean
and to that of the opposite cluster we
find that the data points are stable
hence we have our final clusters now if
you remember i brought up a concept
earlier
caming on the k-means algorithm choosing
the right value of k
will help in less number of iterations
and to find the appropriate number of
clusters in a data set
we use the elbow method and within
sum of squares wss is defined as the sum
of the squared
distance between each member of the
cluster in its centroid
and so you see we've done here is we
have the number of clusters
and as you do the same k-means
algorithm over the different clusters
and you calculate what that centroid
looks like and you find the optimal you
can actually
find the optimal number of clusters
using the elbow the graph
is called as the elbow method and on
this we guessed it two just by looking
at the data but as you can see
the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is in the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want
two different to start with k means
equals two a lot of times people end up
computing
k-means equals two three four five until
they find
the value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific
domain remember domain i mentioned that
last time
you'll know that where to pick those
numbers or where to start guessing at
what that k value is
so let's take this when we're going to
use a use case
using k-means clustering to cluster cars
into brands
using parameters such as horsepower
cubic inches
make year etc so we're going to use the
dataset cars data
having information about three brands of
cars toyota
honda and nissan we'll go back to my
favorite tool
the anaconda navigator with the jupiter
notebook and let's go ahead and flip
over to our jupiter notebook
and in our jupyter notebook i'm going to
go ahead and just paste the basic
code that we usually start a lot of
these off with we're not going to go too
much into this code because we've
already discussed
numpy we've already discussed matplot
library and pandas
they'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame
and map plot for the graphing and don't
forget uh since if you're using the
jupiter notebook you do need the map
plot library inline
so that it plots everything on the
screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a pop-up
window on your computer
we'll go ahead and run this just to load
our libraries and our setup into here
the next step is of course to look at
our data which i've already opened up in
a
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
the miles per gallon
cylinders cubic inches horsepower weight
pounds
how you know how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90.
what year it is so this is you can
actually see this is kind of older cars
and then the brand toyota
honda nissan so the different cars are
coming from all the way from 1971 if we
scroll down
to the 80s we have between the 70s and
80s the number of cars that they've put
out
and let's uh we come back here we're
going to importing the data so we'll go
ahead and do
data set equals and we'll use pandas to
read this in
and it's uh from a csv file remember you
can always post this
in the comments and request the data
files for these
either in the comments here on the
youtube video or go to simplylearn.com
and request that
the car csv i put it in the same folder
as the code that i've stored so my
python code is stored in the same folder
so i don't have to put the full path
if you store them in different folders
you do have to change this and double
check your name variables
and we'll go ahead and run this and
we've chosen dataset
arbitrarily because it's a data set
we're importing and we've now imported
our car csv
into the data set as you know you have
to prep the data so we're going to
create the x data this is the
one that we're going to try to figure
out what's going on with
and then there's a number of ways to do
this but we'll do it in a simple loop so
you can actually see what's going on
so we'll do four i and x dot
columns so we're going to go through
each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important i'll
make lists of the columns
and do this because i might remove
certain columns or there might be
columns that
i want to be processed differently but
for this
we can go ahead and take x of i and we
want to go
fill in a and that's a pandas command
but the question is what are we going to
fill the
missing data with we definitely don't
want to just put in
a number that doesn't actually mean
something and so one of the tricks you
can do with this
is we can take x of i and in addition to
that we want to go ahead and turn this
into an integer because a lot of these
are integers
so we'll go ahead and keep it integers
and let me add the bracket here and a
lot of editors will do this they'll
think that you're closing one bracket
make sure you get that second bracket in
there if it's a double bracket
that's always something that happens
regularly so once we have our integer of
x of y this is going to fill in
any missing data with the average and i
was so busy closing one set of brackets
i forgot that the mean is also has
brackets in there for the pandas
so we can see here we're going to fill
in all the data with the average value
for that column so if there's missing
data it's in
the average of the data it does have
then once we've done that
we'll go ahead and loop through it again
and just check and see
to make sure everything is filled in
correctly and we'll print
and then we take x is null
and this returns a set of the null value
or the how many lines are null and we'll
just sum that up
to see what that looks like and so when
i run this and so with the x
what we want to do is we want to remove
the last column because that had the
models that's what we're
trying to see if we can cluster these
things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out
for one we could take the x and we could
go
data set our variable we're using and
use the i location
one of the features that's in pandas and
we could take that
and then take all the rows and all but
the last
column of the data set and at this time
we could do
values we just convert it to values so
that's one way to do this and if i
let me just put this down here and print
x
it's a capital x we chose and i run this
you can see it's just the values
we could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the i location which
does integers
more common is to come in here and we
have our data set
and we're going to do data set dot
or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns
so if i come in here let me just
mark that as red and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand
would be to do data columns of
everything but the last
one minus one so now if i print this
you'll see the brand disappears
and so i can actually just take data set
columns
minus one and i'll put it right in here
for the columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this and unmark
this and now if i
do an x dot head i have a
new data frame and you can see right
here we have
all the different columns except for the
brand at the end of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set
you're going to get an error later on
and it'll say cannot convert
string to float value and that's because
if for some reason these things the way
they recorded them must been recorded as
strings
so we have a neat feature in here on
pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert
underscore numeric
numeric equals true
and yes i did have to go look that up i
don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there
if i'm working with a lot of these
things i remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up
and we run that oops i must have missed
something in here let me double check my
spelling and when i double check my
spilling you'll see i missed the first
underscore in the convert objects
when i run this it now has everything
converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data
and eliminate null values most people
when they're doing small amounts
working with small data pools discover
afterwards that they have a null value
and they have to go back and do this
so you know be aware whenever we're
formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
x of i we're going to change that we're
going to alter it
and so with this we want to go ahead and
fill in
x of i pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data then we'll put my brackets
up and there's a lot of different ways
to fill this data if you have a really
large data set some people just void out
that data because they and then look at
it later in a separate
exploration of data one of the tricks we
can do
is we can take our column and we can
find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means
the problem is that returns a decimal
float so
some of these aren't decimals certainly
let me be a little
careful of doing this but for this
example we're just going to fill it in
with the integer version of this it
keeps it on par with the other data that
isn't
a decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right
so we're going to go through and test
for
missing data and one of the ways you can
do that is simply go in here
and take our x of i column
so it's going to go through the x of i
column it says is null
so it's going to return any any place
there's a null value it actually goes
through
all the rows of each column is null
and then we want to go ahead and sum
that so we take that and we add the sum
value
and these are all pandas so is null is a
panda command and so is sum
and if we go through that we go ahead
and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns
have zero null values so we've now
tested and double checked and our data
is nice and clean we have no
null values everything is now a number
value we turned it into numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to start using the elbow method to find
the optimal number of clusters
so we're now actually getting into the
sk learn part uh the k
means clustering on here well i guess
we'll go ahead and zoom it up one more
not so you can see what i'm typing in
here
and then from sk learn we're going to
or sk sklearn cluster
i'm going to import k
means i always forget to capitalize the
k and the m
when i do this so it's capital k capital
m k
means and we'll go and create a
ray wcss equals when we get an empty
array
if you remember from the elbow method
from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of
square distance between each member of
the cluster and the centroid
so we're looking at that change in
differences as far as a squared distance
and we're going to run this over a
number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
range zero eleven and the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
create the actual
do it all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this
is in clusters and we're going to set
that equals to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings
to the k-means our guys in the back did
a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones
that you see in a lot of stuff is how
you init your k-means
so we have k means plus plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
incentroids
we only want to iterate no more than 300
times we have a max iteration we put in
there we have
the infinite the random state equals
zero
you really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this
as you start digging in deeper you start
finding that these are shortcuts
that will speed up the process as far as
a setup but the big one that we're
working with is the in
clusters equals i so we're going to
literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process
11 times and if you're working with
big data you know the first thing you do
is you run a small sample of the data so
you can test all your stuff on it
and you can already see the problem that
if i'm going to iterate through a
terabyte of data
11 times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times
that's a heck of a process so you got to
be a little careful with this
a lot of times though you can find your
elbow
using the elbow method find your optimal
number on a sample of data especially if
you're working with
larger data sources so we want to go
ahead and take our k-means and we're
just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sklearn
very common
that you fit your model and if you
remember correctly our variable we're
using
is the capital x and once we fit this
value
we go back to the array we made and we
want to go and just depend that value on
the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it
generates it it generates the value
you're looking for is
inertia so k means dot inertia will pull
that specific value out that we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our plt
plot and what we're plotting here
is first the x-axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there
and the wcss for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title
and let's get some labels so let's go
ahead and do plt
x label and we'll do a number of
clusters for that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph
which is simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline
it'll appear in line hopefully i didn't
make a type error on there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at
two and again right around three and
four and then after that there's not
very much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use
three as a setup on here and let's go
ahead and see what that looks like when
we actually use this
to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars
data set and basically we're going to
copy the code that we loop through up
above
where k-means equals k-means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to 3.
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do 3 and 4
on this and graph them just to see how
they come up differently be kind of
curious to look at that
but for this we're just going to set it
to 3. go ahead and create our own
variable
y k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there
to k means but we're not going to do a
fit
we're going to do a fit predict is the
setup you want to use
and when you're using untrained models
you'll see
a slightly different usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict
but we want to both fit and predict the
k-means on this
and that's fit underscore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick
we're going to take our x value and
we're going to set x as
matrix so we're converting this into a
nice rows and columns kind of set up but
we want the
we're going to have columns equals none
so it's just going to be a matrix of
data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated
so there's like minor changes in the
versions and future versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot
values instead of doing as matrix but
math matrix works just fine for right
now
and you'll want to update that later on
but let's go ahead and dive in and plot
this and see what that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see
what i am plotting so let's take a look
at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1
0 2 1 2. so it's clustering these
different rows of data based on the
three different
spaces it thinks it's going to be and
then let's go ahead and print
x and see what we have for x and we'll
see that x
is an array it's a matrix so we have our
different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array
so we're only going to be looking at the
first two
or positions 0 and 1.
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the
board meeting you might actually do a
little different than and dig a little
deeper into the different
aspects because this is all the
different columns we looked at but we
look at columns one and two for this to
make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and this looks a little complicated so
let's explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means
equals zero the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the x axes and then we're going to do
the same thing here
we're only interested in k means equals
zero but we're going to take this second
column so we're looking at the first
two columns in our answer or in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
with as the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out
it was definitely the toyota on this
we're just going to go ahead and label
it toyota
again that's something you really have
to explore in here
as far as playing with those numbers and
see what looks good
we'll go ahead and hit enter in there
and i'm just going to paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where
y underscore k means equals one and we
want the zero column and y k means
equals two again we're looking at just
the first two columns zero
and one and each of these rows then
corresponds to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and finally
let's take a look and put the centroids
on there again we're going to do a
scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means
the model we created dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with 0 and 1.
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow
and we'll label them it's always good to
have some good labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title and pop up there
plt title cause you always want to make
your graphs look pretty and we'll call
it clusters of
car make and one of the features
of the plot library is you can add
a legend it'll automatically bring in
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's inline
so if you're using a different editor
that's not the jupiter notebook
you'll get a pop-up of this and you
should have a nice set of clusters here
so we can look at this and we have a
clusters of honda and green
toyota and red nissan and purple and you
can see where they put the centroids to
separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other
different data on here as far because we
only looked at the first two columns
this is just column one and two
or zero one as you label them in
computer scripting
but you can see here we have nice
clusters of car make and we were able to
pull out the data
and you can see how just these two
columns
form very distinct clusters of data so
if you were exploring new data you might
take a look and say well what makes
these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the date and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is
maybe you're doing loans and you want to
go well why is this group not defaulting
on their
loans and why is the last group
defaulting on their loans and why is the
middle
group 50 defaulting on their bank loans
and you start finding ways to manipulate
the data and pull out the answers you
want
so now that you've seen how to use k
mean
for clustering let's move on to the next
topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm
is the simplest classification algorithm
used for binary or multi-classification
problems
and we can see we have our little girl
from canada who's into horror books is
back
that's actually really scary when you
think about that with those big eyes
in the previous tutorial we learned
about linear regression
dependent and independent variables so
to brush up y equals mx plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1
all the way up to xn are the features or
attributes we're going to use to predict
the target class
we know what a linear regression looks
like but using the graph we cannot
divide the outcome into categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8 for example a linear regression
graph can tell us
that with increase in number of hours
studied
the marks of a student will increase but
it will not tell us whether the student
will pass or not
in such cases where we need the output
as categorical value
we will use logistic regression and for
that we're going to use the sigmoid
function
so you can see here we have our marks 0
to 100
number of hours studied that's going to
be what they're comparing it to
in this example and we usually form a
line that says y equals
mx plus c and when we use the sigmoid
function
we have p equals 1 over 1 plus e to the
minus
y it generates a sigmoid curve
and so you can see right here when you
take the ln
which is the natural logarithm i always
thought it should be
nl not ln that's just the inverse of
e your e to the minus y and so we do
this we get
ln of p over one minus p equals m
times x plus c that's the sigmoid curve
function we're looking for
and we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function
as it derives goes to 1 or to 0
depending on what your x value is and
the probability if it's greater than
0.5 the value is automatically rounded
off to
1 indicating that the student will pass
so if they're doing a certain amount of
studying
they will probably pass then you have a
threshold value at the 0.5
it automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to zero
indicating the student will fail so if
they're not studying very hard
they're probably going to fail this of
course is ignoring the outliers or that
one student is just a natural genius and
doesn't need any studying to memorize
everything
that's not me unfortunately i have to
study hard to learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant
or benign and this is actually one of my
favorite
data sets to play with because it has so
many features
and when you look at them you really are
hard to understand
you can't just look at them and know the
answer so it gives you a chance to kind
of dive into what data looks like when
you aren't able to understand the
specific domain of the data
but i also want you to remind you that
in the domain of medicine
if i told you that my probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90
or 95 and i'm classifying whether you're
going to have a malignant or a b9 tumor
i'm guessing that you're going to go get
it tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with
so why would you want to do that if you
know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because
you know it's that serious this is like
an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor
know where to look just by understanding
what kind of tumor it is so it might
help them or aid them and something they
missed from before
so let's go ahead and dive into the code
and i'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal imports here
we're importing numpy pandas seaborn the
matplot library
and we're going to do matplot library in
line since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda
so let's go ahead and flip over there
and get this started so i've opened up a
new window
in my anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupiter notebook
i just love the interface and all the
tools and anaconda brings
so we got our import numpy as in p for
our
numpy number array we have our pandas pd
we're going to bring in seaborn to help
us with our graphs as
sns so many really nice tools in both
seaborne and matplot library
and we'll do our matplotlibrary.pipelot
as plt
and then of course we want to let it
know to do it in line and let's go and
just run that so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file so we'll use the pd.read
underscore csv and i happen to name the
file i renamed it
dataforp2.csv you can of course
write in the comments below the youtube
and request for the data set itself or
go to the simply learn website and we'll
be happy to supply that for you
and let's just open up the data before
we go any further and let's just see
what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just
a csv file comma separated variables we
have an id
so i guess the categorize this for
reference or what id which test was done
the diagnosis m for malignant b
for b9 so there's two different options
on there and that's what we're going to
try to predict is the m and b and test
it
and then we have like the radius mean or
average the texture
average perimeter mean area mean
smoothness
i don't know about you but unless you're
a doctor in the field
most of stuff i mean you can guess what
concave means just by the term concave
but i really wouldn't know what that
means in the measurements they're taking
so they have all kinds of stuff like how
smooth it is
the symmetry and these are all float
values let me just page through them
real quick
and you'll see there's i believe 36 if i
remember correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at
the different growth the tumorous growth
so
back in our data and i put this in the
same folder as a code so i
saved this code in that folder obviously
if you have it in a different location
you want to put the full path in there
and we'll just do pandas
first five lines of data with the data
dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id
we have a diagnosis if we go all the way
across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely
for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as
sns makes it very easy to go in here and
do a
joint plot you'll notice that very
similar to
because it is sitting on top of the plot
library
so the joint plot does a lot of work for
us and we're just going to look at the
first two
columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean
we'll just look at those two columns and
data
equals data so that tells it which two
columns we're plotting
and then we're going to use the data
that we pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at i mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram
they show that for the radius mean
whereas the most commons radius mean
come up and where the most common
texture is
so we're looking at the tech the on each
growth its average texture
and on each radius it's average radius
on there it gets a little confusing
because we're talking about the
individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the the histogram
showing us the median or how common
each measurement is and that's only two
columns
so let's dig a little deeper into
seaborn they also have a heat map
and if you're not familiar with heat
maps a heat map just means it's in color
that's all that means heat map i guess
the original ones were plotting heat
density on something and so
ever since then it's just called a heat
map and we're going to take our data
and get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map
and that's simply data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas
for our data and this is pull that
information into a heat map and see what
that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features
we have our id we have our texture we
have our area
our compactness concave points and if
you look down the middle
of this chart diagonal going from the
upper left to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture
so these have almost no corresponding
data they don't really form a linear
graph or something that you can look at
and say how connected they are they're
very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data
doesn't so much change what you do but
it changes
verifying so when you get an answer or
something like that or you start looking
at some of these individual
pieces you might go hey that doesn't
match according to
showing our heat map this should not
correlate with each other and if it is
you're going to have to start asking
well why what's going on what else is
coming in there but it does show some
really cool information on here
and we can see from the id there's no
real
one feature that just says if you go
across the top line
that lights up there's no one feature
that says hey if the area is a certain
size
then it's going to be b9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort
of add up and that's a big hint in the
data that we're trying to id this
whether it's malignant or b9 that's a
big hint to us as data scientists to go
okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it
and while we're exploring the data let's
explore one more area
and let's look at data dot is null we
want to check
for null values in our data if you
remember from earlier
in this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we added stuff
up and sum them up you can actually with
pandas do it really quickly data dot is
null
and summit and it's going to go across
all the columns so when i run
this you're going to see all the columns
come up with no
null data so we've just
just to re hash these last few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seen how they plot with the seaborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram
and the data plotted on the xy
coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seaborne
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other
and forms a very nice combination or
points of scattering points
and you can also see areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data
null value do we have any missing data
in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process
and you've missed this step and now
you're 10 steps later and you've got to
remember where you were pulling the data
in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x and our y
so we just put that down here and we'll
set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do
x equals all the columns except for the
first two
because if remember the first two is the
id and the diagnosis
so that certainly would be an option but
we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on
the worst the worst radius the worst
texture
parameter area smoothness compactness
and so on one of the reasons to start
dividing your data up
when you're looking at this information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming into
my model it might overweigh them it
might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measuring it's basically taking that
information in twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces
and our team in the back went ahead and
said hey let's just look at the worst
so i'm going to create a an array and
you'll see this array
radius worst texture worse perimeter
worst we've just taken the worst of the
worst and i'm just going to put that in
my
x so this x is still a pandas data frame
but it's just those columns and our y
if you remember correctly is going to be
oops hold on one second
it's not x it's data there we go so x
equals data
and then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst
and if we're going to take that then we
have to have our answer for our y
for the stuff we know and if you
remember correctly we're just going to
be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it
b9 or malignant and since it's a single
column we can just do diagnosis oh i
forgot to put the brackets or
there we go okay so it's just diagnosis
on there
and we can also real quickly do like x
dot head if you want to see what that
looks like
and y dot head and run this
and you'll see um it only does the last
one i forgot about that if you don't do
print
you can see that the the y dot head is
just mmm because the first ones are all
malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first
five values of radius worst texture
worse parameter worst area worst and so
on
i'll go ahead and take that out so
moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test
your model so we do that by splitting
the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import
train test split so we're going to split
it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups
so you have all kinds and there's
reasons for that which is pass the scope
of this and for this particular example
isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split
you could write your own quick code to
do this we just randomly divide the data
up into two groups
but they do it for us nicely and we
actually can almost we can actually do
it in one statement with this
where we're going to generate four
variables capital x train
capital x test so we have our training
data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did
on our model and we'll go ahead and take
our train test split that we just
imported
and we're going to do x and our y our
two different
data that's going in for our split and
then the guys in the back
came up and wanted us to go ahead and
use a test size equals
0.3 that's test underscore size random
state
it's always nice to kind of switch a
random state around but not that
important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 percent of the
data
and we're going to put that into our
test variables our y
test and our x test and we're going to
do 70
into the x train and the y train so
we're going to use 70
of the data to train our model and 30 to
test it let's go ahead and run that
and load those up so now we have all our
stuff split up
and all our data ready to go and now we
get to the actual logistics part we're
actually going to do our create our
model so let's go ahead and bring that
in from sklearn we're going to bring in
our linear model
and we're going to import logistic
regression that's the actual model we're
using
and this we'll call it log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just
imported so now we have a variable log
model
set to that class for us to use and with
most the models in the sk
learn we just need to go ahead and fix
it fit
do a fit on there and we use our x train
that we separated out with our y train
and let's go ahead and run this so once
we've run this we'll have a model that
fits this data that 70 percent of our
training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make
but for word though we're just going to
let all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example
and there's nothing in here that really
stands out as super important
until you start fine tuning it but for
what we're doing the basics will work
just fine
and then let's we need to go ahead and
test out our model
is it working so let's create a variable
y predict
and this is going to be equal to our log
model and we want to do a predict again
very
standard format for the sklearn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it
and we're going to test why predict
against the y test
so we want to know what the model thinks
it's going to be that's what our y
predict is and with that we want the
capital x
x test so we have our train set and our
test set
and now we're going to do our y predict
and let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y predict let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of uh
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so that's pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and it's
functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science
that as you explore this you spend a
significant amount of time prepping your
data and making sure your data coming in
is good
there's a saying good data in good
answers out
bad data in bad answers out that's only
half the thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine tuning it
depending on what model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here
log model dot predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to
import classification report and that
just reports how good our model is doing
and then we're going to feed it the
model data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have a precision for
b9 and malignant b and m and we have a
precision of 93
and 91 a total of 92 so it's kind of the
average between these two
92 there's all kinds of different
information on here your f1 score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this i'll go ahead and just flip
back to our slides that they put
together for describing it
and so here we're going to look at the
precision using the classification
report
and you see this is the same printout i
had up above some of the numbers might
be different because it does
randomly pick out which data we're using
so
this model is able to predict the type
of tumor with
91 accuracy so we look back here let's
you'll see where we have uh b9 in
england it actually is 92 coming up here
but we're looking about a 92 91 percent
precision
and remember i reminded you about
domains and we're talking about the
domain of a medical domain
with a very catastrophic outcome you
know at 91 or 92 percent precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it
very different than if you're investing
money and there's a 92
chance you're going to earn 10 percent
and 8
chance you're going to lose 8 you're
probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run
you do that enough you definitely will
make money and also with this domain
i've actually seen them use this to
identify different forms of cancer
that's one of the things that they're
starting to use these models for because
then it helps the doctor know what to
investigate
so that wraps up this section we're
going to cover the k nearest neighbors
referred to as k n n and k n is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated
in other forms of machine learning so
today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n what is k n
how do we choose the factor k when do we
use
k n n how does k n algorithm work
and then we'll dive in to my favorite
part the use case
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set
as far as testing out models and
learning how to use the different models
in machine learning
by now we all know machine learning
models make predictions by learning from
the past data available
so we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know
and then we use that to create a
predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog
based on their characteristics cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears
meows and purrs doesn't love to play
around
dogs they have dull claws bigger length
of ears barks
loves to run around you usually don't
see a cat running around people although
i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws
how sharp are their claws and we can
evaluate the length of the ears
and we can usually sort out cats from
dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now
unless they live a place where there's
not many cats or dogs so if we look at
the sharpness of the claws the length of
the ears
and we can see that the cat has a
smaller ears
and sharper claws than the other animals
its features are more like cats
it must be a cat sharp claws length of
ears and goes in the cat group
because knn is based on feature
similarity we can do classification
using knn classifier
so we have our input value the picture
of the black cat it goes into our
trained model
and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so
what is knn what is the k n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification
so we want to know is this a dog or is
not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified
knn stores all available cases and
classifies
new cases based on a similarity measure
and here we go from cats and dogs right
into
wine another favorite of mine k n stores
all available cases
and classifies new cases based on a
similarity measure
and here you see we have a measurement
of sulfur dioxide
versus the chloride level and then the
different wines they've tested and where
they fall on that graph based on how
much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process
and so if we add a new glass of wine
there red or white
we want to know what the neighbors are
in this case we're going to put
k equals 5 we'll talk about k in just a
minute a data point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five
nearest neighbors here the unknown point
would be classified as red
since four out of five neighbors are red
so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose a factor k k n
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of k is a
process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy
so at k equals three we can classify we
have a question mark in the middle
as either a as a square or not is it a
square or is it
in this case a triangle and so if we set
k equals to 3 we're going to look at the
three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7
we classify as a triangle depending on
what the other data is around and you
can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer
and we jump here we go how do we choose
the factor of k
you'll find this in all machine learning
choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k
did i set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias
in one direction or the other and in
terms of k n
n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based
on it's just two noises it's right next
to a couple things and it's going to
pick
those things and you might get a skewed
answer and if your k is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues
and resource issues so what we do the
most common use and there's other
options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n
so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it
in most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using uh like this
case squares and triangles
if it's even you want to make your k
value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between
two different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n
and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it
and that's where you get the k value
from that is the most common use and
it's pretty solid
it works very well when do we use knn
we can use knn when data is labeled so
you need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats
data is noise free and so you can see
here
when we have a class and we have like
underweight 140
23 hello kitty normal that's pretty
confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and
that would cause an issue data set is
small so we're usually working with
smaller data sets where
you might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean
doesn't have a lot of noise because k n
is a lazy learner i.e it doesn't learn a
discriminative function from the
training set
so it's very lazy so if you have very
complicated data and you have a large
amount of it you're not going to use the
knn but it's really great to get a place
to start even with large data
you can sort out a small sample and get
an idea of what that looks like using
the knn
and also just using for smaller data
sets k n works really good
how does a k n algorithm work consider a
data set having two variables
height in centimeters and weight in
kilograms
and each point is classified as normal
or underweight
so we see right here we have two
variables you know true false they're
either normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn
so if we have new data coming in that
says 57 kilograms
and 177 centimeters is that going to be
normal or underweight
to find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by
distance d equals the square root of
x minus a squared plus y minus b squared
and you can remember that from the two
edges of a triangle we're computing the
third edge since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red
and we have our other points where the
data is scattered around the distance
d1 is the square root of 170 minus 167
squared plus 57 minus 51 squared
which is about 6.7 and distance
2 is about 13. and distance 3 is about
13.4
similarly we will calculate the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from
all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do it's
actually pretty quick for a computer and
it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance
hence we have calculated the euclidean
distance of unknown data point from
all the points as shown where x1 and y1
equal 57 and 170 whose class
we have to classify so now we're looking
at that we're saying well here's the
euclidean distance
who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals three
and we can see the three closest
neighbors puts them at
normal and that's pretty self-evident
when you look at this graph it's pretty
easy to say okay what
we're just voting normal normal normal
three votes for normal this is going to
be a normal weight
so majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k
n algorithm the class of 57 170 should
be normal
so recap of knn positive integer k
is specified along with a new sample we
select the k
entries in our database which are
closest to the new sample
we find the most common classification
of these entries this is the
classification we give to the new sample
so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in a use case
in python so let's dive into the predict
diabetes use case
so use case predict diabetes the
objective
predict whether a person will be
diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were
or were not diagnosed with diabetes and
let's go ahead and open that file and
just take a look at that data
and this is in a simple spreadsheet
format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have
columns a through i that's what one two
three four
five six seven eight eight columns
with a particular attribute and then the
ninth column which is the outcome is
whether they have diabetes
as a data scientist the first thing you
should be looking at is insulin well you
know if someone has insulin
they have diabetes that's why they're
taking it and that could cause issue in
some of the machine learning packages
but for a very basic setup this works
fine for
doing the k n and the next thing you
notice is it didn't take very much to
open it up
i can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer i can look at
it
i can manipulate it and it's not going
to really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss
what ide i'm using certainly can use any
particular editor for python but i like
to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos
with the jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the anaconda
navigator which is the new release out
there which is really nice
you can see under home i can choose my
application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments
i can create a unique environment for
each one which is nice
and there's even a little button there
where i can install different packages
so if i click on that button and open
the terminal i can use a simple pip
install to install different packages
i'm working with let's go ahead and go
back under home and we're going to
launch our notebook
and i've already you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up
a browser window in this case i'm going
to it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use
and since the script is pre-done you'll
see have a number of windows open up at
the top the one we're working in
and since we're working on the k n
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not let's go and put that
title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell
actually we want to go ahead and first
insert a cell below and then i'm going
to go back up
to the top cell and i'm going to change
the cell type to markdown
that means this is not going to run as
python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice
remind us what we're working on and by
now you should be familiar with doing
all of our
imports we're going to import the pandas
as pd
import numpy is np pandas is the
pandas data frame and numpy is a number
array very powerful tools to use in here
so we have our imports so we've brought
in our pandas our numpy
our two general python tools and then
you can see over here we have
our trained test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data
we want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model
and then we want to go ahead and test
the remaining data to see how good it is
pre-processing a standard scalar
preprocessor
so we don't have a bias of really large
numbers remember in the data we had like
number of pregnancies isn't going to get
very large
where the amount of insulin they take
can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so
they're all uniform between minus 1 and
1. and then the actual tool
this is the k neighbors classifier we're
going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test
all about testing our model how good is
it we just put down test on there and we
have our confusion matrix
our f1 score and our accuracy so we have
our two general
python modules we're importing and then
we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this
so these are actually imported there we
go and then move on to the next step
and so in this set we're going to go
ahead and load the database we're going
to use pandas remember pandas is pd
and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing
so here's our data set equals pd.read
csv
that's a pandas command and the diabetes
folder i just put in the same folder
where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there
we can also do a quick length of the
data set
that is a simple python command len for
length
we might even let's go ahead and print
that we'll go print and if you do it on
its own line
link that data set in the jupyter
notebook it'll automatically print it
but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas
we can simply do data set head and again
let's go ahead and add the print in
there if you put a bunch of these in a
row
you know the data set one head data set
two head it only prints out the last one
so i use always like to keep the print
statement in there but because
most projects only use one data frame
pandas data frame
doing it this way doesn't really matter
the other way works just fine
and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew
and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label
on the left remember the head only shows
the first five
lines so we have zero through four and
just a quick look at the data you can
see it matches what we looked at before
we have pregnancy glucose blood pressure
all the way to
age and then the outcome on the end and
we're going to do a couple things in
this next step
we're going to create a list of columns
where we can't have zero
there's no such thing as zero skin
thickness or zero blood pressure
zero glucose any of those you'd be dead
so not a really good factor if they
don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data
and we'll take a look at that because
we're going to start replacing that
information
with a couple of different things and
let's see what that looks like
so first we create a nice list as you
can see we have the values talked about
glucose blood pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on
a very common thing to do and then for
this particular setup we certainly could
use the there's some panda tools that
will do a lot of this where we can
replace the n a but we're going to go
ahead
and do it as a data set column equals
dataset column.replace this is this is
still
pandas you can do a direct there's also
one that's that you look for your nan
a lot of different options in here but
the nan numpy nan is what that stands
for
is none doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here
is we're replacing the zero with a numpy
none there's no data there that's what
that says that's what this is saying
right here
so put the zero in and we're going to
place zeros with
no data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead hope
they just didn't get the data the next
thing we want to do is we're going to
create the mean
which is the integer from the data set
from the column
dot mean where we skip n a's we can do
that
that is a pandas command there the skip
n a so we're going to figure out the
mean of that data
set and then we're going to take that
data set column and we're going to
replace
all the npn with the means
why did we do that we could have
actually just taken this step and gone
right down here and just replaced 0 and
skip anything
where except you could actually there's
a way to skip zeros and then just
replace all the zeros but in this case
we want to go ahead and do it this way
so you could see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
and we're going to create the mean
well this is the average person so
if we don't know what it is if they did
not get the data and the data is missing
one of the tricks is you replace it with
the average what is the most common
data for that this way you can still use
the rest of those values to do your
computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data
if you want to see what that looks like
it we don't have anything in the first
few
lines just not going to show up but we
certainly could look at a row
let's do that let's go into our data set
with printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels
going down and we thankfully don't see
anything in here that looks like
missing data at least on the ones it
shows you can see it skipped a bunch in
the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
you'll skip a few and
go on to the next in a data set let me
go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing
data that way we have something to train
it with and something to test it on
and you're going to notice we did a
little something here with the pandas
database code
there we go my drawing tool we've added
in this right here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one
in pandas this is from the pd pandas
it's going to say within the data set
we want to look at the eye location and
it is all rows that's what that says so
we're going to keep all the rows
but we're only looking at 0 column 0 to
8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer
yes column 9 but it's listed as 8 number
8
so 0 to 8 is 9 columns so 8 is the value
and when you see it in here
0 this is actually 0 to 7 it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column 8
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the
train test split that's part of the sk
learn
right there and we simply put in our x
and our y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up
and then the test size test size is 0.2
that simply means we're going to take 20
of the data and put it aside so that we
can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data
but that is a lot of this is prepping
this data once you prep it the actual
lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there with the actual
writing of our knn we need to go ahead
and do a scal the data
if you remember correctly we're fitting
the data in a standard scalar which
means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303
in one column and the next column is 1
to 6
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between -1
and 1. that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized
and we only want to fit the scalar with
the training set
but we want to make sure the testing set
is the x test going in
is also transformed so it's processing
it the same
so here we go with our standard scalar
we're going to call it sc underscore x
for the scalar
and we're going to import the standard
scalar into this variable
and then our x train equals sc
underscore x dot
fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable
and then our x test we're also going to
transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
and if you look at this we've now gone
through these
steps all three of them we've taken care
of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means of
those columns
that way that they fit right in with our
data models we've come down here we
split the data
so now we have our test data and our
training data and then we've taken and
we scaled the data
so all of our data going in no no we
don't tr we don't train the
y part the y train and y test that never
has to be trained
it's only the data going in that's what
we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit
the train data in the model so we do all
that data prep
and you can see down here we're only
going to have a couple lines of code
where we're actually building our model
and training it
that's one of the cool things about
python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools
let's see before we do this let's do a
quick length of
and let's do y we want let's just do
length of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root
let's do y train there we go it's
actually supposed to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do
math square root length of y test and
when i run that we get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use
12 is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote
don't want to have an even number of
neighbors voting so we want to do
something odd
and let's just take one away we'll make
it 11. let me delete this out of here
this one the reasons i love jupiter
notebook is you can flip around and do
all kinds of things on the fly
so we'll go ahead and put in our
classifier we're creating our classifier
now and it's going to be the k
neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an
odd number of neighbors p equals two
because we're looking for
is it are they diabetic or not and we're
using the
euclidean metric there are other means
of measuring the distance
you could do like square square means
values all kinds of measure this
but the euclidean euclidean's the most
common one and it works quite well
it's important to evaluate the model
let's use the confusion matrix to do
that
and we're going to use the confusion
matrix wonderful tool
and then we'll jump into the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most
commonly used quoted number when you go
into a meeting or something like that
so let's go ahead and paste that in
there and we'll set the cm
equal to confusion matrix y test y
predict
so those are the two values we're going
to put in there and let me go ahead and
run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y
predicted which would be your title up
here you could do
let's just do p r e d predicted across
the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that
this column here down the middle that's
the important column and it means that
our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94
and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong
so you could have like three different
if you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here and that column going down the
middle
so in the first case we have the the and
i believe the
zero is a 94 people who don't have
diabetes
the prediction said that 13 of those
people did have diabetes and were at
high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15
out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect
so you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix
then we're going to go ahead and print
the f1 score let me just run that
and you see we get a 0.69 in our f1
score
the f1 takes into account
both sides of the balance of false
positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account and that's what most
people think of
is it looks at just how many we got
right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the
decision makers in the business they're
going to ask what the accuracy is and
the accuracy is always better than
the f1 score but the f1 score is more
telling it lets us know that there's
more false positives than we would like
on here but 82 percent
not too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different
statistics and running an sk learn and
running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn
which can predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not
or at the very least whether they should
go get a checkup and have their
glucose checked regularly or not the
print accuracy score
we got the 0.818 was pretty close to
what we got and we can pretty much round
that off and just say we have an
accuracy of 80 percent
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model we're going to cover mathematics
for machine learning
so today's agenda is going to cover data
and its types
and we're going to dive into linear
algebra and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos and of course thrown in
there in the middle is going to be your
matrixes and a few other things to go
along with all this
data in its types data denotes the
individual pieces
of factual information collected from
various sources it is stored processed
and later used for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information
a lot of tech stuff money dollar signs
numbers and then you have your
performing analytics to drive insights
and hopefully you
have a nice share your shareholders
gather it at the meeting and you're able
to explain it in something they can
understand
so we talk about data types of data we
have
in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary
always people's favorite is the
vocabulary words
okay not mine uh but let's dive into
this what we mean by nominal
nominal they are used to label various
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label
it's on or off either they have a red
hat on or they do not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal
this is categorical data with a set
order or a scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one movie ratings etc
you can see here the salary rains if you
have 10 000 to 20 000
number of employees earning that rate is
150 20 000 to 30
100 and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket
uh this is where you have 10 different
buckets and you want to separate it into
something that makes sense into those 10
buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal
a lot of times when you get down to the
brass bones again we're talking true
false
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20k
reigns
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets and
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket
quantitative numerical data falls into
two classes
discrete or continuous and so data with
a final set of values which can be
categorized class strength questions
answered correctly
and runs hit and cricket a lot of times
when you see this you can think
integer and a very restricted integer
i.e you can only have 100 questions on a
test
so you can it's very discreet i only
have a hundred different values that it
can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open in
or anything like that uh so discrete is
very solid
simple to count set number continuous on
the other hand
continuous data can take any numerical
value within a range
so water pressure weight of a person etc
usually we start thinking about float
values where they can get phenomenally
small in their in what they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still
discrete but it starts to get
complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33 cents to
580.67 there's a lot of point values in
there
it'd still be called discrete but you
start looking at it as almost continuous
because
it does have such a variance in it now
uh we talked about no
we did we went over nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical
data which were starting to get into
numbers discrete
you can usually a lot of times discrete
will be put into it could be put into
true false but usually it's not
uh so we want to address this stuff and
the first thing you want to look at is
the very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at
linear algebra you can remember back
when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning
linear equations and their
representations in vector spaces and
through matrixes
i told you we're going to talk about
matrix is so
a linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10.
very linear 10x plus 12.4y
equals z and now you can actually solve
these two equations by combining them
and that's we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an
x y z plot um so each one is a direction
and the actual distance of like a
triangle a b
is c and then your matrix can describe
all kinds of things
i find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because
of the magnitude and the different
things are used for
and a matrix is a chart or a
you know think of a spreadsheet but you
have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts
so depending on how the math is being
done what you're using it for
making sure you have the same rows and
number of columns or a single number
there's all kinds of things that play in
that that can make matrixes confusing
but really has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in
are you adding in multiple polynomials
where you have like
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that can be very confusing
versus a very straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such
primary this is what we're here to talk
about is these different math
uh mathematical computations that come
up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have
ax plus b equals c which is a one
variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c
a x plus b y plus z c z equals d
and so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x squared you
don't see x
cubed so we're talking about linear
equations that's what we're talking
about
in their addition if you have already
dived into say
neural networks you should recognize
this a x plus b y plus c
z setup plus the intercept which is
basically your
your neural network each node adding up
all the different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula
is your y equals mx plus c
so you have your y equals the
m which is your slope your x value
plus c which is your
y-intercept you kind of label it wrong
here uh
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set
x equal to zero y equals c and that's
that's your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had a reverse
value of y when x equals zero
equals the y-intercept which is c and
your slow gradient line which is your
m so you get your y equals 2x plus 3.
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems
and then of course the one of the most
important takeaways is the slope
gradient of the line so the slope is
very important that
m value in this case we went ahead and
solved this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line
graph here on the right so
matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers
arranged in columns and rows so we're
talking
m rows by n columns here a11 is
denotes the element of the first row in
the first column
similarly a12 and it's really pronounced
a11 in this particular setup
so it's row one column one a 12 is
a row one column two
first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a
smaller case a for the top row or i mean
you can see where
they can go all kinds of different
directions as far as the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in
and what column it's in and we have our
basic operations we have addition so
when you think about addition you have
uh
two matrixes of two by two and you just
add each individual
number in that matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have
in this case the solution is 12 10 plus
2 is 12
5 plus 3 is 8 and so on and the same
thing with subtraction
now again your counting matrix is you
want to check your
dimensions of the matrix the shape
you'll see
shape come up a lot in programming so
we're talking about dimensions
we're talking about the shape if the two
shapes are
equal this is what happens when you add
them together
or subtract them and we have
multiplication when you look at the
multiplication you end up with a very
uh a slightly different setup going now
if we look at our last one where we're
like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes they don't really say why you
multiply matrixes
you know my first thought is one times
two four times three
but if you look at this we get one times
two plus four times
three one times three plus four times
five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times
five if you're looking at these matrixes
uh
think of this more as an equation and so
we have
if you remember we went back up here for
our multiple line equations let's just
go back up a couple slides where we were
looking at
a two variable so this is a two variable
equation
ax plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do and
this is the
dot product of one times two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough
inputs and then in matrix operations
when you're dealing with a lot of
matrixes
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes
okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving for equations when you're
finding the product you are just finding
1 times 2.
keep that in mind because that does come
up i've had that come up a number of
times where i'm altering data
and i get confused as to what i'm doing
with it uh transpose
flipping the matrix over is diagonal
comes up all the time
where you have you still have 12 but
instead of being 12
8 it's now 12 14 8 21
you're just flipping the columns and the
rows and then of course you can do an
inverse changing the signs of the values
across this main diagonal
and you can see here we have the inverse
a to the minus 1 and
ends up with instead of 12 8 14 12 is
now minus 22 minus 12.
vectors vector just means we have
a value and a direction and
we have down four numbers here on our
vector
uh in mathematics a one dimensional
matrix is called a vector
uh so if you have your x plot and you
have a single value
that values along the x axis and it's a
single
dimension if you have two dimensions you
can think about putting them on a graph
you might have x and you might have y
and each value denotes a direction and
then of course the actual distance
is going to be the hypothesis of that
triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means for categorizing and how close
data is together
they will compute that based on the
pythagorean theorem so you would take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value to another one
it makes a very easy comparison versus
comparing
50 or 60 different numbers and that
brings us up to
i gene vectors and i gene values
hygiene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span
while transformation and hygiene values
the scalar values that are associated to
the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
two dimensions x and y and so when you
do those two dimensions and those two
values
or whatever that value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it
and so if we take and we have a vector
a and that's a set value uh
b is um your is your you have a and b
which is your hygiene vector
two is the i gene value so we're
altering
all the values by two that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall
uh if you're doing picture editing
that's one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
uh your different information
how you transform it is then your igene
value
and you can see here vector after line
transit transition
we have 3a a is the hygiene vector 3 is
the iogene value
so a doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture
and 3 is skewing it one direction
and maybe a b is being skewed another
direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those
by the aging values so let's go ahead
and pull up a
demo on linear algebra and to do this
i'm going to go through my
trusted anaconda into my jupiter
notebook
and we'll create a new uh notebook
called linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as np
or numpy array probably the most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy
we are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10
15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15
29 and i went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read and since it's
the
last line we don't have to put the print
statement on it unless you want we can
simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29 and we get
30 24 which is what you expect 10 plus
20
15 plus 9 you could almost look at this
addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do
a dot t plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that
we now get them we now have 30 24
going the other way we could also do
something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this as far as a plus b
i can also do a plus b dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 30 24 whether i
transpose a
and b or transpose them both at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a
minus b and we run that
and we get minus 10 6. now remember this
is the last line in this particular
section that's why not to put the print
around it
and just like we did before we can
transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main set up and
then we get a minus 10
6 going the other way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do
a scalar multiplication and just put
down
scalar so you can remember that what
we're talking about here is i have
this array here u and if i go
a times u
we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply it
by every value in here
so 2 times 30 is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way so
in numpy uh we have what they call dot
product
and with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is the equivalent
of
two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the well let's walk
through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6
or our u and our v and then we're going
to go ahead and do
if we take the values
and if you remember correctly an array
like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6. we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go and then we'll go ahead and
do
the np dot dot of u
comma
v and we'll find when we do this
we go and run this we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here
but for this we get a nice value for our
dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which is
just your basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do let's
create two
complex matrixes this one
is a matrix of um you know 1210 46431
we'll just print out a so you can see
what that looks like here's print
a we print a out you can see that we
have
a two by three
layer matrix for a and we can also put
together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values uh we could do
something like this
we could go in here there we go
we could print a we have it end with uh
equals a
run and this kind of gives it a nice
look uh here's your matrix that's all
this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2 is 14
10 plus 8 is 18 and so on and just like
we did the
matrix addition we can also do a
minus b and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this uh we have what 12
minus 2
is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go eight minus uh
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
uh but we can see here 12 minus two is
of course 10
10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is minus 42
and so forth
so same as the subtraction as before we
just call it matrix subtraction is
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just
one number to a matrix you can also do
scalar multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have
b which is your array we can also do a
times
b when we run that you can see here we
have 2 times 4 is 8
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up a little bit of a brain teaser
is matrix and vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this uh
we are just doing regular array it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array
we have a which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array
and so we can from here
do the dot a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value
is that it's you could say it's like uh
uh we're doing the
this array b array first with a
and then with a second one and so it
splits it up so you have a matrix of
vector multiplication and you can mix
and match
when you get into really complicated uh
back end stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data
and so you'll end up with a matrix and a
set of
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes
so if you're in the scikit looking at sk
learn where you're doing linear
regression models this is some of the
math that's hidden behind the scenes
that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and
manipulate the data around so it fits
right and then you go back in
and you run it through the psi kit and
if we can do
up here where we did a matrix and vector
multiplication we can also do matrix
matrix multiplication and if we run this
we have the two matrixes
you can see a very complicated array
that of course comes out on there for
our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transpose matrix which is your dot
t and so if we create a matrix a and we
do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from 5
10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15
25 10 20 30 rows and columns
and certainly with the math uh this
comes up a lot um
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put in the pi plot you have one
format
where they're looking at pairs and
numbers and then they want all of x's
and all y's
so you know the transpose is an
important tool both for your math and
for plotting and all kinds of things
another tool that we didn't discuss is
your
identity matrix and this one is more
definition uh the
identity matrix um we have here one
where we just did uh
two so it comes down as one zero zero
one
uh one zero zero zero one zero it
creates a diagonal of one
and what that is is when you're doing
your identities you could be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have feature one
compared to feature one
to itself it is always one
where usually it's between zero one
depending on how well correlates
so when we're talking about identity
matrix that's what we're talking about
right here
is that you create this preset matrix
and then you might adjust these numbers
depending on
what you're working with and what the
domain is and then another thing we can
do
to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh
piece of this puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix and let's just go ahead and put
the
um it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh
the website for numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is two one zero
zero one zero one two one
keep in mind three by three is square
it's gotta be equal
it's going to return the matrix a
inverse
satisfying dot a a inverse so here's our
matrix multiplication um
and then of course it equals the dot
yeah a
inverse of a with an identity shape of
a dot shaped zero this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see what we end up with
is we end up with an array 0.5 minus 0.5
and so forth with our 2 1 1 going down 2
1
0 0 1 0 1 2 1.
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out
you do need to know about the linear
algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up
we took a look at the algebra side of it
let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side
of what's going on here with the machine
learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all
part of the bag of tricks especially
when you're doing large neural networks
but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation uh so we talk
about calculus
we're going to go ahead and understand
it by
talking about cars versus time and speed
so it helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate
of change so suppose we plot a graph of
the speed of a car with respect to time
so as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp
so i had to accelerate so my speed went
way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and maybe peter's off up there so you
can look at this
as as the speed versus time i'm getting
faster and faster because i'm
continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect of time is nothing
but acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the endpoint of
delta x so we can calculate
a simple if you had x and delta x we
could put a line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points i want to know what across
the whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is that instead of i mean if
you ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period
up into maybe 10 sections and you'd use
that and you could calculate the
acceleration between each one of those
10 sections kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller
until delta x is almost infinitesimally
small and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of
a function of a plus h minus a function
of a over
h and that is you're computing the
slope of the line we're just computing
that slope and they're smaller and
smaller and smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral
you can see down here we have our nice
uh integral sign
looks like a giant s and that's what
that means is that we've taken this down
to
as small as we can for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process
in the integration similar small
intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of x
plus delta x where delta x approaches
almost an infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up
all the links together so we're summing
up all the accelerations from the
beginning to the end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c that is
our basic calculus here so when we talk
about multivariate
calculus multivariate calculus deals
with functions that have multiple
variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in w over change of time equals
change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt
it gets pretty complicated it really
translates into
the multivariate integration using
double integrals
and so you have the the sum of the sum
of f of x of y of d of a
equals the sum from c to d and a to b
of f of x y d x d y equals
uh the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f
x of y
d y d x understanding the very specifics
of everything going on in here and
actually doing the math
is usually calculus one calculus 2 and
differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations what we
want to take from here is we're talking
about calculus
we're talking about summing of all these
different slopes
and so we're still solving a linear uh
expression we're still solving
y equals m x plus b but we're doing this
for infinitely small
x's and then we want to sum them up
that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule
when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t
equals the change of w dz and
so forth that's what's going on here
that's what these means
we're basically looking for the area
under the curve which really comes
to how is the change changing
speeds going up how is that changing and
then you end up with a multiple layer
so if i have three layers of neural
networks how is the third
layer changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing
and you get the picture here that now we
have a very complicated
multivariate integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
so the nice thing is that you don't have
to solve this on paper unless you're a
data analysis and you're working on the
back end
of integrating these formulas and
building the script to actually build
them
so we talk about applications of
calculus it provides us the tools to
build an accurate predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change of the change is
that's a little goofy i i know i just
threw that out there it's kind of a meta
term
but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables so there's our multiple
variables going in there
if one variable is changing how does it
affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local
and global maxima and this is really big
uh we're going to actually going to have
a whole section here on gradient
descent because it is really i mean i
talked about neural networks and how
you can see how the different layers go
in there but gradient descent
is one of the most key things for trying
to guess the best
answer to something so let's take a look
at the code behind gradient descent
and before we open up the code let's
just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go there hard to read
there
and i want to make the error as low as
possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line
here which is the minimum
value so we're looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace
here and it goes hey this is still going
down it goes here and then goes back
over here
and then goes a little bit closer and
it's just playing a high low until it
gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error in
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best
output of it that's simply minus the
value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is this is the same
as a negative for where the valley is
looking for that valley that's all that
is this is a way of finding it
so the cool thing is all the heavy
lifting is done
i actually ended up putting together one
of these a while back
is when i didn't know about side kick
and it was just starting
boy it's a long while back and uh
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that
and the back end is all the calculus and
differential equations to calculate this
out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun
uh some things we're gonna note and this
is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models
you're going to find these things are
stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind your model that you're
working with
is very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it
the first question is where do we start
um
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we are arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is
uh how many bars to skip going one where
the other i'm
in fact i'm going to separate that a
little bit because these two are really
important
um if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about um
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function 2 times x plus
5
keep it simple so that's a function
we're going to work with
so if i'm dealing with increments of
1000.1
is going to be a very long time and if
i'm dealing with increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm
so again very specific to what you're
working on
if you're working with money and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations
we want something to cut out at a
certain point usually that's built into
a lot of
minimization functions and then here's
our actual
uh formula we're going to be working
with and then we come in we go
while previous step size is greater than
precision and iters is less than max and
max iters say that
10 times fast um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
um and then we also don't want to go
past a thou or whatever this is a
million or ten thousand
uh running that's actually pretty high i
almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two hundred
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with
uh so we have our previous equals our
current that way we can track
time wise uh the current now equals the
current minus the rate
times the formula of our previous x
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous
step size equals the absolute current
previous
uh so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says
hey local minimum is minus 3.3222 for
this particular
series we created this is created off of
our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5. now
when i'm running this stuff you'll see
this come up a lot
in with the sk learn kit and
one of the nice reasons of breaking this
down the way we did
is i could go over those top pieces uh
those top pieces are everything when you
start looking at these minimization
tool kits built-in code and so
from um we'll just do it's actually
docs dot scipy.org
and we're looking at the scikit
there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
and your x naught there's your there's
your start value so your function
your start value there's all kinds of
things that come in here that you can
look at which we're not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints
bounds some of this it does
automatically but you really
the big thing i want to point out here
is you need to have a starting point
you want to start with something that
you already know is mostly the answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out
a lot of vocabulary and statistics ah
so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation and
presentation of data that is
a mouthful um so we have from
end to end where does it come from is it
valid what does it mean
how do we organize it um how do we
analyze it
then you gotta take those analysis and
interpret it into something that
people can use kind of reduce it to
understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is going to understand what
the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies there
there's a lot of terminologies depending
on what domain you're working in
so clearly if you're working in um
a domain that deals with viruses
and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with um
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling
statistics to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that
that can be a big deal you know we have
these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things if the sensors
pick up
at one point do you replace them instead
of waiting for it to break in which case
it costs a lot of money instead of
replacing a bushing you're replacing the
whole
fan unit an interesting project that
came up
for our city a while back so population
all objects are measurements whose
properties are being observed
uh so that's your population all the
objects it's easy to see it with people
because we have our population enlarged
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about how
the fan units that's the population of
fans that we're working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied
you don't want to do them all because
then you don't have a if you come up
with a conclusion for everyone
you don't have a way of testing it so
you take a sample sometimes you don't
have a choice you can only take a sample
of what's going
on you can't study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object
in a population types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method
based on the theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
a non-probabilistic approach
selecting samples based on the
subjective judgment of the researcher
rather than
random selection has to do with
convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased
so you gotta be very careful on that so
probabilistic
sampling uh when we talk about a random
sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category
so it's as random as you can get we talk
about
systematic sampling we're selecting
random size samples from each group or
category with a fixed
periodic interval so we kind of split it
up this would be like a time set up or
our different categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
uh if you look at i'm going to go back a
window
let's say we're studying economics of
different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh
and when i say separated i don't mean
separated from their
place where they live i mean as far as
the analysis we want to look at the
different groups
and make sure they're all represented so
if we had like an
80 percent uh of a group that is
say hispanic and or indian and
also in that same area we have 20 20
who are let's call our expatriates they
left america
and they're nice and uh your caucasian
group
we might want to sample a group that is
representative of both
uh so we're talking about stratified
sampling
and we're talking about groups those are
the groups we're talking about and that
brings us to stratified sampling
selecting approximately equal size
samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories
and give us an insight into the
different cultures and how that might
affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with as
far as your data and what you're
studying
and so we can see here just to go a
little bit more we'd have selecting 25
employees from a company of 250
employees randomly don't care anything
about them what groups are in which
office they're in nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch and
the category could depend on what you're
studying so it has a lot of
variation on there you see this kind of
grouping and categorizing is also
used to generate a lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential
statistics there are so many different
terms and statistics to break it up
so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup so we're talking about descriptive
inferential
statistics the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like
with inferential statistics we're going
to take that from the small population
to a large population
so if you're working with a drug company
you might look at the data and say
these people were helped by this drug
they did
80 percent better as far as their health
or 80 percent better survival rate than
the people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people
so that's where you get your inferential
so we are
predicting how it's going to affect the
greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative
analysis of data so we have a measure of
central tendencies we have your mean
median and mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is
how the data difference differences you
know
what's the max min range all that stuff
is your spread
and anything that's just a single number
is usually your central
uh tendencies measure of central
tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of whatever
is going on
and then your median separates the
higher half and the lower half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points
so your mean might have some a couple
really big numbers that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those
outliers out where the median would
by separating the high from the low
might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why is the average
so much higher than the median
well it's because you have some outliers
or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the
most common income like in the u.s was
1.24 000 a year
where the average was closer to 80 000.
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money
and then you look at the median income
and you're like well the median income
is
a little bit closer to the average so it
does create a very interesting
way of looking at the data again these
are all
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean
sum of the marks of the students total
number of students and as we talked
about the median
we have 0 through 10 and we
take half the numbers and put them on
one side of the line half the numbers on
the other side of the line
we end up with 5 in the middle and then
the mode what mark was scored by most of
the students
in a test in a simple case where most
people scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh
not so easy when you have different
areas where like you have like the
oh let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group the scores that makes 30
000
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000 so what do you put down for the
mode
uh certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh
range what's the difference between the
highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
score
between 60 and 100 somebody got 100 or
maybe 60 to
90 percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get a hundred percent
um you have your inter-quartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into four
equal parts very common thing to do as
part of all the basic packages whether
you're working
in data frames with pandas
whether you're working in scala whether
you're working in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your macs
and then it'll have your interquartile
range how does it look like in each
quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set
is from the mean and therefore from
every other number in the set
uh so you have like how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation it is to
measure the variance or the dispersion
of a set of values from the mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot so
measurement of spread
marks of a student out of a hundred we
have here from 50 to 63 or 50 to
90. so the range maximum marks minimum
marks we have 90 to 45 and the spread of
that is 45
90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is
and then there's the first quarter the
second quarter
and the third quarter based on splitting
it apart by those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
so here's our you know calculating the
average there
we end up approximately 66 for the
average
and then we look at that the variance
once we know the means we can do
equals the marks minus the mean squared
why is this squared uh because one you
want to make sure
it's you don't have like if you if
you're putting all this stuff together
you end up with an
error as far as one's negative one's
positive one's a little higher one's a
little lower
so you always see the squared value and
over the total observations
and so the standard deviation equals the
square root of the variance which is
approximately 16.
and if you were looking at a predictable
model you would be looking at the
deviation based on the error how much
error does it have
that's again really important to know if
your if your prediction is predicting
something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupiter notebook in python
now almost all of this you can do in
numpy
last time we worked in numpy this time
we're going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns
let's just go ahead and do a print
df.head
and run that and you can see we have
the name jane michael william rosie
hannah's out and their salaries on here
and of course instead of having to do
all those hand calculations and add
everything together and divide by the
total
we can do something very simple on this
like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go ahead and do this print
df pick our column salary because we
want to find the means of that
calorie we want to find the means of
that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median uh
we're used to means in average it's kind
of interesting that those are they use
the two different words
uh there can be in some computation
slight differences but for the most part
the means is the average uh and then the
median
oops let's put a
median here do you have salary that way
it displays a little better
we can see the median is 54
000 so the halfway mark is significantly
below the average
why because we have somebody in here
makes 189 000.
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers but that's something you'd want
to notice this is
this is the difference between these is
huge and so is what is the meaning
behind that when you're studying a
populist and looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most
common income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50
000. so this is this is very telling
that most people are making 50
000. the middle point is at 54
000. so half the people are making more
than that what that tells me
is that if the most common income is
weight is below the median
then there's a few there's a scale
there's a lot of
high salaries going up but there's some
really low salaries in there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistics
when you're analyzing the economy in
different people's
income is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was
you might start asking questions at that
point why aren't you talking about the
median income why aren't you talking
about the mode the most common income
what are you hiding uh and if you're
doing these analysis you should be
looking at these saying hey
why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any
analysis it's important to find out the
minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
dot min it'll pull up your minimum and
then
dot max pulls up the maximum pretty
straightforward on
as far as translating it and
knowing what you're you know put the
your lowest value which your highest
value is here
um which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on
and real quick on no mode uh note that
it puts mode
0. like i said there's a couple
different ways you can compute the
mode although the standard one is pretty
good
we can of course do the range which is
your max minus your min
so now we have a range of 149 000
between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking at the
individual
values on all of these but it turns out
there is
a describe feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe
and if we do this you can see we have
that there's seven
uh setups here's our mean our standard
deviation which we didn't compute yet
which would just be a
dot std and you gotta be a little
careful because when it computes it it
looks for axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information
and then split it up and depending on
what you need now if i just walked in
and gave you this information
in a meeting at some point you would
just kind of fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway so we want
to go ahead and see about graphing it
here
and we'll go ahead and put it into a
histogram and plot that graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here
so we do our matplot inline remember
that's a jupiter's notebook thing
a lot of the new version of the matplot
library does it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import plot library pi plot is plt
that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourselves
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print df that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title
salary distribution color gray uh
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style dash this is
just all
making it pretty what color dashed line
line width of 2 that kind of thing and
the median
and let's go ahead and run this just so
you can see what we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
um so here's the data here's our our
data frame print it out so you can see
it with the salaries
we'll look at the salary distribution
and just look at this
the way the salary is distributed um
you have our in this case we did let's
see we had red
for the median we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it
really i mean here's our outlier here's
our person who makes a lot of money
here's the average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow um based on the average it really
doesn't tell you much about what people
are really taking home
all it does is tell you how much money
is in this you know
what the average salary is so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is
that it's very easy to plot
an ax v line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated
keeping it simple is pretty
straightforward i look at this and i can
see we have a major outlier out here
we can definitely do a histogram and
stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words what you really want to make sure
you take away
is that we can do a basic describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up um
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
statistics
uh being able to
doesn't have the print on there so it's
only going to print the last one which
happens to be the mean
you can very easily reference any one of
these and then you can also
if you're doing something a little bit
more complicated and you don't need just
the basics
you can come through and pull any one of
the individual
um
from the from the pandas on here so now
we've had a chance to
describe our data let's get into
inferential statistics inferential
statistics allows you to make
predictions
or inferences from data and you can see
here we have a nice little picture movie
ratings
and if we took this group of people and
said hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say
and then you ask just a random person
who comes out of the movie who hasn't
been in this study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say
so that's real basics of what we're
talking about is you're going to infer
that the next person is going to follow
these statistics
so let's look at point estimation it is
a process of finding an approximate
value for a population's parameter
like mean or average from random samples
of the population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out
and make sure they're going to work on
the populace a group of people
are chosen from the population medical
trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population
so here's a protected there's our small
group up here where we've selected them
we run medical trials on them and then
the results work for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary
covet virus in the middle of one and
let's take a look at the applications of
inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that
and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution
in central limit theorem hypothesis
testing hypothesis testing is used to
measure the plausibility of a hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now when we talk about theorems
theory hypothesis uh
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory is the same as hypothesis
where theorem is a scientific uh
statement that is something that has
been
proven although it is always up for
debate because in science we always want
to make sure things are up to debate
so hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven
gravity is a theory so if you want to
debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about why the economy is
collapsing in your area that is a
philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
we talk about hypotheses testing the
steps involved in hypotheses testing is
first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test
and we make a decision and so when
you're talking about hypothesis you're
usually trying to disprove it
if you can't disprove it and it works
for all the facts
then you might call that a theorem at
some point
so in a use case uh let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves
they did so by making four chits which
has their names on it and the name that
gets picked
up has to do the cleaning for that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on
it so here's our four people nick rob
emlia
emilia and summer
now rick emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether rob has done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on till 12 days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day ie
his turn never comes up then definitely
he has done some mischief
while making the chits so the
probability of rob not doing work on day
one
is three out of four there's a 0.75
chance that he didn't do work uh
two days three fourths times three
fourths equals point five
six three days you have three fourths
three fourths three fourths which equals
point four
two uh when you get to day twelve it's
.032 which is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis a general
statement that states that there is no
relationship between
two measured phenomenon or no
association among the groups
alternative hypothesis contrary to the
null hypothesis it states
whenever something is happening a new
theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand
uh so your null this is always
interesting in in talking about data
science and the math behind it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation
null hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other
where the alternative hypothesis says
hey we found a relation this is what it
is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of
finding the observed or more extreme
results when the null hypothesis of a
study question
is true and the t value it is simply the
calculated difference
represented in units of standard error
the greater the magnitude of t
the greater the evidence against the
null hypothesis
and you can look at the t values being
specific to the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value
and you're looking for what they call
the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper
let's assume that a new drug is
developed with the goal of lowering the
blood pressure
more than the existing drug and this is
a good one because
the null value here isn't that you don't
have any drug the null value here is
that it's better than the existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation
and the new drug is not doing its job
the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug
uh yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trial showing
positive results which will reject
the null hypothesis and again they're
looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis
so this is specific to the test how what
percentage of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie
in let's say you asked a dog owner
around you and asked them
how many cans of food do you buy for
your
per year for your dog through
calculations you got to know that the
on an average around 95 percent of the
people bought around 200 to 300 cans of
food
hence we can say that we have a
confidence interval of 2
300 where 95 percent of our values lie
in that spring data spread and this the
graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here we
have the 95 percent
you have your peak in this case it's a
normal distribution so you have a nice
bell curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical
and 95 of all the values lie within a
very small range and then you have your
outliers the 2.5 percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis and we're
going to move into
probability so you have your hypothesis
once you've generated your hypothesis we
want to know the probability of
something occurring
probability is a measure of the
likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty
and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
so any event cannot be predicted with
total certainty can only be predicted as
a likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under
one in trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them so we talk about
random variable
a random variable is a variable whose
possible values are numerical outcomes
of a random phenomena
so we have the coin tossed how many
heads will occur in the series of 20
coin flips
probably you know the on average they're
10 but you really
can't know because it's very random how
many times a red ball is picked from a
bag of balls if there's equal number of
red balls and blue balls and green balls
in there how many times the sum of
digits on two dice
results are five each
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your
paradigms
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y
you can take values two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice were roll five let's go ahead
and look at
total sum of five and you have in as far
as your random variables you can have a
one four equals five four one two three
three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different
options you have four of those random
rolls can be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
you can see that we have four out of 36
chants every time you roll the dice
that you're gonna roll a total of five
you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means
but you could think of that at what
point if someone never rolls a 5 or they
always roll a 5
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that
but let's just consider this is one of
the cases is rolling two dice and
gambling
there's also binomial distribution is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial
so passing or failing an exam winning or
losing a game
and getting either head or tails so if
you ever see binomial distribution it's
based on
a true false kind of setup you win or
lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of
football between two clubs barcelona
and dortmund the teams will have to play
a total of four matches
and we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 percent or 0.75
that means that each game they have a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game
and losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game
probability for getting k wins in in
matches is calculated and we we're
talking like so if you have five games
uh and you want to know if i play um how
many wins in those five games
should i get what's a percentage on
those and the probability
for getting k wins and in matches is
calculated by
p x equals k equals n c k
p to the k q to the n minus k
here p is the probability of success and
q
is the probability of failure and so we
can do total games of
n equals 5 where k equals 0 1 2 3
4 5. p which is the chance of winning is
0.75
q the chance of losing equals 1 minus p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25 the probability that barcelona will
lose
all of the matches can then just plug in
the numbers
and we end up with a 0.0009765625
so very small chance they're going to
lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches
probability that barcelona will win at
least two matches
is 0.0878 and of course we can go on to
the probability that barcelona will win
three matches
the 0.26 and of course four matches
and so on and it's always nice to take
this information
and let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches
x equals three x equals four x equals
five
and we end up with the p equals point
two six four plus point three nine five
plus two three seven which equals point
eight nine
in reality the probability of barcelona
winning the series is much higher than
0.75
and it's always nice to put out a nice
graph so you can actually see
the number of wins to the probability
and how that pans out
with our binomial case continuing in our
important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean
value and this is some very important
things
so much of the data we look at and when
you start looking at probabilities
almost always has a normalized look
like the graph in the middle but you do
have
left skewed where the data is skewed off
to the left and you have more stuff
happening out to the left and you have
right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed
it's really important to take a closer
look at that mostly you end up with a
normalized set of data but you've got to
also be aware that sometimes it's a
skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out
and if the standard deviation is small
then most of your data is going to hit
right there in the middle you can have a
nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that
fits certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're if you have a really
high standard deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from
the mean a data point is it is measured
in terms of standard deviations from the
mean
around 68 percent of the results are
found between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there
we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u
it just means the mean uh and then the
sigma is the standard deviation and
that's the o with the little arrow off
to the right or the little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it
uh so mu minus two sigma is your
uh 95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem this goes back to
the skew if you remember we were looking
at the skew values on this previous
slide have left skewed normalized and
right
skewed when we're talking about it being
skewed or not skewed
the distribution of the sample means
will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed
if you take large random samples from
the population
with the mean mu and the standard
deviation
sigma with replacement and you can see
here
of course we have our mu minus two sigma
and the spread
down here the mean the median and the
mode and so you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value
if you do that's a flag that something's
wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it
and if we're going to do all this we've
got to jump into conditional
probability the conditional probability
of an event a
is a probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred
and you'll see this as bayes theorem
b-a-y-e-s
base and this is red
i mean yeah these funky looking little p
brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while
b is already true and you have the
probability of b
being true when a is already true so p b
of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b
being true and we talk about bayes
theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important
formula and it's really it's not if you
actually do the math you could just kind
of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math
but it works with probabilities which
makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine
different studies going on in different
areas
different people have done the studies
they brought them together
um if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread
uh certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science
and understanding where your data is
coming from and how you're going to
combine
different studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case uh
let's find out the chance of a person
getting
lung disease due to smoking and this is
kind of interesting the way they word
this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients they treated
suffered lung disease so we have kind of
a generic
medical report they further found out
by a survey that 15 of the patients that
visit them
smoke so we have 10 that are lung
disease
and 15 of the patients smoke
and finally five percent of the people
continued smoke
even when they had lung disease uh not
the brightest
choice um but you know it is an
addiction so it can be really difficult
to kick
and so we can look at the probability of
a
prior probability of 10 percent people
having lung disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have
lung disease is five percent and
probability of a
is b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and then when you put the formulas
together you get a nice solution here
you get
the probability of a of b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a
3.33 percent chance hence there is a
3.33
chance that a person who smokes will get
a lung disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code
i'm always my favorite roll up the
sleeves keep in mind
we're going to be doing this um kind of
like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools that are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set
so we're going to create a set with
curly braces this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
you have your tuples which can never
change and then you have
in this case the the set so four seven
you can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four
outs it's only unique values and if you
use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary
uh we have a value and that value is
assigned to or that
key is assigned to a value so you could
have a key value set up as a dictionary
so it's like a dictionary without the
value it's just the keys and they all
have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven we can also
take a list a regular setup and i'm
going to go ahead and just throw in
another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if i
take my list one two three four
four and i convert it to a set
and here it is my set from list equals
set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set uh
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function and
one in my set
six is not in the set and so forth if we
run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one
six is in the set six is not in the set
so
not in my set you can also use this with
the list
we could have just used three five seven
and it would have
the same response on there is three and
usually do if three is in but three in
my set is still works on
just a regular list then we'll go ahead
and do a little iteration
we're going to do kind of the dice one
remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the
iteration tool and import product as
product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
they can only have one
value for each one that's why they put
it in a set and if you remember from
range it is up to seven so this is gonna
be one
two three four five six it will not
include the seven
and the same thing for our dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product of a
and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice
where dice a is one two three one to six
and dice b
is one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about
um the different all the different
outcomes of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit we can do
in dice equals two divi dice faces one
two three four five
six uh another way of doing what we did
before
and then we can create an event space
where we have a set which is the product
of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here
and print them all out like we had
before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome
and equals so the event space
is creating a sequence and as you can
see here when we print it out
it stacks some versus going through and
putting them in a nice line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means
it's just gonna it's not going to hit
the return going down to the next line
and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
of course if i get carried away with my
typing of length uh we'll print it twice
and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
what about the multiple of three what if
we want to have
uh the probability of the multiple of
three in our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space
of x y equals outcome if
x plus y remainder 3 so we're going to
divide by 3 and look at the remainder
and it equals zero
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set
not necessary because we know it's not
going to be repeating itself but just in
case we'll go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four
is nine which divided by 3 is 3 and so
forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length of our
f outcome so we can see what that looks
like
there we go and of course i did forget
to add the print in the middle because
we're looping through and putting an
end on the on the setup on there so
we're going to put the print in there
and if i run this you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
uh we have 12 that are multiple that
add up to a multiple of three
and we can easily conver compute the
probability of this
uh by simply taking the length of our
favorable outcome over the length of the
event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with a 0.3333
chance that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of 3
is 0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it
uh you can see we just have a huge
amount of choices
so it just goes on and on down here and
we can look at
the length of the event space
and we have over 7776
choices that's a lot of choices and if
we want to ask the question like we did
above
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not a multiple of
three
we can go through all of these different
options and then
you can see here d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals
the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by 5 does not have a remainder
of 0 but
the remainder is also of a division by
three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not
we can just append that on here and then
we can look at that
uh favorable outcome we'll go ahead and
set that and we'll just
take a look at this what's our length of
our
favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
776
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of 3. and so we're
just going to divide those two numbers
and you can see here we get
0.116255 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not
really complicated math right here on
probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to
come up with with the solution you're
looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data
for which the true values are known and
so you'll see in the left we have the
predicted
and the actual and we have a negative
false negative positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative
and you can think of this as your
predicted
model what does that mean that means if
you divided your data
and you use two-third of this to create
the model you might then test it against
an actual case for the last third to see
how well it comes out how many times was
it
uh true positive versus uh
false positive it gave a false positive
response and you can imagine
in medical situations this is a pretty
big deal
you don't want to give a false positive
so you might adjust your model
accordingly so you don't have a false
positive say with a covavirus test
it'd be better to have a false negative
and they go back and get retested
then to have 30 false positives where
then the test is pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a false positive
i mean a false negative in other words
you don't want to have it tell you that
you don't have cancer when you do
so that would be something you'd really
be looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of
pieces of data that come in there's a
real famous case study where they have
the imagery and all the measurements
they take and there's about 36 different
measurements they take and then if you
run the
a basic model you want to know just how
accurate it is how many
negative results do you have that are
either telling people they have cancer
that don't or telling people that don't
have cancer that they do
and then we can take these numbers and
we can feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision recall accuracy
metric to measure how accurately the
results are predicted
and this is your total true
where you got the right results you add
them together the true positive the two
negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate
versus what were wrong we talked about
precision
is a metric to measure how many of the
correctly predicted cases are actually
turned out to be
positive uh so we have a precision
on true positive again if you're talking
about
like covid testing with the viruses
uh you really want this to be a high
number you want this
true that to be the center point where
you might have the opposite if you're
dealing with
a cancer where you want no false
negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
uh true positive plus uh false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
uh so test positive is the test positive
plus
the false negative on there and we'll
want to go ahead and do a
demo on the naive bayes classifier
before i get
too far into a naive bayes classifier
because we're going to pull it from the
sk
learn or the scikit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers
when you go into the sk learn kit
there's a lot of ways to do
classification and i'll just zoom up in
here so you can
see some of the titles there's
everything from the nearest neighbor
linear but we're going to be focusing on
the naive bayes
over here and this is just a sample
data set that they put together and you
can see how
some of these have a very different
output the naive bayes remember is set
up as
probably the most simplified calculator
or
set of predictions out there and so what
we've been talking about with the true
false and stuff like that where there's
a
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction
and so that's what we're using as a
naive bayes classifier
versus many of the other classifiers
that are out there
for this we're going to use the social
network
ads it's a little data set on here and
let me go and just open that up the file
here we go it has user id gender age
estimated salary purchased and so we
have
you can see the user id mail 19
estimated salary 19 000 and purchased
zero
so it's either going to make a purchase
or not so look at that last one
zero one we should be thinking of
binomials we should be thinking of
a simple naive bayes classifier kind of
setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as
np we're going to nice to have a good
visual of our data so we'll put in our
matplot library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data sets
going to be
we're going to read it from the social
network ads.csv
then we're going to print the head just
so you can see it again even though i
showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
two three values and y is going to be
the four
column four let me just run this it's a
little easier to go over
that you can see right here we're going
to be looking at
0 1 2 as age and estimated salary so
2 3 and that's what i location just
means
that we're looking at the number versus
a regular location a regular location
you'd actually say
age and estimated salary and then column
four is did they make a purchase
they purchased something so those are
the three columns we're going to be
looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and imported the data so now our data
set is all set with this information in
it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
data up so we need our
from the sk learn model selection we can
import train
test split this does a nice job we can
set the random state so randomly picks
the data
and we're just going to take uh 25
percent of it's going to go into the
test
our x test and our y test and the 75
will go to x train and y train that way
once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our
prediction the
next step in pre-processing our data is
to go ahead and do
feature scaling now a lot of this to
start to look familiar if you've done a
number of the other
modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value
of -1 and one uh or someplace in the
middle ground there this way if you have
any huge set
you don't have this huge um setup if we
go back up to here where salary
the salary is 20 000 versus
age 35 well there's a good chance with a
lot of the back end math
that 20 000 will skew the results and
the estimated salary will have a higher
impact than the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our
naive bayes model
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one
that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the sk
learn kit uh they have a number of
different ones you can pull in there
there's a
bernoulli i don't know i've never used
that one categorical
um complement and here's our gaussian
so there's a number of different options
you can look at gaussian when you come
to
the naive bayes is the most commonly
used
so we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they
when they're pulling this in and one of
the nice things about the gaussian if
you go to their website
to sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all to
want you
once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it
as far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier
we're going to equal the gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data
and our training solutions so x train y
train
and we'll go ahead and run this uh it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y
predict equals the classifier.predict x
test so here we fit the data and now
we're going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from the sk learn matrix metrics you
can import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y
test and the y predict so we have our
actual
and we have our predicted value and
you can see from here this is the chart
we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive false
negative
true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65
3 7 25
and in this particular prediction we had
65
or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase
and we guessed three wrong and then we
had
25 we predicted would not purchase and
seven of them did
so there's our our confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting
um you would start to hear some snoozing
if they were looking at the numbers and
you say hey here's my confusion
matrix so let's go ahead and visualize
the results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine is going
to throw an error because
this is being because of the way the
setup is
i have a newer version on here than when
they put together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y train
and then we'll create our x1 x2 and
we'll put that into a grid
and we set our xset minimum stop and our
x at max stop
and if you come all the way over here
we're going to step .01
this is going to give us a nice line is
what that's doing and we're going to
plot the contour
plot the x limit plot the y limit and
put the scatter plot in there let's go
ahead and run this
to be honest when i'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that
there's so many different ways to put
this code together to show you what
we're doing
it's a lot easier to pull up the graph
and then go back
up and explain it so the first thing we
want
to note here when we're looking at the
data
is this is the training set and so we
have those who didn't make a purchase
we've drawn a nice area for that that's
defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green and you can see that
some of the green drops fall into the
red area and some of the red dots fall
into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent
uh we couldn't do that and so we're
looking at our different
data coming down uh we can kind of
arrange our x1 x2 so we have a nice plot
going on and we're going to create the
contour that's that nice line that's
drawing down the middle on here with the
red green
um that's where that's what this is
doing right here with the reshape
and notice that we had to uh do the dot
t if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module you end up
with pairs
you know x uh x1 x2 x1 x2 next row and
so forth
you have to flip it so it's all one row
you have all your x1s and all your x2s
so this is what we're kind of looking
for right here on this setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points that
puts these nice little dots on to
our setup on here and we have our
estimated salary and our
h and then of course the dots are did
they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x train y train
which seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition
so it was its own module that could be
called over and over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same
thing but we're going to visualize the
test set results
uh that way we can see what happened
with our test group our 25
and you can see down here we have the
test set
uh and it if you look at the two graphs
next to each other this one obviously
has 75 percent of the data so it's going
to show a lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by age and
income they're going to make a purchase
or not but that said
it still is pretty clear it's pretty
good as far as how much the estimate is
and how good it does
now graphs are really effective
for showing people what's going on but
you also need to have the numbers
and so we're going to do from sklearn
we're going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
uh precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it pulls in pretty good
as far as
how accurate it is you could say it's
going to be about 90 percent
is going to guess correctly that it that
they're not going to purchase
and we had an 89 chance that they are
going to purchase
um and then the other numbers as you get
down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need
and if you forgot the exact definition
of accuracy
it is the true positive true negative
over all
of the different setups precision is
your true positive
overall positives true and false and
recall is a true positive over true
positive plus
false negative and we can just real
quick flip back there
so you can see those numbers on here
here's our precision
here's our recall and here's our
accuracy on this
what's in it for you we're going to go
over applications of deep learning
what is deep learning why is deep
learning important
what are neural networks the activation
function in our neural network
the cost function that comes in for
processing our neural networks
how do neural networks work deep
learning platforms
and then we'll do introduction to
tensorflow and a use case implementation
using tensorflow so you can see how it
works and gets them hands on
so start off with the applications of
deep learning deep learning helps us
make
predictions about the rain earthquakes
tsunamis
etc allowing us to take the required
precautions
with deep learning machines can
comprehend speech and provide
the required output deep learning
enables a machine to recognize people
and objects in the images fed to it and
with deep learning advertisers can
leverage data to perform real-time
bidding and targeted display
advertising and these are just a small
sample of the myriad
of different uses for deep learning
today so what is
deep learning deep learning is a
subfield of machine learning that deals
with algorithms inspired by the
structure and function of the brain
when we look at this we have the larger
category which is artificial
intelligence
very generic comprehensive
ideal and in there we have machine
learning and then a sub
category of machine learning is deep
learning
so when we talk about artificial
intelligence this is the ability of a
machine to imitate
intelligent human behavior so when we
look at something can it solve a problem
the way humans do can we take it to that
next level
so it's just not repeating some kind of
simple
output that we programmed it to do can
it actually start imitating human
intelligence
and we look at machine learning we have
the application of ai that allows a
system to automatically learn
and improve from experience so machine
learning
the most basic machine learning is your
linear regression model you put a bunch
of dots on the graph and you draw a line
through them
and you have a guess of what x and y are
based on
where what x is you can guess what y is
and finally we have our deep learning
application of machine learning that
uses complex algorithms and deep
neural nets to train a model why is deep
learning
important it works with unstructured
data machine learning works only with
large sets of structured and
semi-structured data while deep learning
can work with both structured and
unstructured data
handles complex operations deep learning
algorithms can perform complex
operations easily while machine learning
algorithms cannot
feature extraction machine learning
algorithms use
labeled sample data to extract patterns
while deep learning accepts large
volumes of data as input
analyze the input to extract features
out of an object
achieve best performance performance of
machine learning algorithms
decreases as the amount of data
increases
so to maintain the performance of the
model we need
deep learning and this is always a
challenge of
when do you go from machine learning
doing linear regression
or other regression models to deep
learning neural networks
it really centers around both uh the
complexity as it becomes more and more
complex or the problem becomes harder to
solve
along with the amount of data so both of
those
play a huge part in deciding which would
best serve
your purposes to predict what your data
is going to do and try to predict the
outcome so what are neural networks
with deep learning a machine can be
trained to identify various shapes
so here we have a square coming in you
can see we've broken it up into the
pixels and we want the label to come out
square and if we turn the square
slightly sideways it's still a square
and we want to still say it's a square
with deep learning a machine can be
trained to identify various shapes
or the different patterns of those
shapes as they be are in this case being
rotated
but how is the machine able to do this
so we'll look at a nice grid 28 by 28
784 pixels
and we look at that grid we look at each
one of those pixels as inputs
so a neural network is a system modeled
on the human brain and so we have all
our inputs kind of like your eyeball
coming in there it has the sensors in
the back your different input sensors
which are your cones and rods so each
one of those is an input coming in with
information and it goes into a neuron
and then it sends out a pulse
so the data is fed as an input to the
neuron the neuron processes the
information provided as an input
the information is transferred over
weighted
channels and this is very central to our
neural network
each one of those pulses coming in gets
a different weight and the output is the
final value predicted by the artificial
neuron
in this image we're only looking at one
neuron so remember we're looking talk
about a lot of neurons working together
and we'll look at how those fit together
in just a moment we look at one neuron
so let's just take a look at that one
neuron let's dig a little deeper so we
can get some concepts in here so we can
understand the neural network
so what exactly happens within a neuron
we have an activation
function so within each neuron the
following operations are performed
the product of each input and the weight
of the channel it's passed
over is found some of the weighted
products is computed this is called the
weighted
sum and a bias unique to the neuron is
added to the weighted sum and you can
always look at that as if you have an x
y graph where's your y in intercept you
know the old
euclidean geometry x or y equals
three 3x plus 5 that's your plus 5 is
that bias is where does that come in
and this is a little bit more
complicated because it's not like 3x
it's more like
3x1 5x2 6x7
and usually you're dealing with float
numbers so it's not even it doesn't even
look like that it looks like
0.001 times x1.13
times x2 and so on so the numbers get a
little confusing but the concept is very
straightforward we're going to multiply
the weight times the value coming in and
we're going to add that all together
plus the bias
and the final sum is then subjected to
the particular function
known as the activation function and the
most simplest one
is if it's greater than zero it's one if
it's less than zero at
zero they usually use a lot of different
there's a lot of other functions that
are more
reliable than that one but that one
gives you the most basic understanding
of what you're looking at
zero or one coming out in most cases you
actually have a value coming out and in
some cases we use like a
tangent wave so that there can be a
value between zero and one
but it might be um it tends to shoot
right up to one rather quickly but you
know
those are things you can fine-tune in
your neural network
as you start getting to the solution
let's keep into the generals here and
let's see what's the next step
we're going to look at the cost function
and this is so important in
understanding
how the current neural networks that
we're working with
are able to learn things so we end up
with a cost value the cost value is the
difference between
the neural net's predicted output and
the actual output from a set of labeled
training data the least cost value is
obtained by making adjustments to the
weights and biases
iteratively throughout the training
process
and when you think about this we're not
just sending one set of numbers through
we're sending all kinds of data in here
so you might have a hundred samples or a
thousand samples
and each one of those samples comes in
and then we look at the cost for that
and we want to get that cost the minimal
the average minimal among all the
different samples so we want a general
answer on there you can see here we
denote
the predicted output with a little half
triangle over it and then the actual
output is just a straight y on this
let's learn how neural networks work
let's dig in a little deeper in how we
program them
how do neural networks work exactly and
this we're jumping from a single node
into a larger picture so our neural
network will be trained to identify
shapes and we'll start with the square
again 28 by 28 or 784 pixels
and this is kind of one of the standard
images we work with a lot of times
our shapes are images of 28 by 28 pixels
each pixel is fed as an
input to the neurons in the first layer
so here we have our input layer
each one of those we might flatten that
out that's the most easiest way to
process that but not the only way to
process
so we flatten it out so it's just one
long array and then we have hidden
layers
that improve the accuracy of the output
and you can see here we're not looking
at just one neuron we actually have a
row
two hidden layers and each layer is a
row of
neurons and data is passed on from layer
to layer over weighted channels
each one of those inputs is then
weighted to each of the next neurons in
the next layer
in the hidden layer each neuron in the
first hidden layer takes a subset of the
inputs
and processes it let's look into what
happens within the neurons
so here we have step one and we can see
in here where we have
x1 times weight one x2 times weight two
plus b1 that's that top neuron up there
and then we have the next neuron down
which is step two
and then in step two they denote the um
with the greek symbol
phi and phi is the activation function
based on step one so it might be um if
it's close to zero
it's zero if it's close to one it's one
and it might be a value in between it's
very common
depending on what activation function
you use the results of the activation
function determine which neurons will be
activated in the following layer
so you can see here we have b1 as we
looked at with x1 and weighted 1
x2 and weighted 2 and then you would
compute b2
the same way and b3 the same way and b4
and b5 and so on so each neuron
has an input from all the input layers
go into each
of the hidden layer neuron the first
hidden layer the result of the
activation function determines which
neurons will be activated in the
following layer and then
that activation number goes off to the
next layer so we see here
b11 b12 b13 and b14 and the weights
coming in from b1 so let's say b1
fires and it goes into b11 usually you
would see
the weights going all the way down so b2
would have their weights going into
b1 and b2 would then go into b11 b1 b2
b3 and b4 and b5 would then go into b11
and they would have their weights
depending on what came out
it might just be zero so there's nothing
coming through or it might be a
value between zero and one and so forth
for b12
b13 b14 and b15 and then we take those
and they'll have the way to test each
one of those coming out and they go into
the final layer in this case we have
a neuron that represents a square a
neuron that represents a circle
and a neuron that represents a triangle
and just as before the information
reaching this layer is processed
after which a single neuron in the
output layer gets
activated but our input was a square
what went wrong here remember we started
with a square
what do we have coming out is hit a
circle well that's going to be a problem
because we don't want it to tell us that
squares are circles well our network
needs to be trained first
how do we train a network the predicted
output is compared against the actual
output by calculating the cost
function remember our cost function at
the end we take whatever we
said it was going to be and what it
actually is and we just subtract those
two
and the most common way used to generate
the cost function is as follows is we're
going to take
the actual value minus the predicted
value where we have y then you have y
with the half triangle over it is the
predicted and then y is the
actual value we subtract them we square
that value
and then we divide it by two so it's
usually how they generate the cost
function the cost function
determines the error in prediction and
reports it back to the neural network so
we're going to do some
back propagation that's what this is
called back propagation we're going back
through the network the other way and
we're sending that error back the other
way
the weights are adjusted in order to
reduce error the network is trained with
the new weights
and you can see here we have c equals
one half y minus y predicted or y actual
minus y predicted squared
once again the cost is determined and
back propagation is continued until the
cost cannot be reduced
any further now keep in mind you know if
we have one picture of a square
and it goes through we actually do just
a little training we don't change it all
to match that first one
otherwise you'll have about what they
call a bias so each of those data goes
back with our
back propagation and we'll send hundreds
of samples on there
until we can get that cost as a whole
down as low as we can get so that our
average cost is very low without it
being biased towards
one specific figure and you can see here
we have
our input layer hidden layer setup on
here similarly
once we've trained it for our square the
network must also be trained to identify
circles and triangles too so we need
sets of all of these we need lots of
squares lots of circles and lots of
triangles
the weights are this further adjusted in
order to predict the three shapes with
the highest accuracy
we can now rely on our neural network to
predict the input shapes
and you can see we have a triangle
coming in here and it goes through
here's our circle going through and it's
going to light up the circle
and so on for the square so before we
dive into some hands-on
let's take a look at some deep learning
platforms
the primary programming language we're
going to look at four of these platforms
and we're going to start with
torch the primary programming language
is
lua with an implementation in c2 torches
python
implementation is called pi torch this
is interesting because python
has become one of the leads in data
analysis
so you'll almost always see a pi torch
or any one of these will have a python
equivalent and it's slowly spreading
throughout the languages so i'm sure
there's within
torch it's also probably got a java set
up and definitely has a c
because its primary implementation is in
c and so we have cross
cross is a python framework for deep
learning
in usp is reusability of code for the
cpu and gpu
processing we have tensorflow tensorflow
is deep learning platform by google
it was developed in c plus plus and has
his implementation in python and just a
quick highlight
cross and tensorflow have slowly been
working together
so there's a lot of things that you can
actually put cross on top of tensorflow
and access tensorflow although there are
still some tools in tensorflow there
that keras doesn't fully access but it
is a great interface for doing that
and then there's the dl4j is the first
deep learning library written for java
and scala it is integrated with hadoop
and apache spark
you remember apache spark is written in
scala that's one of the reasons that
dl4j came about is so that it would run
on the spark platform so let's take an
introduction to tensorflow google's
tensorflow is currently the most
popular deep learning library in the
world
it has really once they open sourced it
it was just amazing how much it's spread
in use
and how many tools are linked into
tensorflow
tensors are vectors or matrices of n
dimensions
and you can see here we have dimension
five we have a dimension four by five
or five by four as the case is five rows
by four columns
here's one where it's three by three by
three and so this is kind of nice
because when you're processing
pictures there are certain things you
want to do where you want the
pixels to be next to each other that's
very important
uh same thing with your processing see a
movie you might want a three by three
grid coming in
where you have the layers of the frames
coming in to be processed
so you can see how having different
dimensions is really helpful
in analyzing certain data structures and
this is what's so great about tensors is
you can of course flatten them out like
we did earlier or you can process them
based on their location in tensorflow
all computations performed
involve tensors so everything going
through is always looked at as
tensors as a matrix or matrices of in
dimension
tensorflow architecture is as follows
pre-processing data
build a model train and estimate the
model and what we'll do is we'll go
ahead and dig
into use case imitation with tensorflow
to do that
i'm actually going to go into in this
case of you using
the anaconda navigator and you can use
either jupiter lab
or jupiter notebook most people are very
familiar with jupiter notebook it's very
commonly web-based
the jupiter lab is the next version of
jupiter notebook and it just lets you
have
multiple tabs open when you're working
on it and if you're using anaconda
you'll go under environments and you'll
want to make sure that you have your
tensorflow installed and you can simply
we'll do this i have it installed but
you could do all
do all you can do is search under all
for tensor and you can see all the
different tensors it's actually
installed in here version 1.1 3.1
if it wasn't you could check the box and
then run the install on there and it'd
bring it right in but we'll go and start
up our jupiter lab which is going to
open up in this case i use google chrome
and in our jupyter lab or jupiter
notebook if you're in the notebook you
only have one
tab and you won't have the added options
like there's a folder and different
things you can do
in the lab that you can't do in the
notebook but everything we're going to
do you can easily do in the notebook
and you'll start up a new project deep
learning is what i'm going to call this
and if you're not familiar you can
definitely we have some tutorials out
on the use of jupiter notebook and how
to run it and set it up and things like
that
the most basic is we put our code in
here it has a nice display a nice
interface
especially for data science i can
display all kinds of things on this page
and then you can just run this page
right here there's no code in it so it's
not going to show any
thing until i put some code in there and
of course you can cut your cells and
things like that
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tools
now if you haven't remember you gotta
install tensorflow and we'll also use
pandas pandas is a nice database setup
and that again is underneath your
environment and you can see here
your whatever you're working on i simply
learned setup where i've installed
tensorflow and pandas in here
and i'll simply go up here and run this
not gonna see anything so we've just
imported those
into our notebook that we're working on
so those are now available to us
and it helps to have some data to work
with and we have here going to create a
path and a test path
and we'll go ahead and let's just
highlight
this whole path and you can always post
a note either down below in the youtube
video
or you can post a note on
simplylearn.com and ask for this path if
you're not quite picking it up but it is
over here at the
uci edu on their setup and it's in their
archive so it's archive.i
archive.ics.uci.edu
forward slash ml for machine learning
slash
machine dash learning dash databases
slash adult that's quite a mouthful
and in this case we have adult data and
adult test well let's go and just take a
look at that let me just paste that
right in there to our browser window and
here's our adult data and if i click on
there it's going to come down as a
download
i'm going to go ahead and open it as a
text in my notepad
um and the guys in the back were kind
enough to look up to find out what the
actual columns were in this
uh coming across so let me do and take
that to pull that information
it doesn't matter whether i put it
before or below because these are just
variables
but we can see here that we have age
work class
final wgt i'm guessing that's final
we'll look that up in just a second see
what that matches in fact let's pull
that up
and just put them next to each other so
we can kind of see we got here so we
have age
we have our working class state gov
maybe final wage
77 516 education of bachelors
education number 13 marital never
married
admin clerical relationship not in
family
so on and so on so it goes all the way
across here so we've pulled out this
information
native country label etc we'll go ahead
and run this
and so now we've loaded all our
different uh paths
and this path by the way this is the
same columns on here so i don't need to
create a separate columns on the adult
test and once we've run this we've set
those variables let's go ahead and pull
that data in
and to do that we'll use pandas and
we'll create a
df train a df test each one is going to
have our pd for pandas.read csv
they'll have our path we put in there
our path test the first one went ahead
and skip
initial space true names columns there's
our columns in there
index column equals false there's no
index column
on the second one if we went back into
here and we open up
adult test let me just go ahead and open
that up pat
you'll see there's an actual row up here
we want to skip a 1 by 3 cross validator
with all the same data in it so we're
looking at the same data in there
and here we're going to go ahead and
bring in our data and then once you
bring it in it's always nice to see what
kind of shape your data is in
and of course when we talk about shape
we're talking about how many rows and
columns
not whether it's been lifting weights we
can see here we have each one has 15
columns and that goes with our columns
right here if we counter them there's
going to be 15. and the first data set
has 32 561
rows where the second one has 16 281
rows
it's also good to see just how the data
came in so we'll use the
pandas d types we'll run that and you
can see here where age came
in as an integer integer 64. working
class has an
object which makes sense and then we
have our
fnlwgt the education is objects or
well this is an integer integer object
so on all the way down and if we flash
back to the data we look at the last
column it's less than or equal to 50k
and if we scroll down enough we'll see
it's also greater than or equal to 50k
so we'd like to kind of give that its
own special setup on that label
so on that feature we're going to set
the label equal to
if it's less than or equal to 50k it's
going to be zero
and if it's greater than or equal to 50k
it's going to be one
so it's one or the other that's always
an easy easy thing to read
and then we can take this and we go
dftrain.label equals
label item for item and df train label
and this just loops through all the
labels there's a lot of ways
we can do this pandas this might be
actually kind of a slower way there's a
way to do just that
setup and do the logic within the setup
instead of doing a
loop uh but for this this thing will
work fine we're not dealing with a lot
of data
you know it's a large data set but it's
not that big of a data set as data goes
and we also want to do it for our test
data i didn't really mention that we
created two date we're looking at two
different data sets one we're going to
train the data
and then we're going to take it and run
the test data to see if it works so we
have our two different data sets
and we didn't catch it off the bat if
you were pulling up this you're going to
pull up
one the this is the training set and if
we go back in here and open up the test
set let me just go back and do that
adult test one of the things that we
didn't notice that you'll want to pull
up
is at the end there's a period so we're
pre-processing our data we want to make
sure that
we include that period in every line on
the second set up so i go back to my
jupiter notebook i've got to have a
label t
which is less than or equal to 50k
period or greater than equal to 50k
period for 1.
otherwise it's doing the exact same
thing we're going to change
the df train label and the df test label
to 0 or 1.
we'll just run that we'll go ahead and
print the df
train label value counts and the df test
label value counts
this is always a good idea because we
want to know is there any weird stuff
going on there
if there's no value stuff like that this
will turn up on that setup and we can
see here we have
zeros how many zeros how many ones and
so on on there
just a quick view of the data that we're
going through and if we go back
up here go ahead and print the train d
types again
and we run that you could actually run
it up there and give you the new answer
because it's loaded this information uh
we now see it's an integer and if you go
back up here
it was an object so that makes life a
little easier as far as what we're doing
with this
now at this point we're going to look at
the data and we can see we have
a lot of numbers and we have a lot of
categories in here uh
so categories would be united states
male never married versus seven and we
can also see that when we looked at this
we have our integers
we have our objects working class so the
next thing we want to do
on there is we want to go ahead and take
that we have integers and the objects
and we want to bring that down here we
want to create those categories in a way
that the
computer can see them and we'll start
with our continuous features like age
we can see age integer fnl wgt
is an integer capital gain is an integer
educational number there's our
educational numbers and integer and so
on uh so if we're going to have
these as continuous features where
they're an integer
we also need to make a list of the
categorical features we want to work
with
such as working class education marital
occupation relationship
race sex and native country and again
these are all objects uh so that makes
sense and when we flip back over to the
data we can see here we're actually
looking at united states if we continue
down
see if i can find another one a lot of
united states on this particular one i
was getting worried there for a second
that we only had united states and it
was a very biased
uh census which it probably is for
wherever it came from and of course
bachelor's
associate vocational some college so you
can see this is more categorical versus
an actual number
uh so now we have our categorical and we
have our continuous features and this is
just the list of these so let's go ahead
and run that and load that list in there
so we can now start manipulating our
data with it
now we get our first line of tensor flow
code
which is exciting and we're going to
create a variable continuous features
and what we're doing in here is we're
going to go into tf
feature columns so we have the feature
columns we're going to set those up
numeric columns k for k in continual
features
so this is going to go in here and says
each one of these
is a continual feature we're going to
feed that into the feature column not
very exciting on the output
because we're just creating this
variable here letting it know what
columns are what
then we're going to create a
relationship
set up so we have continuous features
and then we have a relationship and
again we're doing tf
but in this case we use feature column
so just like this one we're telling it
feature column
and now we do categorical column with
vocabulary list
so it's one of the things we can do with
tensorflow and we're going to feed it
one we have relationship and so we're
just drilling down to the relationship
column and these are the options they
had so this is going to be the
vocabulary attached to
this column and we'll go ahead and run
that so we load up our relationship
and then we're going to do one more way
of loading uh in this one we're going to
do categorical features
and so in categorical features we're
going to do tf
feature column there's our command we've
already seen before
it's going to be categorical column with
hash bucket
we're going to create buckets in this
case for k
and categorical features so it's going
to create a bucket for each one of these
categorical features and the bucket size
is
1000. so we're looking at and we've
actually kind of repeated something
because relationship is also in the
bucket setup on there but we want to
show you
three major ways of loading in your
different features
one is our features that we know where
it's going to be a number
uh so our continuous features then we
can set it as a relationship
in this case we actually created a
vocabulary husband not in family very
clear vocabulary on there and then we
also are loading just
general categories into buckets you can
set different bucket settings in here
we went ahead and just went with a
thousand so pretty much everything
since there's not a huge number of
categories each one gets their own kind
of bucket setup in there
and as far as the initial setup we need
to go ahead and create a model
so this is where it starts to come
together we've as far as the pre-setup
we have our tf we have an estimator
we're going to do
linear classifier on the estimator in
classes equals two so we know there's
only two classes we're looking at
we have ongoing train feature columns
and then we have our different
we have categorical features plus
continuous features
so this basically creates our model what
data is going in
and we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see here that it gives us a little
information
that we had our tensorflow using default
config you can change a lot of defaults
you can change
as far as the model directory uh random
seed
saving summary check points there's all
kinds of things you can go in here and
set up rewrite options keep checkpoint
mix etc
at this point the model hasn't done
anything all we've done is create the
model
so let's just do a real quick rehash of
what we've done so far
what we started off with is we grab some
data in this case
uh an adult an adult test we have a
training data set and a test data set
we set the columns up we took a very
short brief exploration of the data in
its shape
as far as what we're working with we
changed our label around a little bit so
that the label makes a little bit more
sense of zero one
instead of for the machine it's easier
to spit out a zero or a one
we can look up here we double check to
make sure we how many zeros and ones we
have double check our data make sure
it's integer 64. nothing weird's going
on
and then we look to three different ways
that we can kind of label the data
as far as the way we're going to read it
we have our continuous features and a
categorical features
here's our relationship which is one of
them we went ahead and created our model
we did not put the relationship in here
which you can do you can actually
maybe take it out of categorical and
then have its own on here
instead of having categorical features
and continuous features and so on
so we've created our setup for our model
the next thing we need to do is we need
to go ahead and create a function
letting it know how to read the data
into our model how are we going to train
it
and let's go ahead and create two
variables the first one is going to be
features this is just all the features
that are in there and then the second
one
is going to be our label and this is
basically
we're looking at all the different
information we can put into it
and then is that person based on that
information going to make less than or
greater than 50k
that's what that comes down to now the
next part uh the definition we're going
to create has a lot in it and we're
going to feed
this definition into our model training
uh so there's a lot of stuff that goes
on here
first we'll call it get input and
function def get input function we have
our data set
number of epochs equals none in batch
equals 128
shuffle equals true so we're running
this and it's going to return a tf
estimator inputs pandas input
function and in this case it's going to
be x equals our pd data frame
k data set k values for k in features
y is pd series data set label values
batch size equals in batch number of
epochs
equals number of epochs shuffle equals
shuffle
so in here we're passing in uh the
number of epochs
we're not too worried about we're going
to just go once through the data there's
a lot of data in there we don't need to
rerun it
epics is how many times do you cover all
the data and then
how many groups of data do you pull in
and batch at a time
so we're only going to look at 128 do
the reverse propagation like we talked
about
and then it'll go to the next batch and
the next batch and the next batch and it
shuffles them so shuffle means that
we're randomly picking where they're
coming from uh
like again we're only doing we're not
too worried about the number of epics
for this particular model depending on
how much data you have and depending
what you're running
depends on how many epics you need to
run and there's a lot of rules on how
many
epics you need to run one of them is if
you're
training data and you're testing data
because you'll check your testing data
against your training data if your
testing data starts
having a better results in your training
data that means you're no longer fitting
towards the data but you're fitting to
the answer
so it's kind of these little weird
things you start to on here
and tensorflow is really cool because it
actually checks a lot of that for you
but we're just going to set number of
epics equal to zero and then we have our
data set going in
so we're creating our get function how
do we get the data
into training our model and we'll go
ahead and run that so now we have our
data function
and now it knows where the data is
coming from so we need to go ahead and
train it
and that simply would take our model we
created way up here that's where we take
the model there
we've told it what columns is going to
pull in so it knows what columns it's
looking at
know what the definition was going to
get the information from so now we want
to go ahead and train
it and here's our input function equals
in this case get
input function and here we tell it that
our data set is a df train
number of epochs equals none which is
already automatically set up there
in batch equals 128 which is what we
have up here
shuffle equals false and we're going to
do 1000 steps
so we're actually going to go through
128 batches but we're going to do that a
thousand times
and we'll go ahead and run this and i
just ran an update so it's going to give
me some warnings because of that update
and then we're back here and it's still
going to construct pipelines use tf data
module
not a big problem we let it go ahead and
run all the way through on here
and it takes it just a moment there we
go there's our thousand coming out
as you can see here here's a checkpoints
for 1000 ongoing training
1001 global steps and this is just all
the reverse propagation going on that's
what we're doing here
uh one of the things we didn't cover is
we do it in small increments so it's not
all done
like one error goes all the way back
you'd only do a part of that error
and each one sends back a little piece
and so you slowly adjust
your different weights going all the way
back and then if you're going to train
your model
we want to know how it did so we're
going to do model
evaluate and our input function
equals remember our input function up
here that we created way up here
we're going to take this input function
and instead of the data set that's
coming in
we put in the data set here for training
where's our training
input train there we go df underscore
train
uh now we're going to go ahead and
evaluate and here it is
a git input function test so we're going
to test the data out
number of epochs one we don't need to
rerun it more than once
per batch 128 so on shuffle and steps a
thousand so we're going to go ahead and
evaluate this let's just see how good
our test
data did uh how good our model was
programmed on our training data and how
it evaluates on the test
and we can see it going on down here
where it's got the evaluating
graph was finalized let me just
highlight that
ongoing model checkpoint tensorflow
running local init
evaluate 100 out of 1000 and so on and
once it gets to the end we get a nice
output here we have an accuracy in this
case of 0.79
with a baseline of 0.76 so now we've
created a model
uh let's go ahead and tweak it a little
bit so we have our accuracy up here
what we're going to do is we're going to
look at age and let's just go ahead and
create a new
square value for age and the reason we
want to look into the square value of
age is we know that if you really look
through the data you'll find that as a
young person
the age keeps increasing as you get
close to retirement it begins to
decrease
so we square the value of age and that's
very data specific when we're looking at
data
you'll find that any kind of data that
has that kind of like
uptick and down tick by squaring it or
square rooting it you can get some very
different results
and so we're going to go and square our
age and this is kind of it's interesting
because at this point even at the
beginning of this we're focused on
deep learning and on tensorflow but
before i would begin even looking at
any of this i would have probably run
some kind of heat map or some kind of
evaluation in r
or sk learn in python to find out the
correlation between different features
to see just how well they correlate to
each other and there certainly are some
wonderful tools for that because
sometimes you can just mark off some
features and other features you bring in
but for the deep learning we can see how
we can just dump it all in there and let
it
sort it out itself and we're going to
just write a quick little function here
to take the square
variable in this case we have dft dfte
this is our
training and your test variable and the
variable age coming in and we just want
to go ahead and create a new
under dft and the new is going to be the
variable name whatever we put in there
which will be age
so let's load this here's our functions
now loaded and certainly we could have
just done that as a line of code
but you start to get the feeling that
when you build these um
functions you might use it you can now
use this function if you had a number of
different features that had this kind of
quality to them and we have our df train
new so we're going to create a new
training
and a new test and it's going to equal
the square variable dftrain or dftest
and the variable name is age
let's just go ahead and run that and so
now we have our new our df train new and
df test
new and just like we did before let's
just double check the shape of our data
and make sure it all matches
and when we look at the output here
really what's important
is that each one of these has 16
features in it
we want to make sure we're not getting
something weird on there and our
training
set has 32 561
rows in it and this one has just over 16
000 in there
and everything's pretty much the same
except that in our continuous features
new we now have the new column we put in
there so we need to change that
and we have our continuous features new
down here which we're going to load up
with our tf feature column numerical
this would all look familiar because we
just did this
and so we're going to load that up with
the new being the new value in there
let's go ahead and run that and we'll
create a model that we'll call it model
one and this is the same that we did
before
except now we have our continuous
features new in here
so here's our new model in this case
model one instead of model and we're
going to build that model right there
now we haven't trained it all we've done
is told it where to get the data and how
to get the data and what features are
coming in
we haven't actually told it everything
on the features coming in because we
still need to
also build our full our get input
function so where's the input coming
from so we built the model with the
features in it and now we need to go
ahead
and create our get input function this
is the same as before but you'll see
we now have it with the data set coming
in is going to be the same data set up
here
and so if we scroll a little bit to the
right we should see the new
and there it is sure enough there's our
new on the right and so let's go ahead
and run that
now we've defined our model we defined
where the information is coming from and
again you can go back and review the
first part because this is identical
that we did before
except now we have new as the column for
the age
and we'll go ahead and do our model one
and let's go ahead and train it there's
our input function git input function
that we defined up here
dftrain is going to be the same and
everything else is going to be the same
let's go ahead and run that and it
should go through here and run the
tensor info coming in and it's going to
go through
in this case we have steps 1000
shuffling so it's going to go randomly
128 per batch
and then the epics is automatic we're
not worried about that today
so now we have a trained tensorflow
model and with our new model just like
we did before
we want to go ahead and evaluate it uh
so it's the same setup we had before
with our same git input function with
our df
test new in here coming in so there's
our new data coming in
and this is really common when you're
doing these models you make little tiny
tweaks to see if you can improve it one
of the best
articles i read recently was you build
your model to fail
you want a running model so you actually
have something to compare against and
then you continually tweak it till you
get a better accuracy now i don't expect
the accuracy necessarily to get better
on this
because of the way we partition the data
but we can see here we now have an
accuracy of 0.76 which is a little bit
over the baseline and it's about what i
would have expected it to be kind of the
same
the reason is because we split the data
at the 50
the people making over 50k and those
making less and so
the age factor shouldn't be a huge
factor it would be if we were looking at
more
discrete buckets like 40 to 50 50 to 60
60 to 70 when we create buckets but in
this i didn't really expect it to go up
that much in fact we could probably run
it a dozen times which would be
very bad data science and we see we
actually had a slightly better one up
here
but our baseline accuracy was 0.76 and
we come down here we still see
here's our accuracy baseline 0.763 that
didn't really change
and you know the accuracy didn't really
go up that much i could hit the run
button a few times i would probably
upbeat the one above so not a big change
but that's all right that's how we learn
is how we go through and
figure out what's going to work with our
data and what's not
what's going to improve the quality of
our data so we have a better prediction
and what's not and we can now go ahead
and utilize
this model this is where it gets
exciting when you're actually working
with somebody or with your clients and
you come in and say okay here's my
predictions
we're going to take a create a list and
we're going to use model one and we're
going to predict
and our input function is get input
function df test
new again this probably doesn't make too
big of a difference but we'll go ahead
and stick with the new data we created
number of epics 1 batch 128 so all this
should look pretty familiar but we're
running the prediction so we're going to
load all our predictions
into the predictions and let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it go through the
tensorflow setup so it's running done
running local
ops and then let's just go ahead and
print the df test
new ilocation zero so row zero
and we're gonna look at the predictions
also for the same location zero let's go
ahead and run that and we can see here
that we have age 25
work class private it has all the
information coming in for that
individual
and then it comes down here we go ahead
and get our
prediction and in this particular
instance there's our label zero
uh then we come down here and we see
takes a little bit for the
setup to look up but there's our array
which also returns a zero and it has
information for us on there
probabilities logistics on here
so you can see there's all kinds of
additional information you can pull from
this
and likewise we could do it for a
position three
let me go ahead and run that and what's
kind of nice about this is you can now
see here's label one
and here's our logistics output and
again if the kind of hunt for a little
bit in this particular setup but here's
the output array
and there's our one and they match label
one one so we predicted for the
very first one location zero that it's
going to be a zero on the label it's
going to make under fifty thousand and
the individual in two
working class uh private whatever set up
on here
capital gain capital f loss etc came up
as one meaning they're going to make
over 50 000
so we covered a lot i mean this is the
basics
and you can see as you dig deeper when
you look at some of this code let me
just
go back up here we're way back up here
at the very top a little too far
overshot
as we start working in here we have one
defining your features
and at this point we didn't show this
but i would probably use either
python or r to show a relationship
correlation because they have some
really easy packages in there to pull
that up so you can see what features are
really connected and how they're
connected
uh and then we showed you different
features like we have ones that are
integers and then we have ones like sex
that are objects
you're zero one you're male or female
you're uh same thing with the race
um probably have just a maybe 16
different races listed there ethnicities
things like that native country again
that's you don't have like
infinite number of native countries you
just have a handful
so we look at this we have our features
we looked at that we have our continuous
features like
age which is a number or in this case an
integer an
education number how many years and so
on along with
your race your sex your relationship
which are just very abbreviated
uh categorical data uh so we looked at
that we went in there and we showed you
how
to um where was it here we go we go back
up here so we create our model the model
has knows what
categories are coming in that's really
important and this is probably the one
of the more complicated
parts of this is our input function and
this input function is so important so i
want to just
re-hash the input function for that
reason uh this lets us know how we're
pulling the data
it lets us know um if we're going to go
through all the data
20 times or we're going to let the or
we're just going to let tensorflow
itself keep going until the training
model
reaches a point that point is based
on uh with what they call bias you can
become biased on your training data and
so when it hits a certain point where it
becomes
overly biased to just that data then it
doesn't really work really good in the
outside world you start losing
keep it generic but as close as possible
to the right answer so generic
answers for a huge amount of data and
then we have our batch size
are we going to shuffle it which we did
and then also our estimator inputs
so you have your estimator function here
and then of course where the actual data
is coming from so you can see all this
is in that get input function that's
where a lot of the work comes
in putting this together and then we
train our model that's pretty
straightforward once you have your input
function
and all your setup training the model is
quick and then we go ahead and evaluate
and then we can go ahead and create a
predict and then you know look at our
predictions and how they work on
individuals
uh so it's pretty it gives you a whole
roundabout setup on here and how this is
set up and how it's working
certainly there are um a lot more things
you can do
with tensorflow this is the basic
tensorflow and it's always developing so
it's exciting this is gonna be one of
the most exciting
fields right now because it is really in
an infant
stage and just exploding in the market
if getting your learning started is half
the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
welcome to tensorflow 2.0
tutorial what's in it for you we're
going to cover today
deep learning frameworks what is
tensorflow
features of tensorflow tensorflow
applications
how tensorflow works tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0
tensorflow 2.0 architecture and then
we'll go over a tensorflow demo where we
roll up our sleeves
and dive right into the code so let's
start with
deep learning frameworks to start with
this chart doesn't even do the filled
justice because it's just exploded these
are just some of the major frameworks
out there
there's a cross which happens to sit on
tensorflow so they're very
integrated there's tensorflow
pie torches out there cafe piano
dl4j and chainer these are just a few of
the deep learning frameworks
we're talking about neural networks if
you're just starting out never seen a
neural network you can go into python in
the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know
but the most robust version out there
the most top
of the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow
and that of course is changing from day
to day and some of these
are better for different purposes so
let's dive into tensorflow
let's see what is tensorflow what is
tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
library released in 2015 by google brain
team for building machine learning
and deep learning models it is based on
python programming language and performs
numerical computations using data flow
graphs to build
models so let's take a look at some of
the features
of tensorflow it works efficiently with
multi-dimensional
arrays if you've ever played with any of
the simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and
make sure your your stuff is set in a
flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here
where you have x and y coordinates where
the picture is and then
each pixel has three or four different
channels
that's a very complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array
it provides scalability of computation
across machines
and large data sets this is so new right
now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when
python is operating on one computer and
it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow addresses and does a very
good job on it supports fast debugging
and model building this is why i love
tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers
each layer might have different
properties they have like the
convolutional neural network which you
can then sit
on top of a regular neural network with
reverse propagation
there's a lot of tools in here and a lot
of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard
to visualize the model tensorboard is
pretty
recent but it's a really nice tool to
have so when you're working with other
people or showing your
clients or the shareholders in the
company
you can give them a nice visual model so
they know what's going on what are they
paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow
when we talk about tensorflow
applications
uh clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term
this is the programming side and it's
really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation
fraud detection video detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different
than if you have a set numbers like
you're looking at the stock market
you can use this on the stock market but
if you're doing something where the
numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks in
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are
after all that is what tensor that's
what this is named after so we talk
about
tensors in tensorflow tensorflow is
derived from its core component known as
a tensor a tensor is a vector or a
matrix of n dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers might be a number in a direction
you have a simple matrix and then we get
into the tensor
i mentioned how a picture is a very
complicated tensor because it has your x
y
coordinates and then each one of those
pixels has three to four channels for
your different colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and in tensorflow tensors are defined
by a unit of dimensionality called as
rank and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
so it's a rank one matrix would have
rank two
and then as you can see right here as we
get into the full tensor
it has a rank three and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at the basics
of a neural network in reverse
propagation
that is the basics of tensorflow and
then it goes through a lot of different
options and properties that you can
build into your different tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs
it has nodes that represent the
operations in your model
and if you look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs b
c and d and you might have x equals b
plus c
y equals d minus four a equals
x times y and then you have an output
and so even though this isn't a neural
network here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more
you can actually one of the tensors is a
neural network with reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it
and this here is just a basic flow of
computations
of the data going across and you can see
we can plug in the numbers
b equals four c equals three d equals
six and you get x equals four plus three
so x equals seven y equals six minus
four so y equals two
and finally a equals seven times two or
a equals 14.
like i said this is a very simplified
version of how tensorflow works
each one of these layers can get very
complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different
setups up very easily and test them out
so you can test out these different
models to see how they work now
tensorflow has gone through two major
stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0
and then they came out with the 2.0
version
and the 2.0 addressed so many things out
there that the 1.0 really needed
so we start talking about tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code
the first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly
and you can see here from tensorflow 1
to tensorflow 2
we have almost double the code to do the
same thing
so if i want to do with tf.session or
tensorflow session
as a session the session run you have
your variables your session run you have
your tables initializer
and then you do your model fit x train y
train and then your validation data your
x value y value and your epics and your
batch size all that goes into the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager
so if you see the first part you're like
what the heck is all the session thing
going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into
2.0 it's just nice and clean if you
remember from the beginning i said cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow
2.0 it has incorporated cross as
tf.caras
cross provides a number of model
building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project
and we'll hopefully touch base a little
bit more on this sequential
being the most common uh form that is
your
your layers are going from one side to
the other
so everything's going in a sequential
order functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models
and then they come back together and one
of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff
or a neural basic reverse propagation
neural network
and then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into cross
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently in the tensorflow cross setup
a third big change we're going to look
at is it in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of
and here we have a little bit more on
the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow 1 asks you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope
that's not even necessary in tensorf 2.0
so you'd have to do one before you do
do what you see the code in 2.0 in 2.0
you just create your model it's a
sequential model and then you can add
all your layers in
you don't have to pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version
and then we have the last two which is
our api cleanup
and the autograph in the api cleanup
tensorflow 1 you could build models
using tf gans tf app tf contrib tf flags
etc
in tensorflow 2 a lot of apis have been
removed
and this is just they just cleaned them
up because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them
and that's your tf app your tf flags
your tf logging are all gone
uh so there's those are three legacy
features that are not
in 2.0 and then we have our tf function
and autograph feature
in the old version uh tensorflow 1 0 the
python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function
to mark it for the jit compilation for
the python jit
so that tensorflow runs it as a single
graph
autograph feature of tf function helps
to write graph code using
natural python syntax now we just threw
in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph
is what are all those lines that are
connecting different objects
so if you remember from before where we
had the different
layers going through sequentially each
one of those white lined
arrows would be a graph x that's where
that computation is taken care of and
that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward
you can now put your own function in
there instead of using whatever function
they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing
next let's go for hierarchy and
architecture
and then we'll cover three basic tools
in tensorflow before we roll up our
sleeves and dive into the example
so let's just take a quick look at
tensorflow toolkits in their hierarchy
at the high level we have our object
oriented api
so this is what you're working with you
have your tf cross you have your
estimators
this sits on top of your tf layers tf
losses tf metrics
so you have your reusable libraries for
model building
this is really where tensorflow shines
is between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers
you can your losses your metrics all of
that is so built into tensorflow makes
it really easy to use
and then you can get down to your low
level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model
and then go to the other where it does a
neural network
and maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it
and then it comes together into another
layer which is
another neural network so you can build
these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around
and most recently we have the tf code
can run on multiple
platforms and so you have your cpu
which is basically like on the computer
i'm running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models neural network kind of
setup
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms
for the most diverse setup out there
and moving on from the hierarchy to the
architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with and 80
of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on
uh once you have all that set up you
have your distribution strategy
where are you going to run it you going
to be running it on just your regular
cpu
are you going to be running it with the
gpu added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it
or do you have a specialized tpu set up
in there that you paid extra money for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package
you might need to run this on some
really high processors because you're
processing at a server level for
uh let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy
but you're distributing it into a server
where that server might be
analyzing thousands and thousands of
purchases done
every minute and so you need that higher
speed
to give them a um to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
uh data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed
so that when you have hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey
this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about
all those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is
we were talking about that earlier where
it used to be when you did one of these
models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your machine in
the office
and then you need to distribute it and
so we have our tensorflow serving cloud
on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi
a little breakout board there in fact
they just came out with a new one
that has a built-in there's just a
little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model on to that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product
you have the tensorflow js which is for
browser and node server
so you can get that out on the browser
for some simple computations that don't
require a lot of heavy lifting
but you want to distribute to a lot of
endpoints and now they also have other
language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c
java go c sharp rust r or from whatever
package you're working on
so we kind of have an overview of the
architecture and what's going on
behind the scenes and in this case
what's going on as far as distributing
it
let's go ahead and take a look at three
specific pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and
sessions so very basic things you need
to know and understand when you're
working with the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow
in tensorflow constants are created
using the function constant
in other words they're going to stay
static the whole time whatever you're
working with
the syntax for constant value
d type 9 shape equals none name constant
verify shape equals false that's kind of
the syntax you're looking at and we'll
explore this
with our hands on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z
equals t f dot constant 5.2 name equals
x d type is a float that means that
we're never going to change that 5.2 is
going to be a constant value
and then we have our variables in
tensorflow variables in tensorflow are
in memory buffers that store
tensors and so we can declare a two by
three tensor populated by ones
you could also do constants this way by
the way you can create a
an array of ones for your constants i'm
not sure why you do that but you know
you might need that for some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice
2 by 3 array that's filled with ones
and then of course you can go in there
and they're variables so you can change
them it's a tensor so you have full
control over that
and then you of course have sessions in
tensorflow
a session in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about
all that information then goes through
all those arrows and whatever
computations they have that take it to
the next node
and you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf
if we do x equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0
or 20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer
with tf session as session you can do a
session run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the
10 plus 20 is 30. and we'll be looking
at this a lot
more closely as we actually roll up our
sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through
anaconda and then i'll use specifically
the jupiter notebook on there
and of course this code is going to work
uh
whatever platform you choose whether
you're in a notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects
we're going to stick with jupiter
notebook pie charm
uh whatever it is you're going to use in
here you have your spider
and your qt console for different
programming environments
the thing to note is kind of hard to see
but i have my main
pi 36 right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3.6
if you have python version three seven
or three eight
you're probably going to get some errors
in there might be that they've already
updated and i don't know it now you have
an older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up
make sure you go ahead and pip in your
tensorflow or if you're in anaconda you
can do
a conda install tensorflow to make sure
it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out
depending on what i'm working on making
it really easy to adjust
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and
once we're in our new python window this
is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick no errors
yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that
simply by using the version command in
tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and you know it always confuses me
because sometimes you do tf.version for
one thing
you do tf.underscore version underscore
for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in
tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i
did tell you the the um we were going to
dig a little deeper into our constants
and you can do an array of constants
and we'll just create this nice array a
equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the ray
right in there 4 3 6
1. we can run this and now that is what
a is equal to
and if we want to just double check that
remember we're in jupiter notebook where
i can just put the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print otherwise you round you surround
it in print
and you can see it's a tf tensor it has
the shape the type and the
and the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a two by
two array and if we go ahead and print
the v
out we'll run that and sure enough
there's our tf
variable in here then we can
also let's just go back up here and add
this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b
tf constant and if we go and print out
v and b i'm going to run that and
this is an interesting thing that always
that happens in here uh you'll see right
here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands
uh so important to remember that in
jupyter notebooks we can easily fix that
by go ahead and
print and surround v with brackets and
now we can see with the two different
variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable
and this is just a flat constant so it
comes up as a tf
tensor shape 2 kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf
variable so that's how it's looking in
the back end when you're talking about
the difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v
and with the constant we have a
lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here and
just like any other array in math we can
do like a
concatenate or concatenate the different
values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated
you just do a t f dot concat values and
there's our a b
axis on one hopefully you're familiar
with axes and how that works when you're
dealing with matrixes
and if we go ahead and print this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so let's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six
one four five it's concatenated the two
together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one
this means we're doing the columns um so
if you had a longer array like right now
we have an array that is like you know
has a shape one whatever it is two comma
two
um axes zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one
and it translates as columns and rows if
we had a shape
let me just put the word shape here um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix
is going which is column which is rows
are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes axes one you know
zero one two
that's going to be our columns and if
you can do columns
then we also can do rows and that is
simply just changing the concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy ctrl v
and change this from axis one to axis
zero
and if we run that uh you'll see that
now we concatenate
by a row as opposed to column and you
have four three six one seven eight four
seven so it just brings it right down
and turns it into rows versus columns
you can see the difference there your
output this really
you want to look at the output sometimes
just to make sure your eyes are looking
at it correctly
and it's in the format i find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than
understanding what's going on because
conceptually your mind just
just too many dimensions sometimes the
second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array
so tensorflow is utilizing numpy as part
of their format
as far as python is concerned and so you
can treat
you can treat this output like a numpy
array because it is just that it's going
to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think
is filling uh one of these with zeros or
ones
and so you can see here we just create a
tensor tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we print out our tensor
again we're in jupiter so i just type
out tensor
and i run this you can see i have a nice
array
of the shape three comma four of zeros
one of the things i want to highlight
here is
integer 32 if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here of 32.
the reason for this is that we want to
control
how many bits are used in the precision
this
is for exporting it to another platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes
does a float to indefinite however long
it wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on
any computer and so we need to control
whether it's a tf float 16
in this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float so if i
run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point
whatever and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a
tensorflow with ones and you might ask
yourself
why would i want zeros and ones and your
first thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job
solving it if you start with a uniform
set of ones or zeros
you're dealing with a lot of bias so be
very careful about
starting a neural network for one of
your rows or something like that with
ones and zeros
on the other hand i use this for masking
you can do a lot of work with masking
you can also have
it might be that one tenser row is
masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones
and there are cases where you do want to
initialize it with all zeros or all ones
and then swap in different numbers as as
the
tensor learns so it's another form of
control
but in general you see zeros and ones
you usually are talking about a mask
over another array and just like in
numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped
three comma four maybe we want to swap
that to four comma three
and if we print this out you will see
let me just go and do that
ctrl v let me run that and you'll see
that the
the order of these is now switched
instead of four across now we have three
across and four down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random uniform
uh and we'll go ahead and just take off
well we'll go and leave that we're going
to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71 and then
instead of having this one it rolls down
here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you feel
a lot of times you fill these with
random numbers and so this is
the random.uniform is one of the ways to
do that now
i just talked a little bit about this
float 32
and all these data types uh one of the
things that comes up of course is
recasting your data so if we have a
d type float 32 we might want to convert
these to integers because of the project
we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take
a dollar amount or a float value and
then have to round it off to a dollar
amount so we only wanted two decimal
points
and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot
or then convert it to an integer was one
way to round it off kind of
a cheap and dirty trick so we can take
this and we can take this same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer
and so we're going to take this tensor
we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor and then we're going to go ahead
and print
our tensor let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo copy and paste works
fine but sometimes be aware that
copy and paste can copy the wrong code
over personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took um a float
32 4.6 4.2 and so on
and it just converts it right down to a
integer value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about a little bit
about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
of the things that is important to be
able to do
is to take one of these variables we'll
just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a
out and we run this you'll see that's
the same array
but we've flipped it so that our columns
and rows are flipped
this is the same as reshaping
so when you transpose you're just doing
a reshape what's nice about this
is if you look at the numbers the
columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row
so you're not maintaining the structure
of your matrix
so when we do a reshape up here they're
similar but they're not quite the same
and you can actually go in here and
there's settings in
the reshape that would allow you to turn
it into a transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so
there are so many times you have to
transpose your digits that this is
important to know that you can just do
that you can flip your rows and columns
rather quickly here
and just like numpy you can also do
multiple your different math functions
we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v four comma
two
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array
um but instead we're going to do just
a two by one array and the code for that
is your tf dot
mat mole uh so matrix multiplier
and we have a times v and if we go ahead
and run this up let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this you'll
see that we end up with
36 by 30. and if it's been a while since
you've seen the matrix math
this is five times four plus eight times
two three times four
plus nine times two and that's where we
get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the
basic functionality so the matrix or
your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things is to note is that
just like in numpy you have all of your
different math
so we have our tf math and if we go in
here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
um oh let's do some multiplication
that's always good
we'll stick with our av our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bitwise
multiplication and we'll create an
av which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the four
two and the five eight three nine and it
produces
a 2032 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have 4 times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity
matrix which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones
and zeros across the other side let's go
ahead and take a look and see what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way
very similar to your numpy you can do a
dot shape and it's going to return
a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print we'll do rows
oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this you can see we have
three rows
two columns and then if we go ahead and
create an identity
matrix
the script for that got a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d
type is a 32 and then if we go ahead and
just print out
our identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this
as a prediction model and seeing how it
functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use
for that let's go back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go bring this out so it takes
up the whole window because i like to do
that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you've got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how
keras sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go and do a lot of imports
date times warning sci-pi sci pi
is your math so
the back end scientific math warnings
because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup
and of course date time pandas again
is your data frame think rows and
columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which
of course tensorflow is integrated
heavily with
seaborn for our graphics and the seaborn
as
sns is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as
mpl and then of course we're going to
import our matplot library pie plot as
plt and right off the bat we're going to
set
some graphic colors patch force edge
color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style
you can look this all up there's when
you get into matplot library into
seaborne
there are so many options in here it's
just kind of nice to make it look pretty
when we start the
we start up that way we don't have to
think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color
dim gray line with again this is all
part of our graphics here
in our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
uh node interactivity equals last
expression
uh here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns
so we don't want to display more than
50. and then our matplot library is
going to be
inline this is a jupiter notebook thing
the matplot library in line
then warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings
that way when they come up we don't have
to worry about them not really what you
want to do when you're working on
a major project you want to make sure
you know those warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this
it's just going to be loading all that
into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and
import our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under keras now remember cross
kind of sits
on tensorflow so when we're importing
cross and the sequential model we are in
effect
importing tensorflow underneath of it
we just brought in the math probably
should have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential
now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick uh
recall on that and so in cross
uh we have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier
and if you remember from here we have a
sequential
where it's going one tensorflow layer at
a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in
but it goes in one direction all the
time where functional
can have a very complicated graph of
directions you can have the data split
into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one
where now you're adding your own
subclasses into the
tensor to do external computations
right in the middle of like a huge flow
of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where
cross and tensorflow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers cross
has so many built-in layers you can do
your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website
you can see as we scroll down for the
cross layers that are built
in we can get down here and we can look
at let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
um activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here
we had the relu which is the basic
activation that was listed up here for
layer activations you can change those
and here we have our core layers and our
dense layers you have an input layer a
dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long term short term memory
layer
and of course you can even do your own
custom layers in cross
there's a whole functionality in there
if you're doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the
convolutional layers this is for
processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is white cross is
so popular it's open source and you have
all these tools right at your fingertips
so from cross we're just going to import
a couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer and
then of course from
sk learn our scikit we want to go ahead
and do our min max scalar standard
scalar for pre
editing our data and then metrics just
so we can take a look at the errors and
compute those
let me go ahead and run this and that
just loads it up we're not expecting
anything
from the output and our file coming in
is going to be air quality.csv
and let's go ahead and take a quick look
at that this is in open office it's just
a standard
you know making do excel whatever you're
using for your spreadsheet
and you can see here we have a number of
columns
a number of rows it actually goes down
to like 8 000.
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row is bendung
i'm guessing that's a reference for the
profile if we scroll to the bottom which
i'm not going to do because it takes
forever to get back up
they're all the same the same thing with
the status the status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp
on there so we have a date and time we
have our o3
co no2 reading so2 no
co2 voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4
pm 10 10 without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality
as far as an area in a region and what's
going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame
df is a nice abbreviation commonly used
for data frames
equals pd.read csv and then our the path
to it just happens to be on my d
drive separated by spaces and so if we
go ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there
overshot but you can see it's the same
data we were just looking at
we're looking at the number we're
looking at the profile which is the
bandung
the date we have a timestamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows
we could easily have done three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five
for pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time
uh let's come in in two columns we have
our date here
and we have our time and we want to go
ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combine date
datetime that's
our formula we're building our we're
going to submit
our pandas dataframe and the tab name
when we go ahead and do this that's all
of our information that we want to go
ahead and create
and then goes for i and range df shape
0.
so we're going to go through the whole
setup and we're going to list tab append
df location i
and here is our date going in there
and then return the numpy array list tab
d types date time 64.
that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead
and do df date time equals combine date
time
and then i always like to print we'll do
df head
just to see what that looks like and so
when we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's edited on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the format's changed so
there's our
we've added in the date time column and
we've brought the date over
and we've taken this format here and
it's an actual uh
variable with a 0 0 0 on here
well that doesn't look good so we need
to also include
the time part of this and we want to
convert it into hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that to do that
to finish combining our date time let's
go ahead and create a
little script here to combine the time
in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and
cr forcing this into a date time format
and we can actually spend hours just
going through
uh these conversions how do you pull it
from the
panda's data frame how do you set it up
um so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff
is going to be reformatting these things
resetting them back
up so that it looks right on here and
you know it just takes time to get
through all that but that is usually
what the companies are paying you for
that's what the
big bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
um now remember we can select from df
are different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data
so there's nothing in there that
exciting and then we want to go ahead
and we'll create a
second data frame here let me just get
rid of the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see what we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time
03 co so now this is in the same
order as it was before and you'll see
the date time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want
and in the right sequential order and if
we go back to
there we go our air quality you can see
right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want
and that should reflect right here in
the columns we picked
coming across so this is all the same
columns on there that's all we've done
is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at
and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our
you know describe gives us our basic
data analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation uh minimum amount
maximum amount we have our first quarter
second quarter and third quarter
numbers also in there so you can get a
quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable we're going to look at
a number of things for each variable
and we'll see right here q1 we can
simply do the quantile 0.25 percent
which should match um our 25 up here
and we'll be looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're
breaking this down for each uh
different variable in there one of the
things that's kind of
fun to do we're going to look at that in
just a second let me get
put the next piece of code in here clean
out some of our
we're going to drop a couple things our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles
so that's important it's important to
drop those rows in here and so this
right here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here we're going to do a little
bit more with this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows
we're going to go ahead and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll just
create a q1 q3 min max
min iqr max iqr and calculate the
quantile of
i of df2 we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart that's all this is
and this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual
if this was my own project i would
probably spend days and days
going through what these different
values mean
one of the biggest data science
things we can look at that's important
is use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3
so we've broken it down we have our q1
5.88 q3 10.37
if we go back up here here's our 5 8
we've
rounded it off 10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr
and that's computed let's see where is
it here we go
uh q1 minus 1.5 times iqr
and the iqr is your q3 minus q1 so
that's the difference between our two
different
quarters and this is all data science
as far as the hard math we're really not
we're actually trying to focus on cross
and tensorflow
you still got to go through all this
stuff i told you eighty percent
of your programming is going through and
understanding
what the heck uh happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so
when we're looking in that we're going
to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and they usually in this case is going
to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing
low outliers found minimum value high
outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes
you do this project just to find the
outliers because you want to know
crime detection what are we looking for
we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal
and then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness
so we have if your max is greater than
iqr
print outlier is found what we want to
do is we want to start cleaning up these
outliers
and so we want to convert we'll do
create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max underscore iqr min
iqr equals mini qr
so this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in
python and if x is greater than the max
iqr
and x is less than the min iqr x
equals null we're going to set it to
null
why because we want to clear these
outliers
out of the data now again if you're
doing fraud detection you would do the
opposite
you would be cleaning everything else
that's not in that
series so you can look at just the
outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the
nand hum again we have x max iqr is 100
min iq r is min iqr if x is greater than
max iqr
and x is less than mini q r again we're
going to return
a null value otherwise it's going to
remain the same
value x x equals x and you can see
as we go through the code if i equals
our hum then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column uh then we're
going to go ahead and convert
do the run a map on there and convert
the non
hum you can see here it's this is just
clean up
uh we run we found out that humidity
probably has some weird values in it
uh we have our outliers um
that's all this is and so when we go
ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers and
we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06 outliers have been
interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are
these days when you're looking at
something like these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate let the linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
uh same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate
that's what we're doing again this is
all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um we ran through this you can see down
here that we have
our outliers found
high low outliers migrated them in
we also know there's other issues going
on with this data
how do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on
let's take the temp value and we're
going to go ahead and and
use a logarithmic function on the temp
value
and it's interesting because it's like
how do you how do you heck do you even
know to use
logarithmic on the temp value that's
domain
specific we're talking about being an
expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not
what i go look at i don't look at air
care data in fact this is probably the
first air care data set up i've looked
at but the experts come in there and
they come to you and say hey in data
science
this is a exponentially variable
variable on here so we need to go ahead
and do
transform it and use a logarithmic scale
on that so at that point that would be
coming from
your data here we go
data science programmer overview does a
lot of stuff connecting the database and
connecting in with the experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who
is a data analysis might be all the way
usually a phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care this needs to be
this is a skew because the data just
goes up exponentially and affects
everything
else and we'll go ahead and take that
data
let me just go ahead and run this just
for another quick look at it
we have our uh we'll do a distribution
df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the
log temp so we can put them side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df
there's our data frames this is nice
because it just integrates the histogram
right into
pandas love pandas and this is a chart
you would send back to your data
analysis
and say hey is this what you wanted this
is how the data is converting on here
as a data scientist scientist the first
thing i note is we've gone from a 10
20 30 uh scales at 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there
so let's jump into we're getting a
little closer to actually doing
our cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists you want to have a training
set and a test set
uh and we'll go ahead and do the train
size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error
and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set
and then we can simply do train comma
test here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values split it's a nice split
of 1298 and then 433 points of value
that are going to be for our setup on
here
and if you remember we're specifically
looking at the data set where did we
create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic
value of the temp that's where the data
set came from
so we're looking at just that column
with this train size and the test
with the train and test data set here
and let's go ahead and do uh
convert an array of values into a data
set matrix
we're going to create a little setup in
here we create our data set our data
set's going to come in
we're going to do a look back of one so
we're going to look back one piece of
data going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i
and range length of data set look back
-1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data and
take a look at the shape of it
uh let me go ahead and just put that
code in here so we're going to do a
lookbeck one here's our train x our
train
y and it's going to be adding the data
on there
and then when we come up here and we
take a look at the shape
there we go and we run this piece of
code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different
change on here but we have a shape of x
1296 comma
1 shape of y train y test
x text y and so what we're looking at
is that the x comes in
and we're only having a single value out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for
what are we looking for well we want to
look back one that's the
what we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says hey
the humidity was at 97 percent
what should today's humidity be at if
it's 97 yesterday
is it going to go up or is it going to
go down today of 97 does it go up to 100
what's going on there uh and so our
we're looking forward to the next piece
of data which says hey tomorrow's is
going to you know today's humidity is
this
this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be that's all that is
all that is is stacking our data so that
our
y is basically x plus 1
or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x
data we're only dealing with the one
column but you
need to have it in a shape that has it
by the columns so you have the two
different numbers
and since we're doing just a single
point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory
layer so we're going to add another
reshape on here let me just go down here
and put it into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time
step features we're only looking at one
feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error
in the numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on
uh so we're going to do is we're going
to add one more level on here instead of
being 12.99 one
we want to go one more and when they
put the code together in the back you
can see we kept the same shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape
one and this could have depends again on
how far back in the long short term
memory you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is
and you can see the new shape is now one
1299 one one versus the 1299
one and then the other part of the shape
432 one one
again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test
x and then our y is just a single column
because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for so now
we've done our 80 percent
um you know that's all the the writing
all the code reformatting our data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model
and we'll do this sequential model and
if you remember
sequential means it just goes in order
that means we have if you have two
layers
the layers go from layer one to layer
two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together we're
doing just sequential on here
and then we decided to do the long short
term
memory and we have our input shape
which it comes in again this is what all
this switching was we could have easily
made this
one two three or four going back as far
as the
end number on there we just stuck to
going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from what kind of
models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add
a dense model and if you remember from
the very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm
now just about every tensorflow model
uses
dents your dense model is your basic
forward propagation uh reverse
propagation error
or it does reverse propagation to
program the model
uh so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this
is the long short term memory is a
little different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where
do you find these models what kind of
models do you have available and
so for that let's go to the cross
website
which is the cross dot io if you go
under api
slash layers and i always have to do a
search
just search for karas api layers
it'll open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable
weights all kinds of stuff like there
your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates
relu which is like your smaller arrays
or if you're doing convolutional
neural networks the convolution usually
uses a relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft mac
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those
are set up and what we want to do is we
want to go ahead
and if you scroll down here you'll see
your core layers and here is your dense
layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing
uh image categorizing uh so trying to
find
objects in a picture that kind of thing
uh we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually you bring them down into a
single layer
although you can still do like global
max pulling 3d and there is just
i mean this list just goes on and on
there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on uh long
short term memory is a big one because
this is when we start talking about
text uh what if someone says the
what comes after the uh the cat and the
hat
a little kid's book there it starts
programming it and so you really want to
know
not only what's going on but it's going
to be something that has a history the
history behind it
tells you what the next one coming up is
now once
we've built all our different you know
we built our model we've added our
different layers we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together
if you do a the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming
linear regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which will use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing
and just like any of these different
prediction models if you've been doing
any scikit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model so what are we doing in
here we're going to
send in our train x our train y um we're
going to decide how many epochs we're
going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this i'm
guessing it'd probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size so how many different uh
when you
process it this is the math behind it if
you're in data analytics
um you might try to know what this
number is as a data scientist where i
haven't had the
phd level math that says this is why you
want to use this particular batch size
you kind of play with this number a
little bit um you can dig deeper into
the math
see how it affects the results depending
on what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2.
i'd have to actually look that up to
tell you what verbose means i think
that's actually the default on there if
i remember correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it the big ones are your
epic and your bat size those are what
we're looking for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times through all the data
so if you have a huge data set this is
the point
where you're kind of wondering oh my
gosh is this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera
terabyte of data going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500
iterations but yeah a terabyte of data
we're talking something closer to
days week um you know even with
a uh 3.5 gigahertz machine and
in eight cores it's still going to take
a long time to go through a full
terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple processors and multiple
computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere
so we really didn't need to go through a
full 500 epics
uh you know if you're retraining the
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to note where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing
of course if you're going to build a
model we want to go ahead and run a
prediction on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set and our test set or that
we have the train x and the train
y for training it or train predict and
then we have our test x
and our test y going in there uh so we
can test to see how good it did
uh when we come in here we have you'll
see right here we go ahead and do our
train predict equals
model predict train x and test predict
model predict
test x why would we want to run the
prediction on train x
well it's not a hundred percent on its
prediction we know it has a certain
amount of error and we want to compare
the error we have on what we programmed
it with
with the error we get when we run it on
new data that's never seen the model's
never seen before
and one of the things we can do we go
ahead and invert the predictions
this helps us level it off a little bit
more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals an np
exponential m1 the train predict and
then train
y equals the exponential m1 for train y
and then we do the again that with train
test predict and test
y um again reformatting the data so that
we can it all matches
and then we want to go ahead and
calculate the root mean square error
so we have our train score uh which is
your math square root times the mean
square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just
feeding the data through so we can
compare it and the same thing with the
test
and let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see we're doing
but the answer really helps to zoom in
so we have a
train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error and we
have a test score of 3.16 of the root
mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is
better than our training score then
we've over trained
something's really wrong at that point
you got to go back and figure out what
you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training
data and that's why we put them both
through that's why we look at the error
for both the training and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model
it's the test score that you're showing
people this is what it did on my test
data that the model had never seen
before
this is how good my model is and a lot
of times you actually want to put
together like a little
formal code where we actually want to
print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i have to go back and we're up here
if you remember we did the square means
error this is standard deviation that's
why these numbers are different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go
with that uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there we
want to go ahead and plot what's going
on
and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on
when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not works with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise
and so at this point we really want to
put it in a graph so we have something
to display
and with displaying you remember that
we're looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting
we have our train predict plot np
empty leg data set train predict plot
uh set it up with uh null values
yeah you know it's just kind of it's
kind of a weird thing where we're
creating the um
the data groups as we like them and then
putting the data in there is what's
going on here
uh so we have our train predict plot uh
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back we're just is going to
equal train
uh train predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it
so now we have our nice train predict
plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops
looks like i put it in here double
no it's just a yeah they put it in here
double
didn't mean to do that we really only
need to do it once
oh here we go this is where the problem
was
is because this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here
and then the test predict we're going to
look at that same thing we're just
creating those two
data sets uh test predict plot
length prediction set up on there and
then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions
so we have a time axis always nice to
have your time set on there
set that to the time array time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom
and then we have a lot of stuff going on
here as far as setting up
our figure let's go ahead and run that
and then we'll break it down
we have on here our main plot we have
two different plots going on here the
ispu going up and the data and the ispu
here
with all these different settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here
so we're doing a figure plt or
plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there and so we take
and if you go through the code piece by
piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly
we're going to label it the original
data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot
that's what we just created we're going
to make that orange
and we'll label it train prediction uh
test predicts plot we're gonna make that
red and label it test prediction
and so forth um set our ticks up this
actually just put ticks
time axes gets its ticks little little
marks there going along the axis that
kind of thing
and let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue here's
our
training prediction you can see that it
trains pretty close to what the data is
up there
i would also probably put a like a
little
little time stamp and do just right
before and right after
where we go from train to test
prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this
is is just the test prediction on the
right
uh and it's you know there's you'll see
with the original data set
there's a lot of peaks were missing and
a lot of lows were missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty
does pretty good it's pretty right on
you can get a good idea what to expect
for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error
that's the kind of thing i put out on a
daily basis maybe we predict the cells
are going to be this or maybe a weekly
so you kind of get a nice you kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big
takeaway from this is that we're working
with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through
all of those pieces all the tensorflows
and that is to build this sequential
model
and we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated
if you get too complicated it never it
never verges into a usable model so if
you have like 30 different layers in
here
there's a good chance you might crash it
kind of thing so don't go too haywire on
that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in
and say this is what we want to try but
i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu
activation i worked for two weeks to
figure that out
well as a data science i can run it
through the model
in you know five minutes instead of
spending two weeks doing the the math
behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side
and a data analytics is going to look
for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of
tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently
and of course with any data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders
again we want to take and reduce
the information down to something people
can look at and say oh
that's what's going on they can see
stuff what's going on as far as the
dates and the change in the ispu
hello guys welcome to yet another video
by simply learn
i am keef tana and today we shall be
talking about the top 10
artificial intelligence technologies
before getting into the video
here's a gentle reminder to subscribe to
our channel
and hit the bell icon so that you
wouldn't miss any update from us
so without further ado let's quickly
jump into the topic
in the list we have natural language
generation
smart devices virtual agents
speech recognition augmented reality
machine learning robotic process
automation
decision management deep learning
and finally image recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently
is very much crucial in communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence
to convey the message clearly humans
often find it tricky
and when it comes to machines it's
trickier
natural language generation is a sub
discipline of
artificial intelligence and is a trendy
technology that
converts the structured data into a
native language
the machines are programmed in such a
way
that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service
report generation and summarizing
business intelligence
insights some of the sample vendors
are a tvo automated insights
sas cambridge semantics digital
reasoning
narrative science etc
on the list next we have smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using once
upon a time
are now remodeled and modified as smart
devices they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency
and optimize the operations smart
devices
are everyday objects made intelligent
with advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect
share and interact with its users and
other smart devices
some of the smart devices are smart
watches
smart glasses smartphones smart speakers
etc virtual agents
they are computer generated intelligence
that provides
online customer assistance they can
effectively communicate with humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications
we see chatbots as customer service
agents
who interact with us answering our
queries
in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology
which aims to create an effective but
digital impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment place an order
and can even avail product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents
are google assistant and amazon alexa
and the companies that provide virtual
agents are
microsoft google amazon
and assist ai
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another sub
discipline of artificial
intelligence which is used to convert
human speech into a comprehensive
and useful format for computer
applications to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and
humans it's presently used on
interactive voice response systems
and mobile applications some of the
companies
offering speech recognition services are
nuanced communications
open text nice and variant systems
augmented reality yet another trendy
technology in the field of artificial
intelligence
augmented reality is an enhanced version
of the real
physical world that is achieved using
sound
digital visual elements and other
sensory stimuli
delivered via technology augmented
reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment
it alters the perception of the real
world environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores
that make makeup selection and
furnishing
much more fun and interactive if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
machine learning machine learning is an
application
and an important branch of artificial
intelligence
which refers to machines being able to
learn by themselves
without being explicitly programmed it
enables systems to learn
and improve from experience
automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms
apis big data and applications and
training tools
enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning
to reap its benefits for the various
domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization
and prediction some of the sample
vendors
are amazon fractal analytics
google microsoft etc
robotic process automation configuring a
robot to interpret communicate
and analyze data is robotic process
automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human
actions which in turn supports efficient
business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas
where the physical presence of a human
is dangerous
fields like warfare mining etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence
is not meant to replace humans but
instead
it is to complement their abilities and
reinforce human talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation
are pika systems automation anywhere
blue prism etc next on the list we have
decision management decision management
is yet another technology in artificial
intelligence
that helps companies make valid
decisions
by providing up-to-date and relevant
information and performing
analytic functions artificial
intelligence
when combined with decision management
helps translate customer data into
predictive models
of key trends it also helps in making
quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector
financial sector insurance sector
e-commerce and many more some of the
companies that provide this service
are informatica advanced systems
concepts
pica systems mana etc
deep learning deep learning is a branch
of artificial intelligence
that mimics the workings of the human
brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes
like recognizing speech detecting
objects
translating languages and making
decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks
for carrying out the process of machine
learning which is used across several
industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
instinct
fluid ai math works saffron technology
etc at last we have
image recognition image recognition is
process of detecting an
object or feature in a digital image or
video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions
verify users based on their faces detect
license plates
and diagnose diseases the present-day
image recognition is comparable to human
visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and aid visually impaired
users
clarify gums and sensetime provide this
technology
thank you all for watching this full
course video tutorial on artificial
intelligence
i hope you liked it if you have any
questions then please feel free to put
them in the comment section
our team will help you solve your
queries thank you for watching and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here